it's a no
from the hearing with the adjourned
resume the adjourned hearing
on house bill 1369 relative to covet 19
health and safety policies at new
hampshire performing arts venues
substituting for representative wilhelm
who is prime sponsor is a co-sponsor
representative canark
okay
yes um i got a phone call from the prime
sponsor representative matt wilhelm
um as i was driving down that his
youngest is sick and he's staying home
with her
and asked me to pinch it for him i was
planning to testify anyway
um first off i had a little moment of
dyslexia with the number of what i
passed around if it still says 1639 that
is an error i tried to correct it by
hand on all of yours to be 1369
and i
my testimony will be mine with
some snippets of representative
wilhelm's in as well
so uh what
uh
and there's also an amendment which is
being passed around at this moment as
well which i'll come to later on i've
just gotten an email from him and so i'm
doing a little bit of multitasking here
what 1639 does is it provides the
performing arts venues in new hampshire
have the authority to establish their
own
coveted health and safety policies it
does not mandate these policies it
remains a choice of the business as to
what policies they wish to have
performing arts venues really operate on
really thin margins
so they really cannot afford to
significantly decrease their capacity to
be able to maintain social distancing or
they just simply can't
can't function
so utilization of other mitigation
strategies such as
improved ventilation masking testing
and or vaccination requirements will
safely allow them to lessen social
distancing
and therefore increase capacity in order
for them to survive financially
a november 26 2021 article on lansa
demonstrated in a randomized controlled
trial
the participation in large indoor
gatherings
without physical distancing
did not result in an increase of coveted
transmission to the attendees
when a multi-layered risk mitigation
strategy of ventilation upgrades
mandatory medical mask grade wearing
medical grade and mask wearing and a
mandatory pre-admission antigen
screening was used
so what hb 1639 does is it will allow
new hampshire performing arts venues
as a business decision
to implement protocols of masking
testing and or vaccination requirements
for patrons in order to improve the
safety of patrons and employees
they are businesses and should be
allowed to implement protocols
for employee and patron safety
if desired again this does not mandate
they must do this it gives them a choice
as a business
also
these protocols could really be a
marketing
opportunity for the venue
a venue may choose to advertise that
they can that they implement such
protocols
to set them apart as a venue which cares
for the safety of patrons and employees
and many patrons may feel more
comfortable attending a performance when
they know their safety
is being considered
remember that about 68 68 percent of new
hampshire residents have been vaccinated
that means the majority would like to be
safe
the venues should be allowed to market
their commitment to safety
to that majority of individuals who have
demonstrated they care
about their safety and this mattered
certainly i know to me and to some
friends of mine going over to still
martin art center in maine who did have
mask requirements then a vaccine mandate
that you'd feel more comfortable going
there
back when things were a little quieter
now it also suggests that you would
review the testimony
that was sent out back when this bill
was originally scheduled do remember
this was scheduled before which is why
you may have two copies of my testimony
because i distribute it but i did it
again today because if you're like many
of us it might got lost in the shuffle
but bill marsh about that time had uh
emailed his testimony and remember he
served on the governor's economic
reopening task force and worked on the
protocols for performing arts venues so
he's got a unique view
now what uh the prime sponsors
conveyed to me
uh is that after finding this bill there
was a great deal of concern
about the language
in
lines eight
through
ten
which says that any person acting in
good faith to administer or enforce
at performing venues covered 19 health
and safety policy shall be immune from
civil liability arising from such
conduct
the legislative intention of that
was that a
employee would not be sued because they
asked a person to
demonstrate proof of vaccination before
being admitted so as to protect them
not from medical issues or anything else
but simply to protect them from
being
sued for
implementing the policy
but there was a lot of blowback and
there's apparently been no cases of any
that have been brought in this
and as a result the sponsor feels that
uh the immunity language may have been a
little bit too broad
might be able to be used as a general
liability shield that had been expressed
to him as after filing the bill
and
therefore
um
if they for example if a promoter i'm
gonna i'm reading from his email on my
apologies because i did not get a chance
to process this if a concert promoter
asserted that its policy was that they
don't require masks they jam people into
a venue unsafely and act negligent
negligent in theirs
negligently and there are infections
might somebody try to use that language
as a shield well that doesn't make any
sense either
so the bottom line is that he has
given an amendment which
i did not have hands on until just this
a little while ago it's been passed
around which is a replace all for
section one and what it does is it just
removes
the language of lines 8 through 10 about
the liability he's perfectly happy with
that
lastly is he had a conversation with
abby rogers of dhhs
and dhhs feels that this probably should
not be placed in statute 141c16
because it's that it shouldn't be in the
communicable disease statute but instead
in some
statutory reference in commerce but we
all know in this committee we've dealt
with multiple
uh changes that need to be made for
statutory low f statutory home and so we
can certainly deal with that but we'd
have to figure out where it would belong
so with that i'd be glad to take any
questions
would you need to
uh
bring an amendment to us to change the
statutory reference before we
exact okay yes apparently this was uh
this conversation had occurred
relatively recently and we do not yet
know
so although we do have this amendment if
we are going to change the location and
i do not know if dhhs plans to testify
for clarity um but any maybe they could
if they wish to do so but in any case we
would then want to draft a new amendment
to be able to take care of that
uh to answer your question
representative canaric the honorable
gentleman behind you is armed with a
pink card and looks like he's about
ready to use it so yes and uh since
getting me nervous here
i've got your back
yes
if if you if if the testimony goes that
way
could you prepare that amendment to
change the statutory reference
soon so we can move this one along of
course thank you
any any other questions for the
presenter
thank you representative
chair recognizes peter ramsey
who is in support of the bill
thank you very much mr chairman
um i'm very proud to be here members of
the committee um
i was a member of this legislature for
30 years starting at age 21 and i know
some of you so it's good to be back
even though i did not spend much time in
this room i spent a lot of time in
appropriations if you remember before in
the old days and
years and years and in public works
so i will speak for one minute and then
i'm happy to answer any questions i have
the honor of
running the palace cedar in manchester
new hampshire downtown manchester new
hampshire and before the pandemic
we averaged 200 000 patrons a year
and and
brought in about uh
five or six million dollars and uh
uh was very very busy uh in march of of
uh uh tooth that was in 2019.
um
uh all right we were in the middle of a
sold-out uh run of five weeks of mamma
mia which is if you haven't seen it you
need to go see it it's a great show and
uh
we had four hundred thousand dollars in
pre-sales which is a good thing for us
and uh um and i got a call at 12 o'clock
on a friday afternoon from the mayor of
the city of manchester saint peter
there's a pandemic
and uh could you close and i said i
don't want to close
and uh
it's as everyone in this room knows
the palace was then closed
after that for about 15 months it cost
us about 7.5 million dollars um
we laid off about 50 artists
of all sorts of types and
so um i had spoken representative
wilhelm who's my representative now
and um
a bunch of us in the theater business
across new hampshire
there are 14
historic uh performing arts centers in
new hampshire and there are about 50
performing arts centers all sorts of uh
from 100 seats up to
uh
up to snhu arena which had 10 000 seats
so about 60 total ones every one is
different and uh they're all run
differently and i think today you're
going to hear from two operators one in
uh two in concord one in claremont and
they will all tell you different stories
but the point of it is
that every
every act that comes into the palace
that we hire uh
for example wednesday night we have
the the famous um uh
perhaps the most famous person in new
hampshire seth meyers
is coming to the palace theater
wednesday night we are sold out and he
has said to me
well i'm proud to come i'm proud to
perform
but i would like everybody in the venue
to have a mask
so i say well i'd love to have you come
and i will ask everyone to be there the
challenge as you all know is how do you
enforce it i do not want to be a police
officer so i go up to people and say can
you please put your mask on and they say
go to hell ramsay and i say thank you
very much and if they're obnoxious i'll
call the police
but it's it's really been very difficult
but it's almost illogical to think that
we as a society want performing arts
centers in our state and
and not allow them to run the venues how
they have to run them
and economically it makes a tremendous
difference the palace theater generates
about 10 million dollars a year in
economic activity downtown it's real
money that goes to to salaries to
restaurants
to lawyers
there are 10 restaurants within one
block of the palace theater
it's a tremendous economic activity we
need our performing arts centers to
operate the capital center for the arts
it's a wonderful institution we need it
in concord and the new one in nashua
is going to change downtown nashua
immediately and we need to let them run
how they should run so i could go on for
hours i will not
thank you very much for serving the
state of new hampshire i'm proud to be
back with you again i'm happy to answer
any questions thank you mr chairman
oh you had me until you said it was sold
out
and then my follow-up would have been is
there a ticket for less than 24.99
yeah yeah
but that's moot any questions
huh thank you mr chair thank you
chair recognizes john williams who
wishes to provide some information
chairman pearson and members of the
health human services elderly affairs
committee good morning i'm john williams
the legislative director for the
department of health human services and
here today on behalf of miss abby rogers
and i just wanted to provide you with
the thought in terms of statutory
placement the
currently it is housed under 141c our
recommendation would be to to
create and establish a new chapter a
chapter
359 dash uppercase t to follow current
existing um chapter
359 dash
r rt or rs ss rather just have to do the
alphabet a little more carefully on a
monday morning
and our suggestion is because that falls
under the titles that deal with commerce
uh clearly performing arts centers do a
wonderful job but they should not be
regulated by the department of health
and services and our suggestion would be
to placing it under the commerce statute
in a more cleaner
place if this bill were to go forward
that completes our commentary on the
bill and thank you for your time thank
you sir
chair recognizes laura
condon from bedford
good morning chairman pearson
and committee members i appreciate the
opportunity to be here today
i am laura condon i'm from bedford new
hampshire i'm a volunteer new hampshire
director of advocacy with the national
vaccine information center
we are a re resource educational and
advocacy
nonprofit
and we serve to assist those who have
concerns about vaccines or vaccine
policies
including legislative matters i'm here
today to testify in opposition of this
bill
i am pleased to hear representative
come forward with an amendment that
would remove
the provision for
immunity from liability of course that
was one of my concerns
any time an employer who imposes a
mandate on employees must be held
accountable and liable for any and all
harm that results from their mandate
they don't get to cause an injury or
death to others without consequence
and so there should be liability and
there there would be and
whether or not there is a provision in
law to mandate these vaccines we have
some seen some employers
excuse me take it upon themselves to
mandate coveted shots in indeed um they
are not protected from immunity they
have no immunity from liability under
the prep act um and they have no
immunity from liability under the 1986
national childhood vaccine injury act um
when they impose vaccine mandates of
their own volition they do assume
liability for that and i urge any
employees that are injured by such
employ
uh mandates to please file their workers
compensation claim and know that they
would have civil liability
these vaccines are not without risk and
harm
to look up in the
vaccine safety database
used by the cdc in the fda we see that
there have been reported over 23 000
deaths following coveted shots or 124
hospitalizations of
116 000 urgent care
the list goes goes on and on so we do
know that people can be injured by these
shots i do know that this bill provides
no provision for any exemptions for
medical reasons religious reasons or
personal reasons
in addition there is no and there could
be you know people such as you know
women that are are pregnant um that
don't wish to be vaccinated wish to
protect their their unborn baby from
harm from vaccines so there's a whole
variety of reasons why someone might
wish to certain exemption this bill
makes no provision for that
um
and in that way it is discriminatory
against those who um would choose to
protect themselves from vaccines for
whatever reason and the bill also does
not contain any provision for natural
immunity against coven 19 despite the
overwhelming evidence of natural
immunity being equal to or better than
vaccination so makes no provision for
that
and
i will note that it recently came up in
the news that um you know when you look
at workplace mandates it was an indiana
life insurance company
that reported that deaths are up some 40
amongst working people ages 18 to 64.
and they noted that these are not
covades
disabilities are also up in the short
term and now long term
so we need to be aware that these
vaccines are not not without risk and i
urge you to please recommend this bill
as inexpedient to legislate
thank you
representative merchant
thank you mr chairman also thank you for
taking my question
how is
requirement it doesn't say you have to
be vaccinated it just says you have to
have either a test you have to have a
mask or other things to do to protect
the performers
how is this different than an employer
saying if you don't have a shirt i don't
have shoes on you can't come into my
establishment how is that different oh
that's really easy
a shirt and shoes
is something that um you could put on
and take off and it has no
no abs no adverse effect
to um wearing a shirt or shoes you know
i don't see that there's any sort of
shirt and shoes um data safety program
to to monitor the adverse effects and
the deaths of wearing shirts and shoes
vaccines are quite different
we do know that vaccines do sicken
disable and kill
representative weber
thank you mr chairman and thank you very
much ms condon for taking my question
my question is
do you see
the rights
just as
you argue for the rights of those who
choose not to be vaccinated
do you not concede
that
there are other people in this state who
do not agree with you
and just as
you should be able to choose not to get
vaccinated
other people might need
might want to choose
to patronize events
at which they feel safe
just as you feel unsafe
with a vaccination
shouldn't those who have a different
choice made in their lives
have the choice
to
choose to patronize an establishment
that has established policies that they
are comfortable with
thank you for the question and i do
recognize that there is a difference of
opinions on this issue very much so
recognize that
but i follow the science
and
the science shows that covid vaccines
do carry risks they carry risk of
illness disability and death
the science also shows that these
coveted shots were never designed to
prevent infection or prevent spread to
the patrons sitting next to you at the
theater
they were designed from the get-go and i
do attend the advisory committee on
immunization practice meetings those are
live webinars anybody can watch those
and it was discussed from the from the
get-go and the manufacturers volunteered
themselves and you will find it on the
manufacturer's
fact sheet that they provide with these
ua shots is that these vaccines are not
designed to prevent infection they're
designed to reduce symptoms similar to
someone who might take say nyquil for a
cold
someone taking a shot to reduce their
illness symptoms in no way impacts the
patrons sitting next to them at the
theater thank you very much for your
question and the opportunity to address
it
i have a question i'm a sometime
performing artist
and
if i chose
to give an organ recital again
that would be my choice
if peop and if i set policies as to
the people coming to my organ recital or
if the facility for which i'm giving an
organ recital chose to do it the sad
truth
is going to an organ recital is not a
necessity of life
you know that bothers me but it's true
but there are places that are
and
i think this conversation in my opinion
would belong in those places that are
necessities of life
if you want to go to an organ recital
because of the terms the church or
concert hall are setting that's on you
if you don't want to go that's on you
and i've had to wrestle with this
because there's a possibility of me
again giving a recital and would i be
comfortable doing that or not it is
sadly not a necessity of life so my
question is
is the testimony against this bill
better directed towards only those
places that are necessities of life
thank you for the question and and i
agree that performing arts venues are
not a necessity of life and um it
strikes my heart the same way it does
you so because i am a music fan as well
so um but you know those who wish to um
and feel they need to
and believe it it would keep them safe
that there's no requirement that they
attend those performances so i do agree
with you um on that point so you
your question is
if i can understand it correctly is that
you you would seek to impose a vaccine
requirement on
other
facilities that are a requirement
to be there that is not my intent okay
my intent is simply to carve out
non-necessities of life
and therefore is it not
the right
for the people
performing for the performing
venue people and for the attenders to
decide which they want to do
well i do believe in choice and if
you're if you're asking if i believe
people should be able to decide for
themselves yes i guess i'm still unclear
on your question
what you would be carving out
i'm not sure what an essential business
is i mean i can assure you that
everybody employed at the the palace
theater um believes that their job is
essential to them it pays their their
bills it puts a roof over their head it
puts food on their table and provides
for their children so i think they would
very much
see that their job is essential
any other questions
representative gay
thank you for taking my question
it's kind of
i'm trying to boil it down would you
have a problem with this bill
if
vaccine requirements were struck
because
that would still allow requiring the
mask requiring tests but
yes i shouldn't give my opinion i want
to know what yours is
and that was a good point about it's
pretty essential to the people who work
there and certainly
i'm guessing that they would not want to
put restrictions on that would reduce
their audience
right
um
so your question is is you know is is
this a bill i would still object to if
they they took out on the provision
of vaccines and and you know allowed
employers to impose any other
requirements i suppose mask distancing
i don't i don't know what they you know
hand washing
you know hand washing is a good thing
i'm not going to object to that one um
you know whatever that they'll say they
might impose um
you know again and i think it was um mr
ramsey who spoke to this um there is no
enforcement mechanism here i still think
it puts businesses in the same position
and i don't object to that if a business
would prefer that people wear masks and
socially distance i don't object to
those signs that say we recommend we
would like you to
um that's that's a polite request and i
i don't object to those
but um i think you know to
put it into law i i think still puts
these business owners and and patrons
and employees still in an awkward
position thank you for the question
seeing no further questions thank you
very much thank you chair recognizes
rusin chester
thank you committee chair thank you
committee members um
i um
on the good news is i feel our public
arts
public performing places is an essential
responsibility if we look at what's
happened to our society just with
regards to depression and things like
that music fills the soul
music makes you want to go wake up the
next day so i would argue that our
public our performing arts centers are
essential they're essential to our
health mental health and well-being um
that being said um
i understand the intent of this bill and
i respect it
however the bottom line is this bill is
a further form of discrimination against
the citizens of the un the unvaccinated
versus the vaccinated discrimination is
discrimination regardless
i am
unvaccinated because i am vaccine
injured i cannot take the vaccine at
this time so i may not be able to go
someplace and it's happened it's
happened more than once
so that's discrimination um with regards
to testing i have tested four times
because of the job that i had
every time within a six-month period i
tested positive for covert 19. these
tests are not accurate so the fact that
you put a testing requirement in here
i will never be able i may never be able
to go to a performing arts venue again
um
uh you spoke you asked questions with
regards to
um
seth meyers coming to the palace the
good news is there's still 27 seats
available
the bad news is they don't come anywhere
near 30 under 30 dollars
um
and that being said there are a number
of people who
have now been told that seth meyers is
requesting a mask
to be at his performance to be at his
performance you must wear a mask there
are now over um on his website there are
now
152 complaints saying they want their
money they want to be refunded because
they're not going to they're not going
to um
to they choose not to spend their money
on an artist that is going to put those
kind of implementations on them so that
is a perfect example right there it's
freedom of choice
i was one of those persons that spent
125 dollars for a ticket to see seth
meyers wednesday night
i chose i will choose to not go
even if i can't sell my ticket
and that's what freedom of choice is
about
now the only other thing is i do agree
that private businesses should be able
to make their own private decisions for
what's best for their
business and for what's best for their
um for their establishment however
if they receive any kind of public
funding whatsoever
they should not be able to put in
special
so
i am not a hundred percent opposed to
this
other than the vaccine issue um
but
if they i will choose not to
um attend any performance that requires
masking social or not social disc
probably not even masking i will choose
not to attend any event that requires
vaccines or vaccine passports or vaccine
testing because i know ultimately i will
fail
and i don't know if you folks are like
me but i don't like to fail so i will
just choose not to participate
thank you very much any questions
would you choose to take away seth
meyer's right to choose
absolutely not
and seth meyers like i said my issue
is the fact that he's not taking public
money to perform he can choose
thank you but the palace theater if
they're taking public funding they
should not be able to put a policy in
place that's all i'm saying thank you
very much
the chair recognizes salvatore prisio
from the capital center for the arts i
hope i got the name right
good morning chairman pearson and
members of the committee
my name is salvatore prizio from the
capital center for the arts i have been
a citizen of new hampshire now for
nine weeks so
yes and this is the first time i'm
speaking in front of a committee so
forgive me for any faux pas that i do
here
um i do have some prepared remarks um
but one of the things i do want to say
at the outset is i want everybody to
consider this from a macro standpoint as
opposed to the micro standpoint of just
what we're dealing with in this room
on a day-to-day basis my colleagues and
i deal with agents that are in
california new york nashville tennessee
i mean all over the country
they have artists of varying degrees of
restrictions and safety protocols that
they put in place on us to a certain
extent now all of us at our performing
arts centers try to do the best that we
can do to protect the people that come
into our spaces but sometimes it is an
outside force that is asking us to put
restrictions in place
if we are not allowed to
put any of the restrictions in place
that the artists are having
ask us to do
essentially what you would have happen
is an entertainment i don't want to call
it a boycott but
you would have a lot of artists avoiding
the state of new hampshire because we
aren't allowed to put in place some of
the safety protocols they're asking us
to do
do we agree with all of them it depends
it depends on your performing arts
center it depends on the rates of
infection in your area
it's the reason why
we want to have the ability
of ourselves to make the decisions look
none of us in the performing arts
business want to be in the medical field
i didn't do this i didn't become a i
didn't get my md degree
or anything like that to
you know sit up here and and have
conversations about medical practices
but this is the reality of the position
that we're in and i can tell you
like again i've been on the job here
eight weeks
our entire january got wiped out because
of covid all right so zero dollars in
earned revenue over the capital center
for the arts so i have to deal with
those realities on a day-to-day basis
so
i'm having constant conversations with
representatives in our membership
committee
and the more safety protocols we put in
place the more people are feeling safe
to come out
if there's things that i can do in a
responsible manner
as much as possible to make people feel
safe in their spaces i'm going to do it
as long as it's legally viable
um
i also wanted to say uh we so like i
said we've lost 40 of that uh i should
say our ticket sales have been off 40
this year
so in the midst of a pandemic we're
trying to get back to doing the business
of what we do best which is entertaining
the people of the capital here
and to that end we performing arts
centers like the capital center for the
arts were knocked to their knees and
we're desperately trying to get back on
our feet so if there's any tools that we
can use at our disposal to allow us to
get back up on our feet we're struggling
so hard to do so and
we just want the rights
and the ability to put some of these
safety protocols in place
do we want them there forever absolutely
not who wants to go to a comedy show
with a mask on your face it's not ideal
but we're trying to do things we're
trying to fit square pegs and round
holes at the moment to get us through so
we can get to a place where we can all
take our masks off again and feel safe
i respect the rights of others and their
decisions that they want to make but i'm
trying to do what's best for the the
crowds that come into our space
um uh what i was gonna say uh
so after that and when
if we have those abilities it allows us
to kind of assess on a show-by-show
basis per the artist's request for the
safety of everybody that we have
involved i'm thank you in advance for
voting ought to pass on hb 1369 and
guaranteeing the arts businesses in the
granite state the ability to protect
their artists employees and audiences as
the way they see fit i'm happy to answer
any questions
representative king
i'll ask the same question that was
asked
before and that is would you support
this bill if
we removed the vaccine requirement
the problem with removing the vaccine
requirement is any artist that comes
into our space that has a vaccine
requirement attached to it now all of a
sudden we lose that artist we lose them
to to massachusetts we're going to lose
them to maine
vermont
you know all these other places i mean
look at the end of the day it's a
competitive market and we need to do
what we can do to be competitive within
that market
follow-up
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking these questions
so
um
i guess on a business sense do you agree
that this is
you're going after 68 of the market
since 32 percent of the people won't
come
i would say this i would say uh
within the you're saying you're looking
at that 68 and 32
as the entire total population
if i have to look at it as the people
who regularly attend
my performing arts center
those numbers are probably much bigger
than a 68 32 split
not to say that i would ever eliminate
the 32 percent
i just and you also have to keep in mind
too this is on a show by show basis over
at the the capitol center for the arts
we do have a mask mandate in place for
all of our shows right now
but something like you said like a
vaccine mandate again on a show-by-show
basis
uh there are shows that don't require a
vaccine mandate and those people who
refuse to who do not want to get the
vaccine are more than welcome to come to
those shows
thank you that helps yep
any other questions
thank you mr chairman uh thank you for
taking my question are you going to
advertise or have you already advertised
the artist's requirements
for every single show we have listed on
our website it has what that shows
requirements are
we always put that out in advance
um and the the patron is aware of that
in advance of purchasing their ticket
follow-up
uh would you possibly just figure that
as the policy goes
you will make decisions based on your
audience
i'm sorry can you clarify the question
there how can i say it uh
you're you're a business as well as
being an artist you have to be a
businessman and figure out how you're
going to pay for everything absolutely
so i'm i'm going to
guess and you can this is a question
yeah of course
will you
be flexible with your requirements as
you see how the audience responds if you
see a drop
in you know your breakeven number of
attendees
then i'm going to guess that you well of
course i mean any reassess your
requirements of course over time listen
as this pandemic you know subsides
hopefully someday um obviously we'll go
back in and review our our policies on
things and and when i got here it was a
mask optional and then we started
getting into the omicron variant and i i
modified it to be uh mask required
as the numbers drop and we get to a
place where we're safe for gatherings
again it'll go back to mask optional
again you know so it's like we have to
be we have to have the ability to adapt
to these things as we proceed
representative delemus
thank you mr chairman
i'm sorry thanks for taking my question
of course thank you
um
so
if you're able to
not mandate but require
a mask
for whatever performance they say seth
meyers comes in and says hey you've got
to be i want people vaccinated
can't you at this point just as well as
as
requiring masks for the performance
can't you just require at this point
vaccines and then the audience is you
know i i don't know
i'm sorry i'm a little confused about
that all right um so i think what you're
saying i think what you're saying is
should we just have a vaccine required
for every single show that we do no okay
so just uh just for your specific show
so so the example is seth myers comes in
says not only do i want masks but i want
people to be vaccinated so now you put
that on your site you say okay this
these are the requirements for this
particular show can you do that now
that's what we do that's what we do now
then i don't okay
great thank you thank you for that for
answering that question yeah of course
where did you come here from
uh schenectady new york
so you're used to snow oh yeah yeah okay
we actually have more sunny days here
than upstate new york so
put that on the website too
any other questions
thank you so much sir thank you all for
your time
the chair recognizes andrew pinard from
the hat box theater and claremont opera
house
handing out written testimony
little flare there just for you um thank
you uh chairman pearson and members of
the committee for the opportunity to
speak before you today i'm going to
follow my colleagues lead in the fact
that i have prepared testimony and
previously submitted a video package of
other
performance arts venue
operators who are not able to be here
today
i have had the great pleasure of making
new hampshire my home essentially my
entire life
i founded hatbox theater here in concord
in 2016 a little cooperative theater
venue and
as a result of the pandemic i had to
leave my full-time performance career of
30 years
and take
a position as the executive director of
the claremont opera house a
not-for-profit
uh venue that is in a municipal uh owned
building in claremont and
i've had the great opportunity over the
years to perform in over a thousand
venues throughout the northeast and i've
never seen anything like this um it's a
huge struggle for not only the venues
but the artists
and their families and the people who
work in the venues
that help to bring performances to
the their communities
over the last 22 months we've seen
significant declines in revenue and even
in operation at all some of our venues
were closed for seven months or more and
some of us have still operating with 70
to 90 percent earned revenue loss
the ability to make
prudent safety choices as businesses is
vital to our continued survival
um one of the biggest things is the
ability to be able to get people to come
out to a venue and while i am a firm
believer of supporting the individual's
right to choose
that choice is often
influenced
by the conditions on the ground whether
it's
the transmission rates at the time or
it's the safety procedures that are in
whatever location they wish to go if
they wish to go to the grocery store
they may choose to go to a grocery store
that
that requires masks as opposed to
encourages mass or that
god forbid one that doesn't have any
mask policy whatsoever and i think it's
important for the individuals to be able
to choose and they do that with their
feet
uh and i think that's important to note
that's why this is such an important
aspect of running performing arts venues
and while
i appreciate the argument or discussion
about whether the performing arts are a
necessity i'm not really going to get
into that because better points have
been raised
at this point but one thing that a lot
of people do not realize and this is why
we need your help
is that the public do not understand
the business of running a performing
arts venue most people think of a
business that they go and attend as
something like the grocery store where
they walk in they spend 15 minutes
loading their cart or 47 as my wife does
um
loading their cart and then they leave
it's a transactional experience where
people come in they do their business
and they leave performing arts venues
all we do and in our letter here is to
we share
story
sorry through experience and we do that
by sharing the same room and the same
space for a duration of time that
exceeds that
of most normal transactions that people
conduct business
um in their day-to-day lives
so
we have been impacted far greater in
lots of ways than many
other commercial organizations whether
you're not for profit or for a profit
organization we've had significant
impact and
as has been said we were among the first
to close and we're going to be the last
to reopen we are open but a lot of
people think that we're open just like
we were before because the grocery store
is open like they were before
the liquor store you can go and get your
liquor without a problem nothing has
appeared to change but the
type of experience
when people come to experience the
performing arts and have that cathartic
experience to learn something to feel
something and let's face it to
be exposed to the ex free exchange of
ideas
we don't have the town square anymore
that people walk into and they exchange
their ideas
the performing arts are one way for
people to be exposed to things that may
change their lives and the lives of
their families so at any rate i think i
would uh ask that you vote ought to pass
on house bill 1369 uh i truly appreciate
your interest and uh
we'll be happy to answer questions any
questions that may arise representative
kelsey
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
so just to clarify um we you you can
already require require all of these
measures correct
currently we base our decisions on what
happens on the ground in front of us the
biggest challenge as i alluded to is
that we need governmental support in
terms of
suggesting that this is an important and
necessity function of our business if
you say it is not
by not passing this you're in essence
telling our potential customers that we
don't have the right to make these
choices
follow-up okay so basically you want you
want this in statute as an enforcement
mechanism then
i would appreciate the
support that we have the capability of
doing this enforcement as we experienced
in the last 22 months has been a sticky
wicket
during when we had regulations that were
supposed to be enforced by the
government they were not and individual
businesses were left
on their own to attempt to
[Music]
enforce
regulations that were being given
through emergency orders and things of
that nature and there was mixed
messaging
to the community about what we're
allowed to do and what we were not
allowed to do which resulted in
confrontation
people who chose to come out to a
concert and use that as their
independent opportunity to create a
scene when that was not the purpose of
the event it was but because there was
no clear
support from the government saying that
this is well within the rights of their
businesses please let them conduct their
businesses i think that it's important i
would clarify that the language that's
in the bill however does give some
people the understanding that these
requirements all of these requirements
will be applied and i think the language
could be adjusted to include such safety
protocols as and that would leave it up
to the business it would not be a state
mandate of all or nothing i think that's
a very important distinction that may
help us wage some concerns of the public
in terms of enforcement
thank you
representative king
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
and i'm still hung up on the whole
vaccine thing
being in this bill
uh how would you
how would you police that number one
and number two
what if somebody has natural immunity
which we have heard earlier before is
sufficient
thank you i appreciate the question uh
and i'd actually like to respond to one
of your early questions as well
in terms of how we implement it now
the
our patrons are given different options
so if they choose not to be vaccinated
one of the options is they can show a
test that they're not communicable when
they arrive and there are a number of
different options that are provided so
it gives freedom of choice and it gives
a mechanism to ensure public confidence
to attend any particular event so i
would advocate for as many options as we
can provide the public to give them the
confidence to make that choice to
purchase their tickets
and then to follow up earlier
on your question as far as the vaccines
go again there are lots of studies that
will give you lots of different
perspectives on all of these we are
in in some ways living an experiment and
the numbers are bearing out the benefits
and
some of the challenges associated with
it but
as my colleague stated this is a macro
level concern for a business and not one
that we are interested in taking a stand
on or
becoming a a source of contention when
all we're trying to do is conduct our
business representative gay
did you have your hand up
i thought so
i'm impressed
thank you
thank you for taking my question have
y'all ever attempted to put together cdc
guidelines and inform
your
performers because some of these
requests are totally refuted by
cdc conclusions well i appreciate that
opportunity
uh to answer that yes in fact we do
share on a regular basis what current
cdc requirements or recommendations are
with our audiences with our employees
and with the outside contracted
entertainment that come in the
performers
that being said it's it's a difference
between what individual
responses are in terms of whether they
are vaccinated and what is comfortable
for a group
to be able to make a decision to come
together and then
generate the appropriate amount of
financial activity that justifies that
business
so you know it is not our role to
educate every performer
although in the last 22 months i've
worked very hard being involved behind
the scenes advocating for how best to
approach these safety concerns
associated with operating the business
but
the volume of material that's out there
that can be used to refute or to support
it may it does not position us
as
administrators performing arts venues to
be the experts in the field so we do our
best to be responsive to uh both the
artists and to the audiences in front of
us
i hope that answers your question
follow up
you do realize that
there's strong opinions on both sides
and if you want to get this bill through
it's probably
probably going to have to
undergo a compromise
oh i i respectfully appreciate that i
think compromise is is very important
that's what we do every day in our
business every day it's a compromise
about whether we're going to contract
with this particular performer whether
we're going to
bring an individual in who has strong
opinions in a personal area the
performing arts are a lightning rod for
um people who choose to
refute
individual opinions or beliefs and so
anything we program in our space can be
interpreted as a political message when
in the reality is we're just trying to
conduct business and bring the public
something of that they'd like something
that they might need and something they
might not even know they want and so we
pri try to create a diverse program that
supports that
representative kelsey
thank you mr chairman i wave off
anyone else
one thing from the chair would you say
that the last few years has put
poignancy to the phrase struggling
artist
yes
right
thank you and final card that i have
thank you for the opportunity sorry yes
um is from representative tim lang
he asked to speak for two minutes and
here he is thank you mr chair my name is
representative tim lang i'm a third term
rep here representing belknap county
four
however in my real job when i'm not here
at the state house where i'm my name tag
i work in the entertainment industry i
work specifically as a regional i.t
manager for the largest concert promoter
in the country i cover nine outdoor
amphitheaters throughout all of new
england about 30 night clubs through all
of new england i manage i help manage
the technology part of my reason for
this while i'm not representing them i
just want to validate some things that
were said to make it clear that artists
are a huge driver in in this
conversation what artists require
i give an example dave matthews band
requires vaccines or testing for all of
their concerts
i cover saratoga performing arts center
and we had 23 000 people show up for a
concert there last summer for dave
matthews band all of which was able to
manage this this requirement of either
vaccination or testing and the concert
promoter had a process in place for
validating that including doing testing
on site for uh real-time testing or the
instant testing they have
um but i will say the the venue the
artists do drive a lot of this and for
new hampshire the reason is belknap four
i'm here is we have the bank of new
hampshire pavilion up in guildford
that venue up there
um drives
oh yeah i think last year we had 38
concerts probably close to almost a half
a million people show up to do concerts
throughout that venue um give a take i
can't remember the exact number um
actually we had 52 concerts 30 almost a
half a million people um and again
almost i would say 80 of those concerts
had some sort of requirement for testing
over for or for um
uh vaccine requirement either or
um
so it is it is an important aspect
especially for artists right the artists
are concerned i had an enhanced you know
when i do my job i was under before we
had any accommodations or requirements
or mandates one of the mandates i had is
i go backstage i have to be tested every
single day whether i'm vaccinated or not
every single person got tested if you
went backstage because if you look at
dave matthews band
their average knights about a half a
million dollars in revenue for them
never mind what the venue itself makes
but the what the artist makes so me
going backstage sick and getting that
artist sick
would have a multi-million dollar
rolling effect as they have to
quarantine for 14 days if someone got
sick on their tour so there are some
legitimate reasons for doing some of
this
but i will say the one reason i really
came up was in this conversation about
mandates and requirements is the
contractual obligation with the patron
and so we had a situation i served on
the governor's reopening task force i
actually wrote the
guidance for the performing arts center
and worked with andrew and a couple of
other people
to come up with a good set of draft
guidelines for opening in the middle of
this pandemic that would work for them
so they could actually start getting
some revenue coming in rather than zero
revenue coming but the one thing we
found out this last summer was we had
some people put in vaccination
requirements after ticket sales and then
was refusing to
refund money and that's a major problem
that needs to be addressed if this bill
if you choose to move forward on this
bill those kind of contractual
obligations between the patron who
bought the ticket
thinking there was no vaccine
requirement no mask requirement and then
later comes out they set one needs to
have some sort of remedy for um getting
their money back because they're not
going to attend
and that was the main reason i wanted to
speak was that contractual obligation
between the patron
and the and the venue itself to make
sure that if a rule like this is put in
place that it's clear that venues have
an obligation to refund money if they
change the terms and conditions that the
ticket was sold under
that's it
i have a question for you um if
would you see that be being
what
we need to do to amend the bill or while
you're up do you see anything else
in it um in looking at the bill again i
i'm not
i don't i'm not sure there's an
a necessity for this bill because
businesses can already do everything
that's in this bill right are
these the theater companies already do i
know andrew what he does i know bank of
new hampshire already does um they're
almost everything in here they're
already doing i think andrew's point to
enforcement is probably they want to
point to the big bad government says we
got to do this because the big bad
government said so and that's part of
this is there looking for a scapegoat um
that's just my personal opinion um and
you're not speaking for fish and game on
that i'm not speaking for fish and game
on that not at all sir
um so
anyway uh so that
that's what i do think is going on i
think part of this is that they want
somebody to point to to say we have this
policy and here's why it's government
said kind of thing
my opinion my second question which is
unrelated i know in the 19th century the
chautauqua
facility in upstate new york had an
outdoor but very well covered pipe organ
any of the facilities that you manage
have uh the need for a classically
trained pipe organist
who would do it for far less than the
band you referenced i can reach out to
dave matthews being see if they have an
odd chance for you as zach brown band
both of which i'm friends with and see
if they can do something for you but i'm
thinking not the lightest shade of pale
demands a hammond organ
okay any other questions for the
representative
representative guy
no i can't get your tickets
thank you representatives
actually i would like some replace
um thank you
thank you for taking
perhaps even if everybody
okay this is one of those statements
with question mark at the end perhaps if
currently all the activities that are
being asked to may be made formally
legal
even if we didn't need all that
your point sounds very very reasonable
that
patrons do need the protection that if
the
if the requirements are sprung on them
after they bought the tickets that they
deserve
getting the money back
and and this is really
sort of related to
the issue of people donating money to
the truckers in canada and then finding
out
they're not going to get it back and
it's not going to the truckers so i mean
this finance oh you didn't know about
that okay sorry ignore that it wasn't
part of this
so it does sound like there is a
a reasonable
requirement for a bill that would
protect people
doesn't it
so i think i think
yeah i got the question mark at the end
okay so again
i do think that you pass a bill like
this there should be an additional
requirement on the the venues are
looking for some protections and the
additional requirements should be that
they they value the patient's contract
that if it's a new
um
requirement that sprung on the patron
after they purchased a ticket then that
would should void the contract purchase
of the ticket and you get your ticket
money back
thank you
representative delemus
thank you mr chairman
i did
thank you for taking my question
so
if we did put this policy and say the
bill does move forward
and it's basically patrons who are
surprised by policy can say oh i didn't
know and then they get their money back
i just don't see that that
that might be a can of worms
you know i agree it's ripe for abuse you
know someone who just can't make it that
night decides that it's the reason is
they after the ticket was purchased they
put a mask mandate and they don't want
to do it so it could open a giant can of
worms i agree
i will say again we found out this
summer through one of the local venues
here in new hampshire that refused to
give money back we had to get the
attorney general's office involved to
get them to square it away with the with
the venue ultimately end up opening a
two-week window for reimbursement
for people to get their money back but
it was a it was a big heavy load so if
you're going to open something like this
to government then you need to open all
of it and clean it all up and and deal
with this fact of the patron
venue relationship when contract terms
change
representative would you agree with me
that it should not be worded oh i didn't
know
but it should be worded
when it is posted on any site from which
you buy tickets
and going forward
otherwise anybody could claim ignorance
but if you can prove the date
this is when we put it on you are
without excuse if you later choose not
to go for whatever reason would you
believe
buyer beware is always good
policy so you know what you're buying
know what you're getting into
uh anyone else representative weber did
you have your hand up
well thank you
great minds that'll think alike we do
thank you so much
and with that i would like to close the
hearing on house bill 1639 and open an
exact session on the same bill 1639
for the purpose of discussing only and
not voting what we just heard
to see
if we can come to
what i meant
i'm sure i do there's a lot of dyslexia
going around
uh
representative knurk
thank you very much uh so
i was the reason i got out of my chair
was to run back to representative lane
because he makes a very good point i've
already prepared an amendment which
would change the statutory reference
based upon the amendment which was
distributed from representative wilhelm
and i was coming up with wording but i
want to know if this was acceptable be
so i would
not burden ols with multiple requests
for amendments that we don't we keep
changing
that at the end of the current amendment
if you pull it out
line 10
says
instead of a period at the end of the
word investments it would say provided
that refunds for tickets shall be
offered if such policies are changed
after the ticket is purchased
and given the question it was just asked
we could probably add something like
and the patient has
patient
sorry
other hat uh there is therapeutic value
to music i still keep falling back into
old habits and the patron uh same letter
uh the patron uh
has been
informed
of the policies prior to
purchase i'm trying to figure out that
wordsmithing the usual thing
you know when you make a reservation it
says i understand the policies uh the
terms and agreement of
the airline flight or the hotel
reservation regarding cancellation
policy and you check a box since most of
these sales are online that'd be very
easy for them to put in you've checked
it and it's therefore clarified that you
are aware of the policies but if they
change them you get a refund
would the committee feel that's
appropriate and help me with the wording
and i'll get this submitted
representative weber
microphone please
my apologies thank you um
i was going to say provided that refunds
for tickets be provided if policies
relative to
covid19 including mask requirements
vaccine and clients testing requirements
are a combination thereof using the same
language that is on lines six and seven
change
after the purchase is made
how does that sound
question of that do we need to still add
some mechanism in which we document that
the person was informed at the time of
purchase because again they could say
well i wasn't aware of that but if you
have a checkoff off
then i
provided that refunds for tickets be
provided if policies posted at the time
of purchase
change change
for the audience um during an exec
session we do not take further testimony
but we can ask with the permission of
the chair different ones to answer a
specific question so my question to mr
bernard is
are you comfortable with this because it
seems to be quite important to us
i think the contract with the patron is
a very important one and i
do not believe that most venues would
have any concerns
as long as it is specific to this topic
the concerns of illness the concerns of
people who just don't feel like showing
up and then use this as an excuse
this has been a very real problem uh so
but i i know most of the venues in the
state very specifically
elaborate what their policies are ahead
of time with that intent representative
folsom
thank you
mr chair and thank you for taking my
question
uh don't go away i have a question for
you
sorry
um what percentage of the ticket sales
are online
nowadays 100 of the ticket sales are
available so if there was a box that
they had to check off saying i
understand that
are the requirements for this
performance
two of the venues i'm associated with do
exactly that
they already check a box that state that
i will wear a mask that does not
however reflect
their reaction when they arrive
they're often people who purchase a
ticket and forget they check the box
um or some that perhaps a person
purchased the tickets and gifted them to
others that is one of the particular
challenges that why that is why when
we're doing ticketing we're trying very
hard to include the policy on the ticket
so that people have access to that
information
would there also be a
form
available at the box office should box
offices suddenly reappear and someone
comes and buys the ticket there that
here's the form read it check it sign it
again most venues that i'm aware of in
new hampshire currently have some sort
of notice posted prior to the purchase
and there's also practice of the
individuals who are selling the ticket
to remind people of the policies prior
to accepting payment representative
weber
the sentence here is getting very very
long so
if perhaps we left the period after
final
financial investments
and we started a whole new sentence
then we could say if policies posted
relative if policies
sorry that's got to go in another place
if policies relative to covert 19 with
all the added language
posted at the time of purchase change
after the purchase is completed the
venue shall refund the ticket price if
the
patron requests
i said if the if the patron requests
i'm looking for nodding is that
vertically or horizontally
you have to ask me uh representative
soloway
thank you mr chairman
um i would just point out uh to this
committee that we're doing an awful lot
of legislating
including the term
covid 19
in statute and i would simply like to
point out that within the foreseeable
future
profit 19 is more than likely to
disappear as our most immediate threat
and perhaps we ought to substitute
verbiage such as
infectious or communicable disease
rather than covid19 so that we don't
have to go back a few years from now and
repeal all the statutes that we've
passed with regard to covid19
i was thinking the same thank you for
articulating it that would mean that
line three of the bill would need to
change uh but while we're up you know
let's do that representative weber is is
the phrase that you would like if paul
infectious or communicable disease
policies relating to and we change it in
two places at that point thank you
let's speak to that issue anybody have a
point representative folsom
think out loud
okay i'll try and think out loud with
this one he heard me groan i mean think
out
loud um
i i would have
grave concerns to make it too broad
it would have to be
i would want it to be tied to
the fact that
emergency orders had been put in place
regarding some
disease because
the flu is
can be rampant and communicable
um
so
you know that and an infectious so
you know i i think that's a little bit
broad for me
um to have that representative merchant
thank you mr chairman
um i would propose to the committee that
we go back to looking at line six on the
amendment proposed by representative
wilhelm
and two things one is we would strike
the rsa 141 and substitute that for the
recommendation from department health
human services to i think it's three
59t
okay and then the other side of the coin
would be on line six
to be consistent with what
representative soloway is presenting
which i think is logical
is that at the end of the sentence where
it says in response to
to be a canonical disease pandemic
which is going back to declared by the
emergency powers the governor so it does
follow representative folsom's argument
about it has to be something declared by
the governor as a true emergency and
therefore it doesn't apply strictly to
covet but it applies to all the pandemic
that the governor so declare
representative weber
i'm very concerned about tying it into
the emergency declaration because
when the governor declares an emergency
the governor can then declare whatever
policies the governor thinks fit
this is not about what the governor does
this is about what private businesses do
and i think that private businesses
ought to have the authorization
to set policies
that provide them with the maximum
amount of revenue
and whatever else they as a business
value in the world in terms of artistic
satisfaction
and and
service to the public
and that should not be tied to a state
of emergency
it seems to me that the business ought
to set out their policies and their
requirements
very clearly
and you decide if you want to buy your
ticket or not
and if you change they're going to give
your money back
but
that doesn't have to do with a state of
emergency that just has to do with fair
business practices
representative kelsey
thank you mr chairman
do we not already allow private
businesses to do what private businesses
want to do
i mean i guess i'm just stuck on why why
put this in statute when private
businesses are already allowed to
implement
all of these things i've gone to
concerts
you know in the last two years and i
have worn a mask and i have satisfied
the other requirements the multi-layer
mitigation i that was my choice you know
as a patron to do that and i respected
the private business that they wanted me
to do that so i guess i'm just trying to
figure out why we have to put this in
statute when we already allow private
businesses to do what private businesses
want to do may i suggest that's not
necessarily the case and we will have
legislation before us that we'll further
go in the opposite direction
representative shapiro
that is exactly what i wanted to say
representative uh yes one thing is i
would actually avoid use of the word
pandemic and other things like this the
point is
it has to be nimble public health
response should be flexible and it's
difficult to have it in statute because
it's hard to anticipate none of us would
have anticipated what went on the last
two years
a pandemic means around the world
you could have a localized epidemic of
some kind of disorder for example
measles uh something else where
a venue would want to do something
because they'd like to be able to stay
open so i don't think we should have any
specific
comments about pandemics or diseases it
could just be flexible in terms of
communicable diseases
and leaving it communicable uh i think
rather than infectious and communicable
because anything
you know
so i would lean toward that with the
other language you're talking about
representative weber
thank you the reason we need the statute
is because as mr ramsey the honorable mr
ramsey
uh testified
right now if somebody shows up despite
his policies
but do not comport with his policies
there's nothing he can do about it
if we pass something like this
the patron shows up will not comply with
the policies and at least the owners the
managers of the venue can say here's
your 125 dollars back
hit the road jack as opposed to
coming in and violating the
venue's
contract with every single other person
who's in the place
i think that's a really great balance
but that's just me
representative folsom
um
one of the other things that i had about
the bill was um
yes i think the private businesses have
the right to to
set their policies um and then we have
the right to say whether we want to go
there or not
we've already done a couple bills where
we said
we were trying to carve out
migraines or we were trying to carve out
a specific disease
and it almost seems like we're carving
out
for the performing arts
is should we
you know are we going to then have a
bill
next session
carving out
some other
kinds of venues or or things
so
i
i i'm not sure i'm just sharing my
thoughts i'm not
my response to that representative would
be
that taking out the word covet 19
is similar to our not going along with
migraines
it's moving in that direction
representative uh weber i think had hand
up
i was just going to say that
historically there is nothing we can do
that will stop people bringing in new
bills that do things that are odd
or that we think are inappropriate or
that we think get us farther down a
slippery slope and the remedy for that
is moving itl and passing it
representative folsom
i i i want to explain to our guests that
my asking questions are not because i
don't think this is a good thing for you
to be able to do
i am just trying to parse out any
possible
ramifications of the bill it's not that
i'm putting up a big red flag or
something this seems to be to me
consistent with improv theater
i think
i'll take a couple more then we've got
to move on but this is to help what will
be an amendment writing
two summer threesome just two more
representative merchant and then king
thank you mr chairman
um the other side of the equation too is
that i think there's value to this
because
if you have an artist who wants to come
to new hampshire
being able to go to a policy or law
saying the theater does have the
authority to do this would be helpful
for them to secure the artist because
if we don't have an artist we don't have
a performance regardless of what you can
think about the vaccine status so we're
trying to make the artists feel more
comfortable there is in fact something
on the books to allow the
theater
to have a policy like this i think would
be helpful for the artist to be here
representative king
just for the record i'm having i'm
struggling with a lot of different
things here
one is that we don't
even though we have some bills that are
coming through
that may eventually
not
not allow
people to mandate
um we don't and so we're i think we're
talking about this prematurely or at
least it seems that way to me
the other thing is as far as
communicable diseases uh you know
there's a lot of communicable diseases
that really don't need
um and my heartburn really is going to
land on the vaccine itself
it's it's all it as time goes on it's
proving that it's not what it was
advertised to be
there's no returning once it's in your
body
and
i just have a hard time
uh
with that i i would go to a concert or
something if i had to wear a mask
but
i'm not going to vaccinate
which is your choice
all right i'd like to name a an
amendment committee of two or three
people to work on everything uh somebody
from either side of the both sides of
the playground if possible
um who do we have over here
representative canark anybody over
what's that
before the middle of march
there's somebody else
all right representative acton
has the benefit of not being here in the
room when it was all discussed so you
can come with fresh eyes
all right representative knurk and
representative acton
will be the committee of two and uh
i'm not sure when we'll be done
it may be we have a couple of weeks off
before crossover
in the which case could you
come back as soon as you can with yes
thank you so much i'm already drafting
it
that soon and
that representative acting in on it too
he's good yes yeah even though he calls
patrons patience sometimes yeah
okay that closes the exact session on
[Music]
pardon my less dixie
gary hasn't signed this year
i didn't sign it better
oh i'm sorry that's all right
okay
this opens the hearing on house bill
1045 an act requiring legislative
oversight over the emergency powers of
the department of health and human
services and i recognize chairman mark
pearson oh sorry mark pearson the prime
sponsor of this bill thank you
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee
this bill is a very simple little
housekeeping thing to put into
a place in the laws that
the
[Music]
ethics
oversight advisory committee
has a say
to the department of health and human
services
where issues are a matter of ethics
ethics are very important
technical people
may and should ask the question
how do we do it
ethical
thinkers ask the question
should we
and so often and it's not just by bad
actors it's by people responding
responding to an emergency
we'll say we've got to get this done
and sometimes the voice of saying should
we or should we do it this way
is not heard
for any number of reasons
the
ethics oversight advisory committee
is made up of numbers of stakeholders
the medical people of which
will have had some
training along the way in ethics
the speaker's office asked me as it
often does
to recommend
some people to be appointed
from
the house
i looked around
i've gotten to know most of the house
members
and i recommended that
a republican
who in his master of divinity training
to be a protestant pastor
studied ethics
i also find a democrat
who has a master's degree in ethics
and recommended them both and they were
duly appointed
as
the
section of the law that defines what
this ethical ethics oversight committee
does says
it's a two-way direction
the committee may speak to the
department either in the department's
anticipation of doing something saying
something
or after it's done so
and the commissioner
may initiate
by asking whoever is in the chair of the
ethical committee
would you take a look at this to see if
this passes ethical muster
that's what this does it puts it in the
what i am told is the right place
and over the weekend i sent everybody
three pages of single-spaced
analysis i part i ask your forgiveness
for the brevity of it
it spells out the different places in
the law we see numbers rsa this and that
so in that
testimony written testimony i gave you
over the weekend
it spells it all out and i've printed
hard copy which i'll pass out to help
you
further if you wish so madam chair
that's that's basically this it's a
little housekeeper thing
thank you very much i'll take questions
i'll recognize representative weber
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
i i hope a series is okay but i'll ask
after each one
um
my first question is
because the words in front of us rather
than all of the intent behind it
says subject to legislative oversight
how do we know that this is limited only
to
oversight for ethical issues rather than
for
whatever the whim of whatever
legislature is in power at the time when
it comes into
when it is needed
that's a very good question
and i would be amenable to
an amendment that would insert the word
ethics so that paragraph five or six
shall be subject to legislative
ethical oversight or oversight in the
matter of ethics i'd be very amenable to
that
in fact i would encourage it
and a follow-up madam chair
yes follow-up thank you thank you
and thank you for taking my follow-up
my follow-up is is it a matter of
concern
that if i look on the general court
website this is a committee that was
established in 2008
that currently appears to have never had
any meetings whatsoever
and it has currently only two named
representatives both being from the
house
for which we thank you
but is it not
really worrying and troublesome to
delegate that much authority to a
committee that has no track record and
apparently only two members
i would say it has the authority to
speak
it is advisory
and secondly one of the
many
committees i now chair
hadn't met for quite a while
until somebody said why isn't it
and they wangled me in not as a
legislator but as a private citizen
under one category so i would say okay
we're going to meet so start making the
appointments i think this is an
important matter
we know in history of times when
scientists or technical people
said here's how you do it and the voices
of ethics were not heard
and so i think this is very important
and um
with this i would be happy to raise the
human cry that this gets named
one more follow-up
one final follow-up um
would you be
open to
further amendment i i know it says that
the ethics oversight advisory committee
so that sounds like the committee's
meant to be advisory but it says
an emergency order shall be subject to
legislative oversight which kind of
means to me that the legislature gets to
say
uh uh i'm not gonna do that and and i
think we need if what we are
would you agree that if the intent is to
make this an advisory opinion
we need to make it clearer that the
opinion of this committee is merely
advisory
in which case
some of us
who
had real concerns about the language
when we read it the first time might
have far less concerns
knowing that this was a review
simply of the ethical issues involved
and in an advisory capacity which is not
at all how i read it to begin with
i would hope that as we work on this you
would have fewer concerns
thank you madam chair um and thank you
for taking my question honorable
dr cannon
representative pearson representative
will do fine thank you
you forgot air force major but that's
okay
uh i
it occurs to me that we have
a department of health and human
services oversight committee
which i believe is amply chaired thank
you we're dealing here with
a suggested
ethics
committee function
but also there are structural
imperatives that go along with this
would we not be better off
dealing with the ethical issues under
the umbrella of the department of health
and human services oversight committee
i would not uh for the reason
that
uh probably other than you and me i
can't think of anyone else
on oversight who has had training in
ethics
and while not everyone to be appointed
to the ethical
advisory committee will have many of
them will have
secondly i think that while
oversight has a very general purpose
this says that ethics is so important
that we want to have a special group
even if it lies dormant
for periods of time when it's not
necessarily needed although it is needed
now
representative gay
thank you very much uh i i really
approve of such
a few words holding so much information
it's a miracle
but i would really appreciate
having you expound
the nuts and bolts of how to do this
whose authority how binding is the
opinion of the uh because i mean
it says advisory committee
it says shall uh it says ethics
oversight
exactly what kind of authority does the
maybe just two members of the ethics
committee
have how much authority because it says
shall be subject to legislative
oversight
i would say the authority is moral
persuasion
in that
with
um
at least two people
with
training and ethics and the medical
people
having studied ethics
i don't think it would
anything that this group would say
would not be considered lightly it would
have in itself some authority one would
hope
then that the
department of health and human services
would recognize that as a parallel
very much in my own person
at the relatively early stages of the
pandemic
i spoke to one of the
section heads of dhhs on behalf of
churches
and being a legislator also running a
medical center
and being clergy i hit the trifecta
so that what i said
was
i hope because it was well
considered was accepted
so
i think the moral suasion of this ethics
advisory
committee
would carry the day and should it not
we always have oversight
committee
follow-up
i'm not negan negating anything you're
saying i'm just trying to understand
exactly who do you advise the
legislature
the
emergency order the commissioner of
health and human services
okay could we put that in there
oh it's in there somewhere already
oh all right rsa as it exists
there is hereby established an ethics
oversight advisory committee to offer
advice to the commissioner
relative to the ethical issues that may
be identified in the course of planning
for etc etc
and it speaks of communicable diseases
because covet 19 won't be the last of
them
so it's it's in there this this
you know
it's not in there because this is being
added to something that's already
there okay
representative canark
thank you um there are
sort of two questions that are the same
because the concern about limiting it to
um
limiting it not being anything and
everything that they'd want to rule on
that i would presume is already there
since it says pursuant to rsa 141 c 27 2
b
would not you agree that since this has
to do with ethical issues in the course
of responding to and planning to
outbreak communicable disease
that it already is limited
and also since that is precisely what c
rsa 141 c 27
reads
why do we need this bill at all because
it's already there that we have this
committee to give advice
so
[Music]
how is this
actually changing anything
it underlines it underscores it makes
more obvious
um
i wish
i could find my notes when i was
approached by important people telling
me do this
because i tell you who they were
i agree and as we
periodically hear in various bills such
as the last one
a lot of this stuff's already there
but sometimes it's nice to put it in a
couple of places
follow-up
follow-up well the last one wasn't in
law it was in practice this already
exists in law
because 127 741 c272b
already states that this is established
and this is what its job is is to offer
advice
so unless it's altering that i'm just
still not quite sure why we would need
to reinforce it
in law
i wish you could remember why i was
asked to do it because i don't
representative merchant thank you madam
chair
and thank you mr chairman for taking the
question
when i look back at the rsa which is
referred to on the committee
this talks about a legislative oversight
committee
i was under the assumption the
legislative oversight committee was
comprised of legislators
what this has in this bill it converts
back to rsa 141c to
if you look at the list of members
there's 15
of the 15 there's only three legislators
on that advisory committee that is
correct so therefore is this really a
legislative committee or is this really
kind of an oversight committee because i
think legislator
or legislative committee is sort of a
misnomer
i'd defer to somebody who's been in the
house longer to me it's a semantic issue
not a content issue
i know there are some committees that
don't have legislators appointed to them
but the legislature nevertheless
established that committee and i hear
them referred to as a legislative
committee even though there's no legit
that's probably incorrect speaking
this
ethics advisory committee
as you rightly point out has two reps
one senator and a bunch of other
people would it be helpful madam chair
if if the written copy of what i emailed
was handed out now because it has
things that are spelled out that would
benefit those who aren't researching
them on their computers yes i think
that'd be very helpful
okay
i'm trying to keep a list and uh get
people recognized as i see the hands
hopefully that's an all right situation
can i just give a point of information
while it's being passed out
just just a point of information just to
clarify
actually uh what will be coming out if
it's the same as the email
uh discussed
what is stated in 141 c272b that's
actually what's stated in 141 c 27 1. so
just so we have the proper statutory
reference
and that is in the bottom of the first
page
you're saying that it has not just the
2b but also no what it is what's what's
quoted there in italics is actually 141
c 27 roman numeral 1.
i don't know
what i'm saying is it's confusing it
says 127 c27 2b reads and then it says
one
it's actually
what you mean i think
chairman was that 127 141 c 27
1 reads
this is the paragraph at the bottom
of the first page this uh let's make
sure that it doesn't become a discussion
but yes this um the point was raised at
the bottom of the first page the
reference is apparently to rsa 141-c
27-1
because there's the roman numeral one
there in that language yes and that's
what
the chair has actually put in but he has
above it the introduction before there's
something called for the colon 2b it's
actually one
because 2b is
2b is reading review at least annually
reported investigations blah blah blah
that's just a minor error but i want to
make sure we all knew so we're talking
the same language okay and
may i approach the let me show them
yeah thanks
is this 2b here or is this one up there
this you're quoting one
okay all right sorry thank you thank you
very much
it's called the ethics oversight
appreciate that thank you
sorry i think i'm uh being a little too
mis permissive here this is sounding
more like an executive session so i'll
bring it back
i'm letting him know where his area is
so we can we can make progress i
appreciate that there were other voices
that were starting to come up as well so
i wanted to pull the reins back in there
i guess i'm going to recognize i have a
list here of people as their names came
up i was going to ask one question as
chair
thank you for taking the question i've
heard the term with great response great
with great power comes great
responsibility while i recognize you
don't remember the specific people who
asked you to do this were they perhaps
some who realize just
how broad the powers could be in other
hands that might not be quite as
restrained
the people who
the people who asked me to do this said
it is very important we have people who
respond
thinking ethically
and that this advice is given
not just as a bunch of people who are
chuffed off at something but people who
have been trained to think ethically
about questions
thank you representative weber
do you believe that the list of people
trained to think ethically about
questions
include
um
necessarily include it may include but
but doesn't necessarily
uh the three legislative members of the
committee the director of the department
of health that is state epidemiologist
all of which i hope are i firmly hope
are thinking ethically to begin with
the attorney general representative
public health network representative
colleger university
police chief fire department physician
commissioner of the department of safety
member of a fire department emtb
representative a hospital
the commissioner of labor designee a
member of the disability rights center
my concern is
are we delegating the right decision to
the right group of people
and my further question is
aren't you really
um
sorry that you started this discussion
by saying this is a simple housekeeping
bill
to the first question which is always
the kiss of death
to the first question no to the second
question
absolutely
i do not believe
necessarily
and i'm going to dare to say i do not
believe in fact
everyone mentioned there hasn't any idea
what ethics is
i'm not saying they're unethical people
that's not what i'm saying exactly the
scientific or the academic study of
ethics
uh is not probably
something they have ever had
and
you know the question of how do you do
it versus should you do it i should have
asked of myself
because i probably should have rewritten
what this ethics advisory group is about
not that these are aren't fine people
but their opinions their stakeholder
subgroups
opinions
can be heard in other venues than
an ethical advisory committee
thank you representative gay
thank you and i'm chair
um
as i look at what's different between
the current law and what is proposed
what's missing in the current law of
what you've just really defined thank
you so much
the emergency order
and the advisory of the ethics of
i mean if that's the ethics oversight
advisory committee the people that
madame
weber representative weber just read
those certainly seem to be you know
important people for input on dealing
with but they don't really
satisfy the requirements of being an
expert at ethics
so somehow it seemed like it would be
nice if you could rewrite this so that
once again
you have an ethics
this is not ethics oversight committee
i'm saying
whatever you want to call a committee of
two right now and possibly more but
people skilled in the study of ethics
somehow to be more advisory to this
group
because that list of people just isn't
really
an ethics advisory committee
so i want to see the
ethics advisory
to supersede and advise the the people
in that long list of people it's not my
place when i sit on this end of the room
to ask any one of you questions but let
me make the statement
should the question be asked of me
uh would i be well advised to rewrite
the
particip the list of participants to
make sure that an ethics advisory
committee
is a committee of people trained
in ethics
given the fact that these other
wonderful groups of people
have an opportunity to have their voices
heard in other ways
well this is not a housekeeping building
one follow-up
because the emergency order is what's in
your bill and it's nowhere near what's
already in the law
i didn't find that anywhere
so i would want that combined with the
pleasure of the chair i'd be much i'd be
very happy to stop talking which is
again a miracle
um
with the understanding that i will go
off and rewrite an amendment and be well
advised by anyone who wishes to speak to
me and many of you have already well
spoken to me may i withdraw
yes
oh sorry and uh now the chair
recognizes russian chester from bedford
representing herself
thank you committee chair thank you
committee members
just a quick aside
some of those individuals that you
identified like the disabilities write
center
they have quite a bit of experience with
regards to ethics i wasn't able to write
all of the folks down
but the bottom line is the reason why
this bill exists for we the people is
because in the most recent round of
executive orders
this exists
but it's not as there's no teeth to it
so although we the people brought it
forward and said this is not okay
that this executive order is you're
doing this you need to we need to file
an ethics complaint or we need to have
the ethics committee bring it forward
because we truly believe
that our that the executive order
violated ethics
bottom line and so that's why we asked
for it and basically we were told well
we don't have to do it so we're not
going to
that's why this bill needs to pass
thank you
and seeing no no further speakers i will
close the hearing on 10 45.
okay daddy back in the chair thank you
so much and thank you for chairing that
and thank you for ripping my bill to
shreds so that a new one can emerge in a
much better way
thank you folks all right don't run away
um
the honorable lady and i have spoken
over the weekend as to
some bills that are not urgent
but uh they will be in about three or
four weeks that we could profitably
exec at this time
okay
that's good that's fine
nope
please
uh take out
house bill 1384 establishing a committee
to study the need for child care
and ways to supplement and fund it in
new hampshire
we heard this on the 24th of january if
you filed your bills
in a calendar fashion we heard it monday
morning the 24th of january
and
13th 1384.
and we heard it on the 24th of january
and you may know that the speaker's
office has listed has promulgated
uh
with the agreement of
many uh from the opposite party an
eleventh commandment thou shalt not
commit e
committee don't make committees
do not commit e
okay
that's all right
i spoke with representative fenton
and
we discussed the fact that if this bill
were to pass
and work its way through the system
and then be signed
by the governor
into law
that would be summer
and then the committee would take a few
months to get together and
start thinking about what would be good
ideas and now we're into september next
year or this year
wouldn't it be a good idea instead
that this wonderful
needed thought
he
grabs some people
grabs a few reps who are interested in
this
grabs daycare people grabs parents grabs
people who are involved and think this
is an important issue
and come up with an ad hoc group
we do this sometimes with the deaf um
deaf and hard of hearing community of
the states of the state
and that representative fenton would
pull together this ad hoc group
and then come up with some specifics
that could turn into an lsr and we would
have a bill in fact this might get it
done even faster and it would involve
us not having to name
a committee
and as three members of the senate good
luck
not that they're hard working but
because they are
and
i know in trying to fulfill the
speaker's office's request
to find a couple of people who could
serve on this or on that
those who
are able and are willing are not all of
the reps
and many of the reps who you would
really want are already serving on three
or four committees and will not serve on
another one i cannot blame them
and so representative fenton thought
that this would be a good
idea and he
thought that emotion from us
to
itl
would be appropriate
because it would not speak negatively to
the need it would speak to the process
any just any questions yes
representative acton
thank you mr chair
i can second that because when we did
our our study committee in 2019 there's
a
very committed and vocal group of of
take
child daycare owners who are just
waiting to be heard
and so i can give him a list of people
to call and he can pull together an ad
hoc committee in about an hour of phone
calls he can have it all nailed and
these people will come they'll meet they
can do zooms
and he can have a very productive time i
think just doing that
thank you
anyone else representative snow
that has been working for some time it's
called the children's caucus
and i don't know that they focused on
this issue in particular but they might
also have
given some thought
to how you accomplish this same goal
and i know that uh
representative uh cornell
was the chair and she's recently stepped
down and i'm trying to remember who took
over
to stand up
levesque
okay yes that's correct
so maybe at least we ought to
give her a chat to see if there's a role
that that caucus could play and maybe
they've already gathered some of that
same information
i'll certainly pass all of these good
ideas along to representative fenton
representative shapiro
when he and i discussed this uh this was
uh something he articulated i didn't
suggest it to him he knew it already so
but thank you
chair entertains a motion
itl
who would wish to make the motion
i'll make the motion thank you
representative king
and representative snow
the motion before us is on house bill
establishing a committee to study the
need for child care
and ways to supplement and fund it in
new hampshire
moved by representative king itl is the
motion moved by representative king and
seconded by representative snow
would the clerk please call
the role the motion is itl
representative leon yes
representative mcmahon
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative cushman yes the clerk
votes yes
representative kelsey yes representative
king yes representative cagney gagne
gagne
representative delemus
yes representative weber representative
mckay absent representative snow
representative knurk yes representative
salloway
representative cannon
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes representative
pearson yes
any consent
objection
to consent
i won't jump the gun i apologize
you know
nope seeing none it
goes
on consent 20-0
and representative king if you could
write
the a very
appreciative
committee report
on this
some people don't allow
the blurb writers to leave the room
until the blurb is finished i'm much
more sloppy or tolerant whichever on
that but uh to a point
so if you could get that to me sometime
in the next day or so thank you so much
all right
um
mr chair
i just got notified that the amendment
on 1659
regarding the uh
the background checks is now available
i've asked them to make the copy do i
can run up and get that right now if you
wish let's take let's take a five minute
break so you can
i'm sorry
well that's unless you have another one
to start and i can run up and down while
you're starting the other one
okay
that's fine representative webber you're
suggesting which
can't hear you i'm sorry
i was going to suggest um house bill
1409 that's the mental health services
for minors
unless you'd rather wait on that one i
think i would for the moment
i'll i'll
pass it back to the chair for your for
your pleasure
i would like to look at
1139 i know our caucus the republican
caucus discussed it this morning and i
have a note here indicating the democrat
caucus was to do the same
11 39
off the malik
prescription requirements we heard it
on the 18th of january at 1
30.
house bill 1139
and did did you in fact discuss this
this morning
should have no
anyway
no
18th
we have two amendments on it one is by
representative wrong which is amendment
2022-0133-h
we also have an amendment from
representative veglier
representative
amendment is 2022-0014h
and for the life of me i cannot see how
the amendment is different from what the
bill is and i've read it three times so
if any of you can see that i'd
appreciate it
there's just a comma
uh on line 16 following cylinder there's
a comma
oh
and that separates so it's not cylinder
axis it's cylinder comma
that's why we're a committee
okay
it's the hand surgeon sticking out
so representative kanark if you would
keep those in your person and not pass
them out lest we get confused
we're looking at 1139
it is on the bill page 1 line 14
the first word is cylinder
and there should be a comma
after that before the word axis
make sure everybody's got a chance to
take a look at this the wrong amount it
actually happens twice
mr chair may i
i who's mr cheering me me you i did not
realize this was supposed to be done i
had worked with the ophthalmologists i
sent them an email last week saying
that i had to concentrate on the early
bills and i would get back to them
this week to go over their concerns
because they've emailed me with some
concerns about the language including in
the amendment
is there any way we could recess the
executive session on this particular
bill and go back to it yeah i brought
this forward because i have a note that
said
it was the hope that the democratic
caucus would look at this this morning
but
your nods are telling me you didn't
which is perfectly fine
so yeah um without objection i would
like to recess this then so that we can
come back with that additional
information representative weber i'm i'm
very sorry i i think i was misunderstood
or i was not at all clear which is
perfectly possible given to my day
yesterday
we did in fact have a caucus last night
but we discussed the early bills that
were
set for hearing tomorrow and we did have
some conversation about bills that
might be ready to go this was not one of
them representative weber since you were
only one half of that conversation with
me
uh it is quite possible that you uh were
misunderstood by this half of that
conversation
and so i am going to adjourn
the um
very brief exec session having uh dealt
with the problem of the comma
on house bill 1139 representative knurk
what is the bill number you would like
us to consider
uh
the amendment that i just went up to
pick up which did take less than five
minutes is on one six five nine
when was that heard uh on january 24th
okay could you uh pass that around
slowly while i look for that file
yes
thank you you're welcome
i'm i'm a good i'm a good
i'm a good assistant
yes
1659.
that's just fine
have these gone this way yet not here
ugh
i thought you were handing it to me
representative canuck would you uh oh
wait a minute
open
i open a
what's this an exec session executive
session on house bill 1659 relative to
criminal history background checks for
certain health care workers chair
recognizes representative kenner to
speak to your amendment which we just
received 2022-0532h
thank you very much mr chair um
yes basically there was some concern in
this
when i asked a question during the
hearing
if you go back to the bill for just a
moment
on page 1 line 13 it says that
the individual shall
submit a public criminal history record
period
which means i would give you my criminal
history record what i'm going to be
applying and i thought that was odd and
i asked the question about how do we
confirm authenticity of that that
actually evolved into a discussion of
who does the credentialing which we
learned was done by outside agencies
it's other than just the state police
because the current statute has it only
going to state police
so what we end up doing is number one
if you look at the wording on the
amendment on line
five
it it goes back in not that the
person shall give their record which
would mean their criminal background
check but they give the authorization
which authorizes the release of their
public criminal history record to the
facility so they're now again giving
authorization not providing the actual
record that's point number one the
reason that the word form was still
deleted which is on line five
is because that form is referring to the
state police form and there are a number
of different forms this gives the
facility the choice to use their own
form
the second concern was in the original
bill on line 29 on page one when it said
the direct supervision yeah and in a
organizational flowchart you may be a
direct report to a direct to your
supervisor but you may never ever see
them uh and this was something we wanted
a little bit closer supervision we had
debated the word visual but that would
really be untenable
nurses often work alone if you ask the
lna to go run around and take the vital
signs of all the people somebody has to
tag along with them directly into every
room and that would be that would just
not be workable so we changed it to
direct on site supervision so that that
person knows that at all times somebody
could pop in and see what they're
currently doing and we also have to
remember
that this is a person who will have also
just within the prior 12 months already
passed a criminal history a background
history check so it's not a totally
unknown individual 12 months ago they
were already vetted and passed they are
now working conditionally with a
conditional license for 90 days while
waiting for their new
criminal history uh background check to
go through and it just means that this
has to be somebody on site that
supervises them not visually but not
just a direct report
so that's those are the changes
any questions of the representative on
this
or any statements this is an exact
session you can make a
statement yeah i was i was one of those
who was quite concerned about
direct supervision
not just being a name on a flow chart so
thank you for this
representative um snow
about
this applies to anybody that has any
direct contact with a client
and what about contracted employees
where i live
we have somebody from catholic medical
center comes in once a week draw blood
it's never the same person
does that mean each person that may be
asked to come
we also have servers in the dining room
who have a lot of direct contact
with patients they tend to change
frequently but the kind of conversation
they have
is not anything that would ever involve
any real
clinical or legal
problems that i could think of so how
far do you want to go with this
it seems to me
you could suddenly be gathering criminal
investigations on a whole lot of people
people
we have landscapers who come in and you
know they're kind of a rough human group
but a lot of the clients where
other residents where i live
will go out and ask them questions about
what what they're planting and how
they're doing it
what's the best kind of fertilizer to
use for this kind of plant
do they have to have that
submit to that or they have to say
no i'm not going to
talk to you because i haven't
done it i mean i think it's very
confusing i think in language i think we
need to refine the language
any direct contact
and try to refine it a little bit more
how would you understand then lines 11
and following of the bill
for the durations of licensure or
certification
every individual selected for employment
with any facility or entity required to
be licensed or certified
under this chapter
then we go into the criminal record
thing so it already seems to be a
restrictor
line 15 picks up any employee including
volunteers
whose scope of employment is direct
contact with a client
client records client tissue bodily
fluids biological
material
it seems to define
the scope
representative weber
and i too just wanted to emphasize that
those words are already in statute
that's not what we're modifying we're
only modifying what
the application process rather than who
it covers it's all they're all already
covered we're trying to make it easier
to fulfill the requirements
yeah i know i know i don't need to be
reminded i do not need to be reminded
thank you representative gay
thank you mr chairman
we need to remind everybody that this
bill is just to help uh nursing homes
and similar com similar uh facilities
that are desperate to get employees and
because it takes a while to get a
criminal background check
this just says that they can
they don't have to have the
they can they can employ people right
away as long as they have the
authorization to request the criminal
background check
and like like representative weber
saying we're not changing any of the
requirements
any of the people it's i think the bill
really says you know that the license
you're talking about people who have who
just the people who have to be licensed
i don't know if that means the person
who's cutting the grass
uh
oh you think it's more more extensive
point of information can i clarify this
because i
yes please
no the original statute applies to
anybody who comes in contact
with the residents or or clients
yes
representative
yes the issue is this when we're talking
this is what was really confusing and
came up and i spoke with uh paula
manahan about this just last night
this is discussing institutional
licensure
this is not licensure of the individual
person
it's that the applicant for a license to
to operate a facility
has to have in place a screening for
employment that involves a background
check that's what this is about so we
were talking about licensing of
facilities that's what's being done and
again as you've stated it's just to
streamline the process so they don't
have to go through the state police they
can go through other means that's all
representative snow has that been
helpful
not enough okay
representative canark no
section one does section two is for
duration of licensure or certification
that means of the facility every
individual selected for employment with
the facility any facility or entity
required to be licensed that means again
the licensed entity uh shall have a
criminal background check so it's not
just the operators it means anybody who
works there any individual selected for
employment it's all employees but this
is and there's a phrase i'm not going to
use because the poor guy who did the
last bill
regrets it very much that he used it but
were we not in that position of regret
that's kind of what this bill is
i mean it does not redefine categories
of persons or anything like that
actually it's it's more than just a
housekeeping bill what it's allowing is
it's allowing them to use it's allowing
them to to not have to use the state
police it's to streamline the process so
it does fundamentally change
the process but we're not changing who
and everything else is represented
wherever pointed out that's all in
statute already we're only changing
what's struck through or what's bold
you okay with that representative
snowden's
push push the button the button makes it
go
individual
oh
yeah well you're good you're good leave
it alone don't don't
normally touch the only one in this room
that has trouble with these microphones
because we all have of our own troubles
yes we do well i'm glad mine is
restricted to microphones we are too
does this
how do people feel this also covers a
lot of these contracted licensed
employees lab assistants
uh
both elliott and cmc send
different lab assistants in each time
they come
dna sends people in to perform certain
duties within the facility
do they have to get a criminal
background check on everyone that the
hospital is going to send or not
the point is off the point
it is
it's not the point of what we want
that's another subject
what
this is
this changes how not who okay that's all
representative folsom to clarify
thank you um
when they hire a contractor to fill
those positions
it's usually that company you're
contracting with that has done the
background checks
representative merchant
thank you mr chair
and a question came up during the
testimony
when we talk about going through the
division of state police
they do it
comparison pick with the federal level
sometimes with the fingerprinting and so
forth to be sure that what's coming
across the federal is matching up with
what's on the state level
my concern here the way this is written
i don't oppose the way it's written per
se
but there's nothing in here to say
where you can go to get a public
criminal back i don't know if about this
and saying could anyone give a public
criminal history background or because
at least with state police you know
you're going to a state agency
that's acting as a clearinghouse to
ensure that the public is getting a
criminal background check
when we
delete the state police because of the
backlog we hear about
my concern is that we don't have
something as a clearinghouse at a
federal estate agency to be acting in
that capacity
representative canark i'll try to answer
them i'm frantically looking for some
notes for my discussion with uh paula
manahan last night i'm not able to find
them right now but uh basically for
example if you are going to be a
licensed provider you still go through
that check as a separate thing that is
your own check that you're going through
um like when you apply for a medical
license and so on
this uh
the
it's important to understand that the
apparently
lieutenant
sorry
from state police musli
uh was actually new to that position and
he was confusing uh those couple of
different things this is an employment
check
what actually would happen is
the
remember this has to do with licensure
so the licensing for the facility could
set those standards of who they would
accept for
uh doing the background check that would
be something they would do in rules
remember we don't have to write every
little detail in legislation rules will
then implement it and part of that
implementation would be they'd say here
are the uh
the authorized background check
people that you facility can use to do
your background checks but we do not
need to clarify that here that was
clarified that we do need to make sure
it's adequate that would be their job
and they have agreed to do that
representative gay
thank you mr chair
um and the actual bill
line 25 starting line 25
agrees profoundly
with the purpose of the bill which is it
establishes the provisions for temporary
employment
not meaning forever temporary in a
residential care facility
or as a licensed nursing
assistant
by people waiting for the result of a
criminal history background check the
problem was you need to hire people very
quickly now because the need is so great
so i think excuse me
i'm sure all the issues that we're
discussing and the terms are important
but the purpose of this bill is to mean
they can employ people while they are
waiting for whatever background check
they have employed so all the person has
to do the old form the old rsa says they
have to give their their criminal
background check they have to prove it
and this says they can just give
authorization for it they can start
working and then online
starting with 25 it gives the employer
uh up to 90 days
hoping that rape that criminal
background check comes but it allows
them to employ people before they get
the background check
and that's why there's all this careful
addition in the amendment on line 17
of how they're being watched to make
sure that they are
it's safe to have them there
so as we've been discussing it seemed
like we were getting away from the
purpose of the bill
representative merchant
thank you mr chair
and also in regards to the
entity that can provide the criminal
background check i do support the fact
that it's probably best in rules but i
would like to have something it would
say
organization as approved by the
department of human services that way
there we're sure that some state agency
is approving the identity that which
they can
contract with to provide the information
is we're basically got the state police
at this point in time
which is a state agency and we're not
putting something back in to say it has
to be go through another agency somehow
to be allowed to approve and say okay
these companies have been approved by us
you can do it that's all so you have
some sort of oversight to be sure that
what does come back in fact is coming
from an organization that has been
reviewed by the state to be sure that
that point in time what's coming back is
in fact what the state's looking for
anybody wish to speak to that question
then well uh
yeah may i respond to that
yes just simply
this was agreed upon by including dorian
shockley who's in charge of the
licensing so i think this is what their
intention would be she was here for the
testimony and worked with the
state police on the uh amendment
with minahan uh to make sure that that
was all there
i do not know if we need to go to that
level of information that there are
people with more seniority than i that
could answer that question
representative gay
thank you
yes if we already have some we already
have an other rsa
who is permitted to
grant that who to do the background
check we don't have to address it well i
mean we're used to using the state
police but does anybody else's anybody
else already authorized to do that
to do the criminal you may answer that
representative
i would assume that they have not
because currently it's for the
department of safety so new rules would
have to be promulgated by the licensure
department licensure that would be they
would describe how the process would now
work that would be done at the rules
level
because they would not have a rule of
who else could do it when other places
were not currently allowed to do it
follow-up representative gay yes uh
because of the 90 days now being granted
while you're waiting for that does that
really mean they don't want to use the
they don't use the state police anymore
representative
many of them still will use the state
police the issue is they wanted the
flexibility to use other credentialing
agents agencies as well that was the
point of this as you stated earlier it's
to give them more flexibility in how
this process is done that is correct and
flexibility is best served by rule not
by stats by law right yes representative
shapiro
if i remember correctly which i may not
um
when we're talking about businesses
doing background checks i think it's on
is it on
we were talking about vendors who would
then get the background checks done not
not businesses or vendors that did the
background checks but evidently there
are vendors that people can contract
with to actually get
and i thought they were federal
background checks
done
so it's not it's not necessarily the
businesses or vendors that are doing the
background checks they are just
organizing it
that is correct it is uh and i find i
found the notes from a discussion last
night
uh it it is it's it is it's basically
sets as a condition of employment
that they have to do the background
check but they the you you're right it's
not that the
nursing facil nursing home would
actually do the background check they
would work with a vendor who does a
background check and as i say in rules
those new rules will need to be
promulgated by the licensing authorities
anyway as to how that this process would
work and they would probably then state
which
vendors could do that
representative leon thank you mr
chairman in my previous life on uh in
the financial world i had to be
background checked many many times for
the sec for finra for all of them my
hands were almost always black
from the fingerprintings but those were
all conducted with private businesses
that had all of the clearances in
downtown boston the financial district
we basically went into a vault to do it
when i was up here working from
new hampshire we'd get the fingerprints
done at the local police and then sent
in so there already is a good framework
for these background checks um i'd argue
that these patients are more more
vulnerable than money but without the
money they also can't stay
and keep their their freedom so
um i do think that rules would be the
best way to do this because it's already
done in other industries
and they're pro there already probably
are some in the state that can step into
this role as well
representative weber
not to beat a dead horse but i'm just
going to flog the poor nag one more time
and say all we're doing
is changing the choice of form
and making it a little more
broad
there are no rules to go along with it
yet because
up till now there was only one way of
getting the background check which was
one of the barriers to getting people
employed and working
so
i i'm fervently hoping that this very
small change to the bill as it came to
us
would be approved
and
we could then move on to deal with the
bill itself
so i'm going to suggest that
representative knurk makes a motion on
his amendment
2022-05
the amendment to house bill 1659 fn
representative kenner i would be happy
to do so i move uh
amendment 202 to 0
5 3 two h the amendment to house bill
one six five nine fn
and do we have a second
a second representative leon
sorry
think nicely you can't help it that you
wore the same dress to the party
all right um that's
what the clerk
call the role please on amendment
0532h
to house bill
1659 the motion is ought to pass
represented by um made mo moved by
representative knurk and
in a split
tie representative leon seconded it
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey
yes
representative king
representative geg
[Music]
i'm not going french sorry um
representative gagne
oh he's yes
delemus
yes
representative weber
representative mckay is absent
representative snow representative knurk
representative soloway representative
cannon yes representative nutter up yes
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant no
representative pearson
yes
that is the amendment
now representative mcmahon you are a
co-sponsor of this would you wish to
move the bill
and someone from over this side would
like to second it from the democrats
the motion before us
and by the way in the original hearing
17 people
signed in in favor
and one
against
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended on house bill 1659
fn
amended by
2022-0532-h
representative mcmahon moves ought to
pass his amendment as amended with
representative canark seconding it with
the kirk clerk please call the roll
representative
yes
representative mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman yes the clerk
votes yes representative kelsey yes
representative king yes representative
gagne yes representative delemus yes
representative weber
representative mckay absent
representative snow yes representative
knurk yes representative soloway
representative gannon
yes representative nutter upham
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant
no
representative pearson yes
uh representative would you object to
this going on consent not at all thank
you so it goes on consent thank you so
much
and what was the vote i'm sorry
19 to 1.
uh representative mcmahon if you'd write
the committee report for us
thank you
and this closes the exec session on
house bill
and
it opens a
53-minute lunch hour
[Music]
and by the way
that bill we just did it was just a
housekeeping thing
yes yes ma'am
could i ask my fellow democrats to
process across the hall for a couple of
minutes before lunch for
a discussion
thank you
no no no no no
if you're catering something over there
i think you should
i share
uh
you
right
thank you
foreign
foreign
oh
i'm in hampton
thank you
so
about
uh
oh
thank you
runners
oh
one
thank you
you
oh
this yes
okay
over there
is
um
you have to audience
is
with anybody
all right
i'm
oh
um
opening the hearing on house bill 1633
relative to requiring covet 19
vaccination for school attendance let me
give to everybody in the gallery the way
this hearing is going to be conducted
we will have the
prime sponsor of the bill testify first
we will
have a physician who has been flown in
from texas
testify for several minutes
we will hear from the department of
health and human services
we have two different individuals
representing two different nursing
organizations and they are on opposite
sides of this
after this i have a growing stack
of pink cards
you will be allowed
two minutes
after two minutes or after about a
minute and 45
the gavel will come down your opinion is
very important but when there's a lot of
people we have
the bills we need to move on to
we've seen before in hearings like this
that people can be incredibly articulate
for their position
in two minutes
the chair recognizes the prime sponsor
representative
dr william marsh
thank you uh chairman pearson and
members of the health and human services
committee it's a pleasure to come back
and see you again for the record i'm
representative william marsh carroll
county eight representing seven towns in
southern carroll county
and i'm here today to introduce house
bill 1633
relative to requiring covet 19
vaccination for school attendance
i have emailed you all a copy of my
testimony as well as an ama document
showing how covid19 has become a
childhood disease i have one hard copy
for the clerk which i will pass up when
i'm finished
recently a similar bill was filed in
california they titled it the keep
schools open and safe act
that really summarizes the intent here
we know vaccination is our best tool for
reducing the transmission of covid19 in
our schools
we know our kids really suffered for the
last two years from remote learning
both their education and their mental
health
we know that they are suffering this
year as massive absenteeism among both
students and staff is again disrupting
their education
we know unvaccinated children with covid
have been filling pediatric icus across
the country
covet has caused long-lasting
multi-system inflammatory syndrome in
other children
we know historically we have never
controlled any viral disease disrupting
our schools without a vaccine mandate
the first six diseases for vaccination
is required under rsa 141 c20a are
specific examples diphtheria mumps
pertussis poliomyelitis rubella and
rubiola historically all were known to
spread in our schools
and while the omicron spike is winning
we know that the even more contagious
ba2 variant is already present in half
of u.s states
this bill is really important to keep
our schools open and safe
this bill is co-sponsored by every
physician in the legislature
originally i plan to file it just from
the physicians as i had hoped we could
pass this in a non-partisan manner but
that doesn't seem to be possible right
now let's look at the details of the
bill
section 1 expands the definition of
schools in the communicable disease law
to include post-secondary education this
is intended for two reasons
for most of the pandemic we could see on
dhhs's map of case counts that the towns
in new hampshire hosting universities
were epicenters of infection
this is intended to mandate coveted
vaccination for university attendance
most private universities already
require this of on-campus students
including dartmouth college saint
anselm's college colby sawyer college
franklin pierce university new england
college riviera university and southern
new hampshire university
section one also corrects an unintended
consequence of last year's house bill
220.
i apologize to this committee
because i failed to see this unintended
consequence when we were working on this
bill last year
in 2007 there was an outbreak of
meningococcal meningitis on the unh
campus
as i am sure you all know that is a
rapidly fatal disease spread easily in
the dormitories on college campuses
public health controlled that outbreak
by mandating by rapidly mandating
meningococcal vaccination of all close
contacts
and because of their swift action
only one student died
a recurrence today would be highly
problematic and i'm afraid we would see
far more deaths
section 2 adds covet 19 to the mandated
school vaccination list
only when it becomes fully approved by
the fda
right now that means ages 16 and up as
further data becomes available and
vaccinations become fully approved at
younger ages that age is likely to move
downward without further action by the
legislature
sections 3 and 4 contingently repeal the
section limiting the requirement to
vaccines fully approved by the fda once
a vaccine exists without age restriction
i urge you to recommend this common
sense measure ought to pass i will be
glad to take questions i will tell you
that i have to return to edna for an
executive session fairly promptly
so thank you for that thank you
representative martian welcome back
glad to see you
any questions for the representative
representative acton
thank you mr chairman uh thank you
representative marsh
will there be any um provisions in this
for natural immunity my my daughter
had covered two weeks ago and
was sick for
about 12 hours and then she's back to
normal but had to miss considerable
amount of school
now she has natural immunities are there
will there be any provisions
in this for her to
avoid being vaccinated we wrote this
bill intending that the
exact vaccination requirement how many
shots when they be needed what age they
would need could be expanded upon in the
rules as you all know these things
change and usually this committee does
not tell the medical professionals how
to do their own job
uh my understanding of natural immunity
is it does not occur in all cases and it
also tends to wade after three to six
months
so
i i think that that would be pertinent
mr chairman i ask you to keep ordering
your committee
i think that would be highly pertinent
and of course as further data comes
forward that would be rather pertinent
as well
okay thank you representative kelsey
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um do we have the
data on the vaccine immunity like what
the va what the vaccinated vaccination
immunity time frame is
i'm not sure i understand your question
i think that may be a better question
posed to some of the to dhhs and some of
the other people who may testify after
me okay thank you
leon thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative marsh for taking the
question um i see that you are
indicating that only those vaccines that
are fully approved by the fda would be
required um would you intend this to
wait until comiarti which is the
approved one is actually available for
use in the united states or are you
willing to allow essentially the
biosimilars to those to be used even
though they don't have specific fda
approval i i think that the rule making
process would address your question
representative soloway
thank you representative marsh um
on a local level local school boards
local universities rather than having
statewide legislation
i don't think that's ever been done in
the state of new hampshire generally if
vaccines are going to be required for
school attendance we add them to the
list you and i have both been on this
committee long enough that we know other
examples where that's been uh considered
follow-up please mr chairman
uh thank you um we're putting kovid 19
into the legislation
is it possible that covet 19 will in
fact disappear as a threat
you're the epidemiologist and i am not i
know that you're of the opinion that
this will become endemic which to my
mind means a low level of chronic
cases
my belief is that it's more likely to
come in waves like other diseases have
in the past and we can have that debate
another time it's not pertinent to this
bill
any further questions for the
representative erica excuse me
representative leon thank you mr
chairman this is a friendly committee my
other question was about
applying this to schools like dartmouth
as you mentioned they actually pre-date
our country and so the rights of what
dartmouth does are carved out pretty
well
i'm curious how how you view the
legislature having the authority to tell
dartmouth college what to do
thank you for that question as you may
know i am an alumnus of dartmouth
college and the dartmouth college case
was one of the early cases that defined
the roles of the united states supreme
court i think that the exact rights that
dartmouth college has has been very much
been under debate since the founding of
this country and the passage of this
bill will not change that
representative folsom
thank you chairman pearson thank you for
taking my question
i'm kind of rolling off of
representative leon's question
i don't
maybe i'm not reading it right but
are you also going to mandate feel that
this should be mandated for private
schools
i think that diseases can uh spread in
private schools as well i don't think
that i'm the person to ask as to whether
this specific statute applies to private
schools i think you should ask that
question of dhhs
representative marsh on line two it says
school means any
facility i think that question is
answered here in our bill i think that
that would be an appropriate answer to
the question but they can tell you how
they are applying the law at present
regarding other vaccines that are
mandated by the state of nature i
appreciate your answer thank you sir
anyone else
thank you for your testimony
representative marsh
say hi to edna force
the chair calls representative jerry
kanerk from this committee has written
testimony supports the bill
thank you mr chair and i distributed the
written testimony
prior to the hearing
so
yes i'm for the record representative
jerry canuck representing carroll county
district 3 and a retired surgeon
i agree with representative marsh that
vaccination is our best tool for
reducing the transmission of covet 19 in
our schools in order to minimize closure
and absenteeism of teachers and pupils
a high level of vaccination is also very
important to protect those vulnerable
individuals
who are medically unable to be
vaccinated and those who are
immunosuppressed
they may not be able to mount good
response to the vaccine or to the
infection
my job today is to concentrate on
clarifying some of the misunderstandings
of the science
which have been prevalent and stated in
our committee this year and the enormous
number of emails that we have received
because our policy decisions even though
we may disagree on that must be based on
facts and not disinformation
some people have contended the
vaccination does not work based upon the
fact that if you have a breakthrough
infection you can still transmit the
virus
well that's true at the individual level
it is not true in the aggregate or the
whole population level
since vaccination decreases the rate of
infection it decreases population level
transmission
then vaccinated are formerly far more
likely to get infected in the first
place
the data and this varies some data from
january said a seven fold increase in uh
unvaccinated getting infected recent
data from washington state shows a
three-fold increase in the infection
rate and vaccinated versus
unbacked sorry in the unvaccinated
versus vaccinated in the age group 12 to
even with omicron
so though the risk of transition by an
individual with breakthrough infection
persists
the risk of transmission transmission at
the population level
which is what we're interested in will
still be lower because many fewer people
will be infected and therefore able to
transmit the virus
additionally vaccinated people who do
have a breakthrough infection have an
accelerated viral clearance that means
they get rid of it faster
than those who were unvaccinated that
makes them infectious for a much shorter
period of time therefore decreasing
further
the population level transmission so you
combine
the decreased number of people who are
infected
with the acceleration of the variable
clearance and the bottom line is the
covered vaccination will
decrease
the chance of transmission on a
population level even though the
individual person transmission may still
occur
the next you've heard it contended that
the vaccine doesn't work if we look at
an early study of over 2000 adolescents
there was initial study ages 12 to 15 it
showed a remarkably high efficacy after
two doses
with regard to infection
not talking about you know illness and
so on but just infection at a hundred
percent which is a bit unusual but
that's because with only two thousand
that it can have that kind of a number
which is probably a little bit less with
more
but no cases in the vaccinated group in
18 cases amongst the placebo and no
deaths
a more recent study was done in response
to the surge of omicron looking at 1400
children ages 12 to 18. it was published
just in january
and it demonstrated a 94
protection against hospitalization and
98 protection against icu admission with
all deaths occurring in the unvaccinated
now the big thing you've heard it
multiple times including even today
incorrect statements about the number of
deaths due to covet vaccine from the
vaccine adverse events reporting system
veers
it is precisely that it is a reporting
system
it is not a causal system it's important
to note that all
deaths following vaccine administration
must be reported to bears
even if not related to the vaccine
if a child drowns a week after a
vaccination that has to be reported as
an adverse effect event
there's a clear disclaimer on the vares
data that shows that a report in various
does not imply causality
it is purely coincidence
every adverse effect event is
investigated in order to determine
causality
that's how for example we found the link
between thrombosis throughout
hydrocytopenia syndrome with the j j
vaccine that was confirmed it led to
warnings for that age group and a
recommendation to use the mrna vaccines
instead
the system works
so the fact that there may be a death
reported does not means it's causal
you all got an email i think two days
ago
claiming that a
15 year old here in the state who was
reportedly a nephew or something of
congressman pappas
hadn't had his in uh had his vaccine and
then well swimming died a week later and
they even linked to the various report
i'm not sure how many of you read the
autopsy report i did
the only relevant finding was thickening
of the left ventricular wall
and if you've gone to the gym you'll
find that in one week you're not going
to get bulging muscles that takes a lot
of time that is not related to the
vaccine
that person had hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy which is a well-known
problem in young adolescent
and young men
with sports which is one of the reasons
why we we think one of the reasons why
we often see sudden death in
high performance athletes it's one of
the postulated mechanisms
so there it is the person is claiming it
to death from the vaccine because they
got they died afterward
jumped in the lake he swam
he died
nothing to do with the vaccine
period
now if we look at the original study
of
all the patients 43 000 this is the
initial eua study
and you look at the adverse events
they're a lot
but there were for example
life threatening
in the vaccine group there were 21 there
were 23 in the placebo group
deaths 2 in the vaccine group 4 in the
placebo group
so a report does not mean it's causal
because we saw actually more in the
placebo group that doesn't mean
that placebo caused them to die it's
just simply looking at the numbers and
you have to actually correlate and look
for causality
the best full cdc data i can find for
kids
covers a period from december 20 to july
and as of july 16 2021 8.9 million
adolescents
ages 12 to 17 had been vaccinated and
there were 14 reports of death to theirs
but if you look at the pattern of
reported deaths it was not suggestive of
a causal relationship
although the full data was still pending
on a few for example two deaths were due
to suicide that's the third leading
cause of death in adolescence already
not related to vaccine
and if you look and i've dug this up if
you look at the annual death rate in the
group of ages 12 to 19 historically
nothing to do with covet nothing to do
with vaccines
50 kids in that age group per 100 000
will die per year
therefore if you took that 8.9 million
kids you looked over seven months you'd
expect
2595 deaths that would occur
that's the background noise
so when somebody dies in a week two
weeks whatever after a vaccine it
doesn't mean it came from the vaccine
until you can actually
look at the record
look at the autopsy find out why that
person really died so when people keep
spouting out numbers and bears
it means
nothing
it is a reporting system to give us
information
because that is how we do find
the signal that there may be a problem
such as in ttp
thrombocytopenia thrombosis
syndrome
because indeed it was found that that
was particularly young people and it did
exceed the natural history of that
disease
it's also been said that covet doesn't
affect kids but that's not true
more than 700 kids under 18 have died of
covid and as of october 20 21 nearly 1
000 sorry sorry
100 deaths from covid in the age group 5
to 11 have been reported covet actually
ranks in the top 10 causes of death for
kids ages 5 to 11.
so it is not a non-problem
and the comment was just made about
community
commonity is precisely the same
as the eua formulation
it is simply
you would use up the old stuff
in the vials before you start going to
the new stuff that has a label with a
different name
several months ago when i bought a box
of cheerios it was called cherry oats
they were harkening back to 40 years ago
when that's what they used to call it i
didn't run right home and grab the
cheerios in my closet and throw them
down the drain because they're now
not labeled the same
because they're the exact same thing
this is the corneality and what was done
for the eua which is in other vials
without with a with a different number
pfizer bnt a bunch of numbers it's the
same stuff you don't throw away a good
vaccine so you can just use the stuff
that has a different label
so in summary the vaccine is safe it is
effective we need to increase the
vaccination
rate in our kids to protect those who
cannot be vaccinated
thank you very much i'll take questions
questions
representative king
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
um
i appreciate what what you talked about
with vares and the numbers not really
meaning anything
could we apply the same logic to
the covid number the covid deaths before
the vaccine
where people were dying of cancer
in old age
but if they had covid they were
considered covet related deaths
okay that's something that is often
spotted about in terms of the adult
saying that only people really died of
covet because they had no comorbidities
um i i have some comorbidities i have
hypertension and if i happen to have a
heart attack i died of my heart attack i
didn't die of hypertension but it was
contributing probably
the point of the matter is if somebody
happens to have
obesity and diabetes
and they're walking around perfectly
fine i would dare say a number of people
in this room have diabetes
they're not going to die tonight
but if they get coveted and then they
develop pneumonia and they're on a
ventilator and they die they died
because of covid they didn't die because
they had diabetes that is an underlying
predisposing condition
but it is not the cause of death i've
filled out death certificates
and you do you have to put down all the
various factors
but the cause of death is what killed
you so when we say that though they had
these other diseases it doesn't matter
it does matter
by the way i didn't say the verse is not
doesn't count it counts a lot that's how
you do get it but you can't say it's
causal you have to look at it then
investigate it you don't take the raw
data thank you
representative
cushman
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative canarque for taking my
question
uh
you you gave um testimony that the
vaccine slows the spread in the
population even if it
doesn't have any effect on transmission
between individuals
i just want to understand how that
how that applies or how that
cashes out when you consider that
israel the country of israel had some of
the highest vaccination rates in the
entire world and they not only had
higher infection rates among the
vaccinated but
also higher hospitalization and death
rates among the vaccinated i presume
just for clarification you mean as
opposed to
the unvaccinated
is that what you mean yes okay first you
have to look at the population
so for example we know that covet is a
disease that affects a lot of people and
it actually has been overall shown in
the country to primarily affect
it has a disproportionate impact on
people of color
but wouldn't you be amazed to know that
the majority of people who have died of
covid in new hampshire are white
that's because the majority of people in
this country in this state are white
so your vaccination rate the higher it
goes it means the higher the number of
people in your hospital at any given
time
let's let's take it easy let's say fifty
percent and fifty percent you got fifty
percent vaccinated fifty percent
unvaccinated
but
if you have in like in this state about
two-thirds of people vaccinated the pool
you're taking from with vaccinated are a
heck of a lot higher
so that really means that the odds of
getting infected are still lower for the
vaccinated and the higher the rate of
infection sorry the higher the rate of
vaccination
the greater you will see that the
population by raw number in your
hospital will be the vaccinated
even though they are less likely than
the unvaccinated to become infected i
know that's kind of complicated but it's
a matter of the pool it's taken from
let's say if you have 100 percent of the
people and your stay in your
in your state are vaccinated
100 of the people admitted will be
vaccinated
representative cushman on the follow up
thank you mr chairman um thank you
representative kanark
i'm i'm sorry if i wasn't clear in my
original question but the rate the rate
of infection the rate of hospitalization
and the rate of death is higher
among vaccinated in israel than among
unvaccinated would you believe that
i think my concern is knowing do you
mean the percent of people for example
that's maybe there's 80 of the people in
their hospital are vaccinated versus 20
is that what you mean by rate i need to
know what rate means
no the
instance
of
infection hospitalization and death
the percentage
that that happens
is higher among the vaccinated in israel
right but that's pretty vaccinated per
100 000.
okay
i'm not quite familiar with that data so
it's hard for me to comment i have ac i
have looked at the data in this state
when for example the comment was made at
one point in time that 86 percent of
people
in the hospital at a certain point back
in the fall were vaccinated so therefore
it wasn't working but the point is that
we were 380 were unvaccinated and if you
looked at it again you were drawing from
a pool
of unvaccinated that was far smaller
than the pool of vaccinated in this
state so it still demonstrated a
nine-to-one ratio
of the
chance of being hospitalized by virtue
of being unvaccinated um so again i do i
have not seen those numbers i'd love to
look at them if you'd forward that to me
this is
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking the question
um
would it be possible for me to ask two
one and then a follow-up
okay the first question
the first question i've been trying to
get the information to know how many of
the hospitalizations have coveted as an
incidental finding because of the
testing in order to make sure the right
precautions are done so i'm not sure if
you're aware in new hampshire what
percentage of those hospitalized with
covet are hospitalized for covet versus
with covet
i will have a hard time answering that
with precision
because we also know there's that under
reporting because if you're still
hospitalized you're recovering from cove
but that's also still not reported and
captured after hospital association told
us one of the cleaner easier things is
to think about is to look when we see
the rate who are
intubated
in the icu and die and they're not dying
because they came in with
you know for total hip replacement and
incidentally were found to have covered
they were dying of coving so
yeah follow-up question thank you and my
follow-up question is i really
appreciate that you're looking to that
initial seminal study on this that that
evaluated in such a large population
i wanted to know if you were aware that
those in the placebo arm were offered to
cross over immediately
so that all the people who had
volunteered for the study wanted early
access to the vaccine so the crossover
rate was very large which seriously
confounds our long-term assessment of
risks i agree 100 but the data that i
was quoting was the data from the paper
which was prior to them crossing over
because you're absolutely right when you
cross over the data is no longer good so
they're not good for the long-term
information but this was the data that
was published as the results capturing
it i mean it was because of the positive
study that then they were allowed to
cross over
uh that's kind of routine an awful lot
of things we when doing a study you have
to have what's called equipoise that
means the two different arms have
sort of equal probability they might
work otherwise it's unethical to do the
study
sometimes you see that the study is
terminated early because it's such a
huge difference that it's unethical to
consider it back to ethics again and the
issue here to continue i should say but
otherwise you carry it out to completion
and after that's done then of course a
person may choose
to move off into the other treatment
group and that is always a potential
confounder but they were not moving over
prior to that final analysis that's the
final analysis prior to moving over
one more sorry the last clarifying
follow-up
does that that means that we're not
going to be looking at that original
trial for any sort of long-term safety
or efficacy because the crossover rate
was high enough that even if you go
intent to treat or actual treatment the
data is no longer valid and perhaps
theirs might give us a better signal of
long-term risk absolutely that that's
exactly you're right that's why we do it
we do all these studies to
identify is something effective and is
it safe
then it might get in this case emergency
approval for that one or later on final
approval
then there may be other studies done the
second study i discussed was a study
done in january well actually completed
in january it was done very quickly
because of the omicron actually due to
the pediatric surge so it's delta and
omicron both but the point is
that then yes then you have the
long-term surveillance post-marketing
surveillance is routine in drugs uh but
it is very aggressive in terms of covert
19 with the vares reporting and the
mandatory reporting
mandatory for deaths and other adverse
severe adverse effects
any additional questions for
representative
representative soloway
thank you mr chairman uh thank you
representative representative would you
believe
that in israel there have been three
million two hundred eighteen thousand
three hundred ninety one cases of covid
and only
9180 deaths one of the lowest deaths
rates reported
uh yes i would actually indeed the
united states has lagged behind a number
of other countries uh in terms of its
death rate as you all know we have with
the highest when the higher death rates
amongst the uh developed countries and
part of that is because of our low
vaccination rate that is
something it is we do have a
significantly lower rate than a number
of other countries i
you know our health care system has
other problems as well but
that's a major issue
thank you representative canuck as our
expert witness in support of the bill
now the chair calls
an expert witness to testify in
opposition to the bill dr
angelina farella from webster texas
good afternoon thank you for having me
um just for the record my name is dr
angelina farella i'm a pediatrician in
webster texas i have no financial
claims or conflicts of interest
i was invited invited here by one of
your representatives um
and uh i really want to on i want you to
understand that i've been very outspoken
about mandating children for the covid
vaccine and i hope that my talk will
bring up some very salient points i want
to first explain to you i've been in
practice for 25 years as a pediatrician
and prior to 2019
my office was pretty much 100 percent
vaccinated and in the state of texas
we follow acip
guidelines which in new hampshire
you do about half of what we do
so
you know for those of you that think
that i might be coming from a side that
opposes vaccine you're you're very
mistaken
um so
first i want to define what vaccine used
to mean and and what it what the
definition was that it stimulated
your immune system to produce immunity
and protect you from a specific disease
process and in that process
it would prevent the transmission of the
disease
why did the definition then change in
september 2nd of 2021
to
a preparation used to stimulate the
body's immune response
as you notice they stopped talking about
producing immunity
the history of vaccine development
usually takes five to ten years
especially in children
the development starts with animal
studies and then extensive safety phase
trials go into phase 2 and phase 3
before any kind of approval can happen
the coven 19 vaccine skipped animal
trials
it combined phase two and three and
unblinded their study prematurely so now
the control
group is moved over into a treatment arm
the demographics were skewed to younger
and healthier populations and excluded
please pay attention pregnant
and breastfeeding moms
those with autoimmune disease
those that were previously infected with
covid
those with bleeding disorders
it lacked good standards for testing
subjects for suspected disease
the outcomes in the first two months of
this trial were ignored there were
actually 20 deaths in the inoculated
group and 14 in the placebo group
of those 20 deaths 14 were
cardiovascular events
the adverse events that were also
reported in these first two months
were
they they broke them down into related
severe and serious the related adverse
events numbered 5241
in the inoculated group in the placebo
group it was 1311
which showed a 300 percent increase in
serious related adverse events in the
inoculated group 300
severe 362
events in the inoculated group 150
in the placebo group which is an
increase of over 75 percent
serious adverse events which include
hospitalizations and er visits were 127
in the inoculated group and 116 in the
placebo group which was up an additional
10 percent
but the outcome was not for death or
hospitalization with the pfizer trial it
was for cases
so
if you look at the case rate it was
eight per 18 198
subjects in the inoculated group for a
percentage of
0.04
percent versus in the placebo group
there was 162
cases
over 18 325 which gives you a
0.88 percent
case outcome
still less than one percent
post-marketing pharmaco villages report
which reported two and a half months two
and a half months after the emergency
use authorization
this was done in november 17th of 2021
there was in excess already of 1200
deaths
more than 25 000 nervous system adverse
events and there were concerns for
anaphylaxis and vaccine-associated
enhanced disease
this is not just a red flag people this
is a signal what we call in in medicine
a signal
july 27th of 21 the cdc actually
admitted that covid19 vaccines do not
provide immunity or prevent people from
catching the disease that's out of their
own mouths
all
in in children this is all risk and no
benefit the age group between 12 to 15
that study was underpowered there was
only a thousand kids in the inoculation
group versus 978 in the placebo group
statistically children are not at any
risk for death for covid19 but they're
at high risk for adverse events
in the age group of five to 11 the cdc
acknowledged that i'm sorry pfizer
acknowledged that their that myocardius
myocardius might happen
might happen in healthy subjects
myocarditis is an inflammation of the
heart where the muscle
is so inflamed that blood may not be
adequately delivered to the rest of your
body and this can lead to stroke or
heart attack the mortality rate is up to
20 percent at six and a half years post
event
we have to prove these things safe first
before we give them to kids kids are not
little adults
lots of stats that were thrown out here
are on adults
dr eric rubin who is the new england
journal of medicine editor-in-chief who
published the pfizer study
stated in the
trials that
it's okay to start giving it to find out
the adverse events just like rotavirus
let me explain to you in rotavirus
fibrovirus um
is a another viral disease that causes
high risk of hospitalization death in
small children
the rota shield was pulled off the
market after 59 cases of intussusception
which is a telescoping of the gut i was
a pediatrician at that time i worked in
the hospital and it was my job to walk
around to all those refrigerators and
pull the rotor shield out of the
refrigerators 59 cases of a non-deadly
process
it took them five years to get another
rotavirus vaccine back on the market
five years
and this was a fully
approved fda vaccine
the swine flu back in 1976
this was when uh president gerald ford
thought that it would be a good idea to
hurry up and get a swine flu vaccine out
there it was pulled after 25 deaths
pulled off the market 25 deaths
they also noted there was 500 cases of
gillian barr syndrome which is a
paralytic
disease associated with vaccination
kids have a 99.997
survivability
okay
all cases in all years of myocarditis
i'm just going to run these through real
fast so that you know with the covid 19
vaccine age five one
age six two age seven one age eight four
age 9 9 age 10 6 age 11 6 age 12 129
age 13
age 14
age 15 286
age 16 275
age 17 317
age 18
357 for a grand total of
1774.
1774 kids that received the covid
vaccine now have myocarditis that is a
lifelong condition will shorten their
lives and now they have to see a
cardiologist
every year or more frequently for
follow-up
at the same time we had
three precious five to eleven-year-olds
that died of heart attacks
399 kids ages 12
and young adults through 29 they skewed
the results 399 heart attacks dead this
is not normal children do not die of
heart attacks
in new hampshire since we're in new
hampshire i want to tell you about your
vaccine-reported adverse events in age
groups 5 to 11 you have 33 reports
sorry in age groups 12 to 18 you have
two deaths reported
secondary to the coveted vaccine
administration out of 167 reports
you have seven cases of myocarditis
13 hospitalizations and one permanently
disabled child
for kids this is all risk and no benefit
even the aap says that 0.1 to 1.5
percent of co-hospitalization is in
children
and of this 0.0 to 0.002
is a death from kovid
four states in our nation have reported
no deaths and as of january of
2022 new hampshire was one of those
so in new hampshire you've lost 2 223
citizens
and this is a tragedy
in the 0-17 age group again this is from
the beginning of february
there were none from covid
you had 183
deaths of children from 0-17 for all
causes
in the united states by contrast 0-17 we
had 770 children
die from covid or with covid
out of
463 kids that died of all other causes
covet association is one point one
percent of all possible pediatric
deaths one percent
the first tenant of medicine is do no
harm
first tenant the coven vaccine
is for the alpha variant and now we're
down the frat row of variance and there
it does not stop the spread of coven 19.
natural immunity is strong and durable
as the johns hopkins study just showed
21 months
just came out
we know that from the sars co v1 there's
18 years
of natural immunity proof
early outpatient treatment is still
available and it works
there's a tenant of causality as well
for epidemiology
and all of the tenants are satisfied to
unequivocally
show that these vaccines are causing
larger numbers of deaths than would be
expected
we have sadly lost 23 141 citizens in
the united states in association
to this covid19 vaccine
thank you
representative
audience will refrain from outbursts or
the room will be cleared representative
cushman
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
are you familiar
with the um
the issues with vares as far as how
often adverse reactions are actually
reported we know that it's required by
the law
i've been a nurse for seven years and
i've encountered patients with vaccine
injury and i've personally filled out
vare's reports but i can tell you every
nurse i've ever asked if they've ever
done it didn't even know that the system
existed and
are you familiar with the harvard study
it was harvard pilgrim in 2010 where
they found it was conducted in
conjunction with the health resources
services administration
found that it was estimated that only
one percent of all injuries are actually
ever reported to vares that's absolutely
true yeah that was a hopkins study um
that showed that the reporting system is
very um
arduous
although 70 percent of what is reported
on bears
is is from either a medical professional
or from the actual company itself
over 70 percent
so you have to understand that although
it's not
perfect it's not even close to being
perfect
because we're missing 99 of adverse
events as a pediatrician i'm well aware
of what bears is i could say in the in
prior to 2019 i've never had to make
any
reports to theirs and i'm very happy to
say that considering i have nearly a
hundred percent vaccination rate of a
vaccination schedule that's double
yours
and it's because i asked the pertinent
proper questions
and i have informed consent to my
patient population
which is not happening with the covet 19
vaccine either so
one percent is being reported and yes
it's a poor system but it's the best we
have right now and i can tell you it
takes over 20 minutes to try to report
one adverse event and just in my
personal private practice which is very
small i'm a solo practitioner i don't
come from a big university
um uh you know i'm independent and i
have seven
teenagers right now that i am trying to
treat for post-vaccination
problems that never had any problems
prior these were my patients since the
time they were babies
they went out on their own thinking they
were doing something for the greater
good
got themselves a shot
and now we're suffering
and no one can help them
and the sad thing is is that's what i'm
trying to do
even though we have no precedence
we're flying by the seat of our pants
here in medicine
and unfortunately we've monetized
medicine and that's a bigger problem
doctor
do i hear you when you say they went out
on their own these teenagers who on
their own
chose to get vaccinated without their
parents knowledge or permission so two
of the two of the no three of the seven
were under 18 and their parents were
with them
um so their parents were with them when
they got it
four of which i also treat kids up to 26
in my practice
so
um four the other ones were over 18 okay
so there were 18 19 young adults um and
they went on their own to do it one was
actually an emancipated minor she's
married okay a question from
representative king
thank you mr chairman and thank you
doctor for taking my question
um
i'm sure there's a joke in here about an
engineer trying to be a doctor
um but i'm not gonna go there um
anyway
uh dr kinnerk referred to a young man
who died swimming and uh he had a
thicker
uh ventricle
um
and then as you explained
could myocarditis
can the two of those be linked somehow
yes
so it's an inflammation of the heart
whether it's a part of the heart or the
whole heart it's still an inflammation
part of the heart and since we don't
know what his pre pre-status was
it's very possible that he had an
enlarged heart although in teenagers
especially those that have hit puberty
children are very different so
pre-pubertal those kids will stop when
they're tired once they hit puberty
athletes will push themselves to an
extent that is just beyond
ridiculousness and we if anyone that has
a teenager understands what i'm saying
so
these kids will maximize their heart to
such an extent that you know if it was
an adult we'd kill right over
these children are in excellent health
i mean you think about it they don't
have diabetes yet they don't have
hypertension yet there is absolutely no
reason why a kid should drop dead from a
heart attack especially in the age of
five to 11.
thank you
any further questions representative
acton
thank you mr chair and i thank you
doctor
as a father of a
10 year old daughter
i am
filled with vaccine hesitancy
due to the problem of of
getting real data
um
a lot of my sources have been censored
and de-platformed
and i'm very much worried about
what how this vaccine will affect
fertility for the future do you have any
information that you could
give us on that yes sir actually i do in
the japanese study japanese
before allowing pfizer to come into
their country which is why they're only
18 vaccinated
they they wanted studies from the
company to show distribution and the
distribution oddly enough is highest in
women's ovaries and in men's testes
we do not know what that means for the
future except that it's the distribution
of the spike protein which we know
is the problem
with covid it's the spike protein why
would the spike protein need to deposit
in an ovary that just doesn't make any
sense you know a vaccine's supposed to
stay in the spot that you inject it
just so that people know in case you
don't understand
and your body is supposed to develop
stuff where you inject it so if that's
in your leg or in your arm wherever that
might be
um and what they noticed in the
what the japanese had uh said to pfizer
is we need to see your distribution
studies oddly enough they did not show
the distribution to the brain and we
know we know for a fact because it's
causing neurologic problems that it must
pass the blood-brain barrier
it must pass it what we're seeing in the
neurologic realm is absolutely
terrifying
in pediatrics
and this is this is more anecdotal i
mean we know that in their study they
have 25 000 but i've personally seen one
patient 15 years old five hours after
getting that vaccine contour in ways
i've never seen anyone do before in my
life
and we also know that one of their
pfizer study patients
now is permanently disabled
with irretractable seizures
has to be fed with an ng tube this was a
perfectly
fine 12 year old whose mom
sat down through the informed consent
and thought this is a great idea let's
let's you know my child's going to be a
subject
and now
pfizer won't answer her calls
there's absolutely no repercussion no
one is helping this poor woman with her
12 year old daughter who is permanently
disabled this is seen with senator
johnson's senate trials
one of the things that you have to
understand as well because you're
talking to a censored physician right
here
um
is you're right there's there's a
there's a lack of professional
banter intellectual banter
you know we we never called the cdc or
nih and asked them how to treat our
patient ever
i did i did a rabbit hole study
in february of 2020 because i wanted to
make sure that if one of my patients
walked in the door
with
this disease that i knew how to treat
them
and i thought oh respiratory check got
that one i know how to use a nebulizer
albuterol and buds and i didn't give
oral steroids and maybe some
azithromycin if necessary how about an
antiviral we have tamiflu amantadine we
have oflusa we have a ton of stuff to
use and now we can't use it they say
there's no treatment
that's that's that's a censorship issue
for sure
other questions representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
being here and taking these questions i
know we heard before about the sudden
cardiac death in young men and and boys
that it's a real issue and that's when
we've we've changed how we do things
because we have these physicals to
prevent it i'm curious if these heart
attacks were similar to that if it might
be exacerbating an underlying condition
or if this is an entirely different
mechanism of heart attack because i know
there's lots of different kinds of ways
to die because of your heart right so if
you actually look at the pre covered 19
vaccine numbers and the posts look in
the professional sports
um that overall they lost maybe four
people per year
on the on the soccer fields or
professional sports okay four in the
whole world
we're up to over 24 now
that's a real short time and what's
we know that most professional sports
teams are requiring
the covid vaccine
they're requiring it
i mean we see this on tv all the time
the few outliers that are like i'm not
doing it
so
there's there's a real concern
especially when pfizer did not ever
check these young men i mean they could
have done things like d-dimers
pre-imposed they didn't do it they chose
not to do it even though they admitted
that there was a possibility of
myocarditis when they were going to do
the study on smaller children
like why would you subject a child to
heart disease
for a disease process that naturally
they have a runny nose for 12 hours
that's what they proved
that's what they proved adverse events
were high they may have lowered the case
rate but the adverse events were so high
that it does not justify
the benefit the risk benefit ratio of
this particular
vaccine is so out of whack
that anyone should be able to see this
you don't need to be a physician to see
this
okay i'm gonna let i'm gonna all out two
more questions from this witness
representative gay has one of them
thank you
thank you very much for taking taking my
question i used to take my mother to
webster for her doctoral
appointments
i'll just ask them together and you
answer what you want
how does teen myocarditis present
how many of your patients opted out
since you have never ever had to report
to theirs on your patients so far up
until coded
is anyone answering your calls on
treatment
so as far as the opt out for my patient
population um there are people that opt
out and if we have a reasonable
conversation um we wait we we change the
schedule a little bit that's totally
fine with me especially post covid this
has been been extremely eye-opening for
pediatrician who
um
honestly i i like vaccine i mean i have
i haven't had to stick a needle in a
kid's back for meningitis for 15 years i
haven't seen a whole bunch of bleeding
and
purulent ears gushing and i haven't sent
kids to the hospital for pneumonia
frankly
that's all because of prevnar
i like that particular vaccine it's
pretty dang good
but when we're talking about
the covid vaccine it's been there's no
animal studies these vaccines take 10
years it's not even been a year yet and
we have 1774
kids with heart disease it hasn't even
been out a year
wake up
this is dangerous
our signal
is less than
25 deaths
and we had in the post eua
over 1200 deaths
1200 deaths and to date
i know i have the date i know i have the
the number here
from the vaccine i mean it's like 24 23
149 deaths from this vaccine
when's it going to stop
thank you doctor we're going to be
moving it along more quickly now
anyone who has not asked a question of
the doctor um
representative soloway
sir thank you
mike
uh location ethnicity um age
distribution approximately just so i can
get a sense of what kind of population
you're dealing with sure
um so i'm from so my practices in
webster texas
um we that it's a suburb of houston so
houston has a catchment area of over
seven million people
um i don't catch all seven million thank
you
um we i see babies from
one day old all the way up
i take i keep some of my high risk
population kiddos you know that have
cerebral palsy
attention deficit disorder
down syndrome you know things like that
that really adult docs have a hard time
with i keep those kids
um
i've been in practice over 25 years my
demographics
are generally um
either self-employed
or insured patient population
um i have
in excess of
i've ten you know over the years i've
given tens of thousands of vaccines so
that tells you how many patients i have
a lot
um
and um as it's a mix because i am in
texas so we have hispanic we have white
we have black we have many international
because we're right next to nasa um so
we have a lot of international families
there
so we have a really nice
mix of every ethnicity
you know predominantly white just
because we're in texas i guess but a lot
of the hispanics consider themselves
white too if you ask them um
so we we have a very nice mix of
everything
thank you so much and thank you for
coming before us as promised two more
and i have done the two more
so now the chair calls paula mckinnon
from the new hampshire school nurses she
says she wants to speak for three
minutes
and you are in support of the bill
thank you for taking my testimony today
the new hampshire school nurses
association supports this bill just
three weeks ago dr chan and his team
reported 117
active clusters of covid19 in k-12
schools each one of those clusters had
12.8 cases per cluster
all policy considerations for schools
start with a goal of keeping students
safe and physically present in schools
vaccines are one of the best
preventative measures to create a safe
environment for learning vaccination
will decrease the disruption of
education by significantly reducing
outbreaks in schools and keeping kids in
school where they belong
the first step of course is the full fda
approval of the covid19 vaccine not
simply a temporary authorization and at
this time 50 states have requirements
for other vaccines in place for students
we cannot predict that there won't be
another variant like the omicron
let's get prepared to fight the fight
it's time to get coveted behind us just
like all other vaccine preventable
diseases
and i didn't use my three minutes um but
would you take a question i would be
happy to take a question or two
questions for ms mckinnon from the
school nurses
representative
weber
thank you mr chairman and thank you very
much for taking my question
um is the school nurses uh a membership
organization or is it just virtue of
status and and
if so what what are your membership
numbers i i should have introduced
myself in that regard i'm the current
president of the new hampshire school
nurses association we have 440 current
members it is a membership association
um and we represent the school nurses of
new hampshire
thank you
representative king
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um
you say fight the fight
is um
there are other
methods of fighting the fight other than
the vaccine
but a lot of people discredit them
things such as vitamin d and e
and zinc
and
building up your immune system through
healthy diet
sleeping and
uh maybe even chiropractic
um there's even been mention of
ivermectin and
um and yet
uh we discount those how do you feel
about uh alternative ways of fighting
the fight i certainly don't discount
many of the things that you mention
the more preventative measures that you
have in place
the better vaccines are one of them
vitamin d certainly is another one
proper sleep taking care of yourself
is certainly all of those things
when it comes to schools this isn't this
particular bill but when it comes to
school
you should be using all of the
mitigation
strategies that are available to you and
most of them are most of them are
masking most of them are taking
precautions for social distancing and
vaccination is the next step to get us
where we need to be so that we can have
our kids in school full time
one more question of
the nurse
seeing none thank you so much
where should i give the copies of my
testimony
here thank you for bringing written
the chair recognizes kathleen letter
she's wanted to speak for 10 minutes
you're not going to get 10 minutes you
are going to speak with incredible
articulation for about two minutes and i
will now hand around
the handouts that you provided okay
yeah i i um
two minutes it's going to be hard to do
but
i was
very very thankful to the doctor from
texas because she said it all
and i because that's where i started
from in my head was risk reward
and the papers that you're getting show
the actual most current
coveted cases in new hampshire
and the death rate
and
zero to nine um
one death this is for the whole period
of covid
that's zero percent
uh ages 10 to 19 zero
deaths
that's also zero so for the ages of zero
uh to 19 there were was one death
which is zero it's like zero uh uh
rate okay so that being said that's
the risk
of to these children
by the new hampshire statistics here
the
risk of the vaccine as a doctor from
texas i'm sorry i don't remember your
name
is much much much higher
and the thing that is not ever being
mentioned i just it drives me crazy
do you know does everybody here
understand that the pharmaceutical
companies have no liability
none
and that's huge i mean big pharma is
having a field day they're walking
around with billions of dollars
they're censoring
discussions around this will not be it
will not be allowed
um
and the whole various report the current
vares report is
is like right now it's like 23 000
deaths
124 000 hospitalizations
urgent care doctor's visits anaphylaxis
bell's palsy
permanent disabilities miscarriages
heart attacks
shingles it goes on and on
and um
and what's interesting is the lazarus
study which was the one percent
um
that's actually being reported to verse
that comes from a study that was done um
by
the they call it the lazarus study you
can look it up
um
but
but this is interesting the cdc oh is it
my done well almost it means you get two
very well put together paragraphs to
conclude the cdc actually
uh asked for the study this is how when
they didn't liked hearing that it was
only one percent effective this is what
the study concludes unfortunately there
was never an opportunity to perform
system pro system performance
assessments because the cdc contacts
were no longer available and the cdc
consultants responsible for receiving
data will no longer responsive to our
multiple requests to proceed with
testing and evaluation of the system i
think we could start with that and leave
us with that what i think we could ask
you now thank you so much for your
testimony
your final statement was was quite
telling thank you
oh okay thank you you know how i feel
then
thank you
now the chair will recognize the chair
will recognize tricia tilly and ann
marie mercury from the department of
health and human services
and
we'll bring the department up
or at least some of them
good afternoon my name is patricia
tilley i'm the director of the division
of public health services at the
department of health and human services
and with me i have anne-marie mccurry
she is the chief of our immunization
section
good afternoon chairman pearson and
members of the committee i am anne marie
mccary the immunization section chief
for the department of health and human
services
the department is here to provide
information on hb 1633 relative to
requiring cova vaccination for school
attendance and i'm just going to check
you can all hear me
thank you
the pfizer bion tech covet vaccine is
currently authorized for use by the fda
for ages 16 and older
for children 5 to 15 the vaccine is
currently under emergency use
authorization and review is currently
underway that may soon allow coven 19
vaccine to be available for children
five and under
under these criteria the legislation
would require anyone age 16 and over
including those in college to be
vaccinated for covid19 for school entry
the department has no intention of
adding immunization requirements for
code 19 at this time
as relates to covet 19 there have been
over 38 000 doses given to adolescents
in new hampshire
despite their lower risk of severe
covid19 disease children and adolescents
have been disproportionately affected by
cova 19 control measures
the most important indirect effects are
related to school closures which have
disrupted the provision of educational
services and increased emotional
distress and mental health problems
vaccination of student offers an
additional layer of protection against
covet 19 and can be an important tool to
return to normal
higher levels of vaccine coverage can
lead to less community transmission
which can protect against the
development and circulation of emerging
variants
the department seeks to appropriately
balance individual and parental choice
and the goal of keeping children
enrolled in school while protecting the
health of all children
in the event that a consensus to
recommend covet 19 vaccination
requirements for school in child care is
reached in the future the department
would then examine the key criteria
including but not limited limited to
vaccine efficacy vaccine safety severity
of disease likelihood of infection and
method of transmission prior to making
such recommendation
any administrative rule processes to
adopt a new school immunization
requirement would involve feedback from
public
pursuant to rsa 541 a 11.
the department supports the proposed
expanded definition of school in h.b
to include post-secondary institution as
proposed by hb 1633 however given the
novel nature of covet 19
a consensus to recommend covet 19
vaccination for school requirements has
not been yet achieved by the department
we continue to urge parents to educate
themselves on the benefits of coven 19
vaccine for eligible children and to
reach out to a child's health care
provider with any questions they may
have related to the disease
thank you very much for your time i'm
happy to answer any questions you may
have mr mccurry if there is no consensus
now
it would seem to me that if this bill
were to pass
you would have a mandate placed on you
that is correct
thank you mr lee
any other questions
representative delemus
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
aren't the variants
responses different to the vaccines the
different vaccines and isn't the vaccine
that's used for coven 19 specifically
targeted at like delta and the previous
variant and hasn't it been
discovered that the vaccine is
a lot less effective on the latest
variant and we don't know what it's
going to do with the other variants and
after hearing the anecdotal and
statistical evidence from the previous
speaker
don't you
think we might want to pump the brakes
on
giving these vaccines
without having
uh
trials
thank you very much for your question
um the
research is evolving about this
there's a lot to know know and what we
don't know about cobit vaccine
and about the disease the pandemic is
evolving in its nature
um as such i think that it is important
that we continue to consider what the
research is prior to making all these
recommendations so we are
really wanting individual families to be
able to have those discussions with the
providers
so that they understand
what is in the best interest of their
own child
any other questions for the department
seeing none thank you so much
and now looking at the stack of pink
cards i have
if you were just turned loose we would
be locked in for the night
since i don't see any sleeping bags or
teddy bears
i'm going to ask that truly
you speak in to two minutes
so those of you while you're waiting to
be called upon if you could write it out
boil it down
we would much appreciate that
chair calls christine
veno
vino
n-a-u-l-t yes i'm francais
all right
and this is my friend william
um
so again for the record my name is
christine vino um
we live here in concord i have another
son
and um i am here in opposition of this
bill
um
i
will chop down my testimony as much as i
can um
the doctor from texas did a wonderful
job at addressing a lot that i wanted to
say so
uh here i go
um
ready okay
what we're seeing right now
in no uncertain terms
are crimes against humanity in real time
it's hard to process what's blatantly
obvious sometimes but that's exactly
what this is
mandating this shot flies in the face of
medical ethics and bioethic core
principles
developed since the nuremberg code
it's bad enough that agency directors
and politicians have gotten away with
mandating the shot for adults as a
condition of employment but to try to
impose it on children as a condition for
education is a new low and knowing what
we know today it's immoral
there are multitude
there are multitude of reasons why this
concept and this bill are ridiculous and
why mandates are completely irrelevant
but let's start with the obvious
transmission it does nothing to stop
viral spread and in fact may actually be
increasing it
we're seeing something called negative
vaccine efficacy which means exactly how
it sounds that not only are the vaccines
not controlling infection and
transmission but they are actually
accelerating
infection and transmission
maybe we should spend some time looking
into that before we create a bunch of
school age super spreaders which is
ironically what the media has been
trying to scare us with all along
next we have the long-term safety
profile or complete lack thereof
no one on this planet can tell you what
the effects of the shot will be in five
years or ten years time yet the sponsors
of this bill would like to inject our
children
your children your grandchildren
with a product surrounded by unknowns
why on earth would we be so reckless
with a novel product on such a massive
scale
15 seconds oh boy
okay
um okay let's let's get right to it then
nelson mandela said there can be no
keener revelation of a society's soul
than the way in which it treats its
children it's fair to say that our
collective soul as a nation is in
turmoil it is fighting an internal
battle of good versus evil right versus
wrong
mandates of this product for any person
in any circumstance is baseless reckless
and utterly asinine
why are we pretending these shots
contribute anything to public health if
anything they're stripping it away
nothing has been as crystal clear over
the last two years as this
it's a charade and the majority is
finally waking up to it and we're
watching we're taking note of lawmakers
judgment of actions and of integrity
please oppose this bill
thank you thank you so much and thank
you for pronouncing charade correctly
thank you
the chair calls tara hafey did i get it
right
and katherine smith's on the on deck
circle
get ready
hi
my name is tara hafey i live in
brentwood new hampshire
with my husband and two daughters and
i'm here to speak in opposition to this
bill
i never expected to be here
but i want to share what happened to my
daughter because of a vaccine mandate at
her college
and how it has changed our life and our
family
for the past six months and is
continuing
my 18 year old daughter was subjected to
a coven 19 vaccine mandate in order to
attend the college of her choice
after 18 months of lockdown losing the
end of her junior year most of her
senior year
we she was excited to go to college and
we were really excited for her
we didn't want her to get the coveted 19
vaccine
because of some underlying health things
that she had
had nothing to do with her heart
had nothing to do with her respiratory
system
it was how she reacted
to medic medication
and other issues
no one would give her a medical
exemption
we put it off as long as we could
we waited until the last possible day
on august 4th
last year
we gave in
and she got the johnson johnson vaccine
a few hours later she was admitted to
the emergency room and that night i see
you
her resting heart rate her ekg was
abnormal
her resting heart rate was 174.
to put that in perspective for those of
you who don't know what a typical
healthy competitive athlete's resting
heart rate might be
it was typically in the low 60s
sorry i'm
uh
after she was admitted to the er she
said to me
mommy my heart hurts
my heart was breaking
she said mommy i wish i didn't get the
shot
i
will never forgive myself
for giving in to the college's mandate
and letting her get that vaccine
now understand
we tried we talked with physicians we
talked with people
no one felt she should get a medical
exemption
okay nobody
we're going to ask you to finish up now
if you would please so
one week before the vaccine my daughter
went was a normal she went to a college
incoming camp
late nights lots of laughs long days she
had a lot of fun
now
six months after her vaccine she's still
on a medication
to control her heart rate
she takes a nap every day because she is
exhausted
she's taken this semester off to focus
on healing
to be very clear with all of you
my daughter didn't have heart issues
before she got the vaccine
three minutes or two minutes isn't
enough to let you guys know how our
lives have been changed due to this
vaccine mandate
and i beg each and every one of you
to please vote in opposition
so that no one else ever has to go
through what our family has done the
choice
should be ours
it should not be mandated by anybody
to have this
unknown unproven vaccine
thank you for listening thank you so
much
thank you so much for coming
the chair recognizes catherine smith and
linda mcgrath is in the on deck circle
thank you for letting me speak um my
name is catherine smith and i'm
inhabited of chichester and i'm also a
registered nurse and i have a bachelor's
in science in nursing and i speak in
regards to house bill 1633 and by my
statement it is known that i oppose the
vaccine mandate for school attendance
my objection is based on the knowledge
that pfizer is on record for fighting
the release of the vaccination data and
research additionally the food and drug
administration has asked the courts to
further delay the release of the
vaccination data
this is what i was going to say but in
conversation with someone this this
information that i wrote this morning
based on a recent article is already
obsolete
and one of the things i'd like to
express you is a nurse who just got her
nursing degree about two years ago i
spent a lot of time doing research and
up-to-date data was really important
and this vaccine and all the information
about the covet is shifting sand
and i think that if um
people are quoting data and they're
using current information they're going
to very quickly find that that
information is obsolete based on the
nature of the what we're dealing with
population changes
so many variables and i just don't think
that it's fair to for us to ask our
children to do something that's going to
permanently affect their lives when the
information we have is so
there's just there's there's nothing
there's nothing solid to stand on i have
tried to
formulate an argument for and against
because of the nature of my work as well
as my social group i'm in the middle
i can't i can't substantiate either way
there's too much conflicting information
and i'd like to say i think it's really
important that if a person presents a
bill
then they should be sitting here
listening to people
and i'd i'd also like for mr is it mr
morris he should be in this room and he
should be hearing it it's shameful that
he's not
if you could if you could please keep to
the topic of the bill and not the people
and personalities would greatly
appreciate it i will
um
i think that
it's in good conscious for us to ask
ourselves how
we can look our children in the eye and
say
we made a decision that could
permanently alter their lives without
good solid information
we owe it to them to know
thank you
now we have laura oh sorry
i was shifting the cards we have linda
mcgrath and
laura condon is up
on deck
hi i'm linda mcgrath i have been a
pharmacist for over 40 years
and this young man here is why i no
longer have a job
thank you for bringing him
last year when
i was mandated in my job to inject the
kovid shot into children
i did a lot of research
and i
could not do it in good conscience what
everybody said here that we just don't
know nobody here
can know for sure and the risk benefit
is what we have to look at
so the three things that i asked myself
is
number one do they need it
the first year
of covid before the vaccines in sweden
no vaccines no lockdowns
no social distancing no children's
deaths
they don't need it
the second was does it work it certainly
doesn't work the way they said it was
supposed to work
and there's information on both sides i
truly i don't know what to believe and
nobody here can know
is it safe
i think is the most important question
that we're all asking ourselves here
today
and there's already been a lot of
information on that so i can
skip down to the part where i say i
admit i don't know what to believe
however the
basic tenet of medicine which was stated
here many times is first do no harm
i find myself not trusting the science
that is purported by the government
and i started to question this when for
the first time in my 40 years
i was unable to dispense a prescription
written by a doctor
for an approved medication for an
off-label use
it didn't make any sense
if you can just wrap it up thank you
i will
i will wrap it up with number one who
profits
big pharma
is the clear winner do you trust them i
don't
and
lastly i will say that
i couldn't live with myself
luckily i'm able to support myself
without a job my kids are grown
i don't have any bills
i'm blessed to be able to forfeit my job
so that i could sleep at night i made
that decision for myself and i
ask all of you to think about that
because if this turns out badly
thank you very much for your testimony
we have laura condon up now and gary
york is on deck
dr gary york is on deck
good afternoon i'm
good
hear me now
good afternoon my name is laura condian
i'm from bedford i'm the new hampshire
director of advocacy with the national
vaccine information center it's a
volunteer position i oppose this bill
that would mandate covered vaccines for
children there are a few technical
problems with the bill
you'll note that
it does call for
this rsa to
to
apply to all children who are residing
in the state
that is existing law and then if you go
look at
the definition of a child
a child means any person between birth
and age 18
years of age redefining school and
statute to include colleges
doesn't redefine child so the cut off
still is the vaccine requirements of the
state the cutoff is still at age 18. so
that's a technical glitch with this bill
um and
unless somebody wants to redefine child
to include those people over the age of
18.
and i don't know what the limit they
would put on it at that point
this bill seeks to repeal state law
protecting natural essential and
inherent rights
that's quite honestly offensive
we know that these coveted shots do not
prevent infection do not prevent illness
do not
prevent spread and do not prevent death
and this is per the manufacturers any
representation these shots will prevent
any of these things is misinformation
the coveted shots are causing harm and
death
in fact deaths do occur
here in new hampshire
there have been this many deaths from
covid that's
zero here in new hampshire there have
been reported two veers this many deaths
child deaths due to the coveted vaccine
that's two
one of those individuals is a 15 year
old girl
the other one is a 15 year old boy
from bedford we know him as charlie
um
i ask that um
that you find this bill without any
significant basis to mandate these
vaccines and you find this bill and
expedient to legislate thank you
thank you very much we have dr gary york
and
on deck is representative blazak
thank you
co-chair
representative
my name is gary york i'm from hopkinton
new hampshire and
i would like to
present uh
some reasons why this is
itl thumbs down for this bill
it's actually good news uh at least i
see that it is
i've come across some data from the cdc
that did a study on the zero prevalence
of
antibodies against coed for the age
group 5 to 11 years old
in november december
that
zero prevalence was
18 for the five to 11 year old
group
six months later
they report
a prevalence of 42
reflective of
exposure to the virus and forming
antibodies and not necessarily being
sick from the virus possibly
asymptomatic but these are unhealthy
children and the state is from
laboratories from across the country
so given that that was a large rise in
zero prevalence for the antibody i would
expect and i think it's reasonable to
expect that eight months later that
fully
more than half of kids five to 11 have
natural antibodies through exposure at
school parents whatever
and that's a pretty high
percentage and now historically if we
look at flu vaccines and if we consider
the omicron variant which is a very mild
flu-like illness
historically
manufacturers of vaccines try to
anticipate what the what the flu vaccine
will be for the upcoming years
and typically it's it's less than 50
percent
efficacious
so i think what we're dealing here is uh
the good news is that children
already
inherently have
antibody resistance to this
and i think they should be exposed to a
mild disease we should all be exposed to
a mild disease give us all a chance to
form natural antibodies to this
mild
variant of covid thank you
thank you very much
next i call representative melissa
blazek and julie smith is on deck
okay i'm short
i know
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record i am melissa
blasic and i represent hillsborough 21
that seat is not done to intimidate i
sat there earlier this morning and i
realized how people could think that's
not our intent
um okay i'll keep this brief um i just
want to quickly point out if i'm reading
the bill correctly that not only does
this bill mandate the covid vaccine for
k-12 but post-secondary schools as well
and it seems to
also mandate the entire k-12 vaccine
schedule for post-secondary schools that
means that all public and private
colleges and universities will have a
full schedule of mandated vaccines this
is incredibly unusual i could not find
evidence of a single state that
mandates all of their k through 12
vaccines for post-secondary schools
um
to be clear no state has mandated the
covit 19 vaccine for post-secondary
education none and to clarify the
question that was
asked of representative marsh before yes
this does apply to private schools as
well as public schools
i think the reason why this bill has
received so much attention is because
people are shocked by the audacity to
suggest to mandate this vaccine which is
still emergency use authorized for
children it seems incredibly premature a
healthy child is not at a statistical
risk from covid a child is at more
statistical risk from influenza or
drowning
lastly i would like to point out that a
basic tenet of our society is that we do
not place burdens upon children to
protect adults
over the last two years we have severely
lost sight of this philosophy and as a
result we have damaged a generation
physically emotionally and academically
as a society we need to reverse course
and protect our children thank you
thank you
next up we have julie smith and on deck
is leanne romano
i think they're pretty much
the same we have problem solvers thank
you so much for doing that
good afternoon committee members julie
smith from nashua in opposition
first let me say kudos to all the
parents who made sacrifices to be here
today to make their objections known
using their vacation time gowns of
expensive gas finding a sitter and or
spending hours at the wheel with
rambunctious kids did not go unnoticed
i'm here today for them and for those
absent who wanted to be here i am here
as a taxpayer to object to the
government trampling on their parental
rights this blatant overreach is denying
them access to the schools that i am
forced to pay for as someone without
kids i don't get to opt out of paying i
expect the enemy talking points to
include
suggested use of the newly minted
education freedom accounts to them i ask
how many of you also are actively trying
to undo them talk about hypocrisy
and let's look at the front man of all
the sponsors an eye doctor who sits on
the huggins hospital board of trustees
we're getting into personalities you
will confine your remarks to the issues
only
okay i'd like to reclaim my time please
as well we will decide that now you read
you read this and be finished please
as frank our devoted commissioner said
parents are the bottom line people
responsible for supervising their
education of their kids if they choose
to utilize the school in their zip codes
involuntarily funded by their fellow
taxpayers such as myself they are still
free market consumers
and
as my senator presented his bill on
january 13th the correct bill to support
sb288
parents have the right to decide
if their kids are vaccinated or not
and i'd like to finish by saying that
the testimony of the woman in the cobalt
blue blazer actually broke my heart
shame on the sponsor
and every
doctor in our legislature please kill
this bill now
and on deck is ed groves and remember no
personal attacks please this is about
the issues and not about the people
behind it
i think she left we have ed groves and
al brandano is on deck
thank you
uh
nice to see you guys again so yes my
name is ed groves i've been to a number
of these hearings uh over the past few
weeks
i like to call them freedom fighter
hearings
getting rid of mandates getting rid of
masks
but there's been a common theme on both
sides and i've heard it here today from
the professional testimony on both sides
we have actually been using our children
as guinea pigs lab rats whatever you
want to call it for the last two plus
years and this just has to stop
the damage we've already seen about the
suicide rates i was in a hearing
yesterday and there was a doctor in
there
there's
there's already stats what do you think
these stats are going to be in five
years if we continue to do this to our
kids we had three-year-olds that are now
five we got eight-year-olds that are now
ten
the woman in the cobalt dress i feel for
her my daughter's an 18 year old at
keene state college
she has been pressured to get
the jab she had a quote
school advocate she was a senior
pushing her literally telling her hey
courtney you might as well get
vaccinated now you're going to need it
for graduation that's just wrong that
was what the whole hearing was about
yesterday
our kids are scared she sat for a year
and a half on her bed graduating from
manchester central high school yay no
extracurricular activity
no prom no
think about that senior year in high
school is one of my greatest years of my
life and i'm 58 years old and i remember
my whole the point is we've done enough
damage to our children we we've got to
let them be free we got to get rid of
the masks we got to get rid of the
mandates we got to get rid of this
experimental drug and there's one way to
do it and you guys have the power to do
it
house bill 1022
ivor mektin i took it it works
there's so many studies i know we're not
here to talk about that
but please
please do your research on that
thank you
thank you i'll call ann oh sorry al
brandano
up and on deck is amanda mastroianni
thank you very much and thank you
everybody um
i'm gonna go in a little different
direction
human beings realize truth
as empirical or scientific
for instance
fear always drives the one they choose
first
science as defined begins as an educated
guess
throughout history science initial
initials premise has proven wrong more
than right
from the world is flat to now covert
mandate this now covert mundane hearing
science driven by fear leads to mistrust
and this is the most dangerous
miscalculation of all
why
because trust is like a soap bubble
and once it's gone it never really
returns
we are all well beyond the point the
tipping point regardless of blame
it's too late
so i share with you a line from the
bible that makes my point
give unto caesar what is caesar's
and give to god what is god's
in today's words
give unto the politicians what is the
politicians
and give unto the parents their children
back
when a politician or doctor takes
what is god's
then it is called totalitarianism
i ask you to be bold
do what is inherently human and right
you know this
please don't be the person or the party
just to to break this bubble this trust
is in
it's in our it's everything about us
don't break this trust
please do not support this bill
thank you
thank you very much
i call amon amanda mastriani to the to
speak and on deck as melissa ekumakas
thank you
the woman who gave her testimony about
her child's vaccine injury
that's okay
that was the quickest two minutes
she's a great example of how
moms know best of course that's not true
with every mom but it is true with many
moms
that mom knew better than those doctors
who wouldn't give her a medical
exemption
i'd also like to say thank you to dr
farella i echo much of what she said in
her testimony
i'd like to share what's known as the
physicians declaration
from the global
covid summit
as of
january 18th
over 17 000 doctors and scientists have
signed this declaration
we the physicians of the world united
and loyal to the hippocratic oath
recognizing the imminent threat to
humanity brought forth by current
covenanting policies are compelled to
declare the following
whereas after 20 months of research
millions of patients treated hundreds of
clinical trials performed
and scientific data shared we have
demonstrated and documented our success
and understanding in combating covid19
whereas in consideration of the risks
versus benefits
of major policy decisions thousands of
physicians and medical scientists
worldwide have reached consensus on
three foundational principles
i'm only going to mention the principles
i'm not going to get into each one
because i probably won't have time
the first principle is that healthy
children shall not be subject to forced
vaccination
principle number two
that natural immunity
people with natural immunity recovered
from sars cov2 shall not be subject to
any restrictions or vaccine mandates
three
that all healthy
agencies and institutions sell cease
interfering with physicians treating
individual patients
this was signed by over 17 000 doctors
worldwide
thank you
oh and i've sent all the substantiating
evidence to this entire committee via
email
sent
last night i believe around
10 p.m
well i'm a few days behind but thank you
that's okay
thank you i'll call melissa
ichimakis and on deck is kelly potenza
hi thank you for
hearing me my name is melissa konomakas
i'm from newton new hampshire
and i'm here to oppose this bill
i don't have any kids in the school
system right now i did before but i
don't anymore but i'm here to in support
of all the parents that
don't want to have their kids
vaccinated i
i personally have
a friend
her sister
got vaccinated and she is
deaf in one ear she shakes
a lot um probably a neurological
disorder she's no longer able to drive
and i also have a friend who's 25 um i
know he's not a child but still he
got vaccinated and he now has hodgkin's
lymphoma um stage four um just all of a
sudden
i think that um i can't prove that it
was from the vaccines of course i can't
prove that but
tom renz the lawyer said that there's
been a significant
percent higher percentage of people who
are getting cancer
from this vaccine
and
there's just no that the risks
completely outweigh the benefits and i
just urge you to
look into your heart and
ask yourself do you want your kids
to be harmed by a vaccine
your grandkids
just please
please consider
the kids
this is really really important
thank you
i'll call kelly potenza up to speak and
on deck is ruth marvin
so my testimony has changed now because
of a wonderful doctor that spoke into so
many of the points that we wanted to
give
my heart goes out to the woman and her
daughter
that injury
broke our heart
so i'm actually the person that wrote
the article
about charlie zink
i want you all to say his name and know
his name
that's the that's the 15 year old boy
from bedford that died
he's now known as
17649 seven four
in the vares which is the vaccine
adverse event reporting system
this is how i started the story
when i heard of this extremely
heartbreaking story of a 15 year old
male teen drowning
in bedford new hampshire
on june 20th 2021
i was surprised and saddened
the obituary clearly articulated the
short but amazing life charlie had
after reading almost every news story
published to understand what happened to
this bright vibrant healthy athletic and
handsome young man i along with several
other granite staters some who know this
grieving family personally
realized something didn't add up
there were many logical question
questions surrounding his death why
would a healthy teenager who was a good
swimmer who used this rope swing on
dozens of occasions at the same pond
suddenly forget how to swim and die from
drowning
did he hit his head
did he accidentally knock himself out
what really happened that day
many great granite staters are very
confused and very concerned thank god
the family had an autopsy
there is no doubt that charlie's inc was
ver's id
176-4974 there is little question from
the autopsy results that charlie
suffered from an acute heart injury at
the time of his death
it is well known by medical experts that
one relatively common sign of cardiac
injury displays as unilateral shoulder
pain when charlie surfaced after he hit
the water he said wow
that hurt
he always went underwater to swim to the
door
one can conclude that
he could have been referring to the
cardiac injury myocarditis myocardial
infraction etc while hitting the water
or sometime around that event
i know i only have two minutes i do want
to say a couple things
the vaccines are the one okay i
appreciate that
um
the vaccines and that's the only time
i'm going to say this here because it is
not a vaccine it is an experimental
gene therapy injection those are the
variants that is why the children in the
school from the nurses association those
the reason why these kids are sick right
now and are testing positive is because
you just injected them all
let's be clear on that
and i know we're not supposed to say any
names
but rep woods rep kirk and rep shapiro
please better pull this bill and i want
this exact today all right you are
finished you will leave now
if you're not supposed to
don't do it
not whatever
next we call ruth marvin and on deck is
dr christine asnow i hope i said that
correctly
thank you for letting me speak i'm a 61
year
wife for 39 years three beautiful
children
and five grandchildren
and i'm here to speak for the children
all the children in this class got
coveted
sick for a day a fever a cough a cold
um
all of his schoolmates got coveted
they're not even sick and we're keeping
these kids away from each other
i just can't believe
that this bill would even be available
me i raised all my kids and i made all
the decisions about their health care
with my doctor
my grandson now who's 11 years old has
panic attacks he was a healthy boy
until all these stupid restrictions
um
that they're not even getting sick my
daughter took him to the doctors did all
that he can't breathe his heart
everything and they said no he has panic
attacks now
and the doctor said he's not alone i'm
seeing lots of kids come in
with panic attacks
i'm seeing lots of kids she said the
suicide rate of the children has gone
skyrocket depression
um
what we're doing to our children i just
cannot believe that
people want to inject them with this
this vaccine and i have a grandson my
oldest one he's 14.
he got damaged from a vaccine to where
he had bleeding of the brain
so
it shouldn't be up to any one of you
people in here to make decisions for
parents what's good for their children
and i you leave it up to the the family
their doctor and then you make a
decision but
little charlie he had a whole life ahead
of him and little maddie she's in a
wheelchair with an ng tube the rest of
her life she was incredible the clinical
trial
and the mother can't get help she's
millions of dollars in debt insurance
isn't going to help her because it was
experimental drug
and
you know i just it i could see if the
kids were getting sick but they're not
they're not getting sick
and i just ask everyone to oppose this
bill please do not have blood on your
hands of children because if we start
enforcing this
we could have a lot of blood on our
hands
thank you very much i'm called dr
christine asnow and on deck is dr
jennifer jones
um
so sorry about that oh i apologize
if i can have those ones back those are
for the next one
then we have one last card for this bill
i will call up
thomas macleod please
thank you madam chair member of the
committee my name is thomas mcleod i
live in mount vernon
uh representing today health freedom new
hampshire a non-profit
citizens advocacy organization with
about
hundred
constituents throughout new hampshire
uh health rim new hampshire opposes hb
uh 1633
we continue to believe that fewer
mandates with robust exemptions in place
are the best way to prevent vaccine
adverse events including death
that's it
thank you
thank you very much
with that i'll close the hearing for
house bill 1633
oh did you have a pink card that was
submitted
there was
oh sorry what's your name
yes yes if you could please come up i
will reopen that so that i can do this
correctly i apologize i'll try yes i
will reopen the hearing for 1633.
okay
leanne romano litchfield um i just
we've been doing this for months now i
i had a a really good speech and i had
to whittle it down to three minutes but
all i can say at this point is i was in
tears when that woman described
her college student
because that's my biggest fear
it's my biggest fear that my little 13
year old rock star of a catcher does not
even think she can go to college on a
scholarship because she can't go to a
new hampshire college i said hey we're
going to go to florida mama we'll figure
it out she doesn't even have a desire to
even progress forward she just wants to
play her whole softball team is
vaccinated she is not
and she's kind of she
she's really bubbly and she's awesome
and this isn't just about my kid it's
about many kids she has a ton of friends
that are not vaccinated and we all feel
the same way we're shunned in school
everyone's like do you have your vaccine
i'm like you really talking about this
we do not need mandates in schools we've
got enough vaccines we are not in
jeopardy of all dying because of the
children i don't think there's been any
deaths in litchfield's
at this age group
and i don't want to see this going into
colleges i want to be able to think
about the future with my my little ones
and i have one in high school and i have
one in in middle school moving up to the
high school you do not have the right to
tell us we the parents
we birthed these children at least i did
okay
you didn't
we can make solid choices i'm an
intelligent woman my husband is an
intelligent man we have a business we've
been making decisions for in my case
almost 30 years because i have a
29 year old they're alive and they're
kicking and they're actually doing very
well
and i i don't think that you need to
tell me what i need to do with my
children so please
i oppose this bill you should too as
everyone has said there's going to be
blood on your hands do you want that
imagine if someone told you or your
children what to do with your
grandchildren or your children
i have nothing else to say please oppose
this please you don't have that right to
tell us what to do
thank you very much um remember we stay
quiet in the hearing so we can make sure
everybody's here but thank you very much
everybody for your testimony i will
close the hearing on house bill 1633 for
real this time
jerry this is actually 5301.
whenever
i absolutely
[Music]
ugh
you know
but i don't necessarily know
give us correction but respect
solutions
um
okay
i just think the consensus
yeah thank you thank you
thank you
i'm not
but at sure time
took me two minutes
i mean i don't know who reports is
um
i want to hear you but i can't hear you
with them
realized
wow
hi
i want to know
yes
assuming
[Music]
okay thank you
thank you
here
the hearing on house bill
oh we're getting a pile 10 35
relative to exemptions from school
vaccine mandates
and the chair recognizes
representative tim lang
from belknap four that's north of my
district isn't it everything's north of
your district
thank you ladies and gentlemen of the
committee my name is representative tim
lang i represent belknap four coming
around is um actually i'll tell you how
nice of a guy i am is uh written
testimony in opposition to my bill that
someone asked me to distribute which is
there
uh
please from the basically the maturity
of a committee chairman sir thank you
so again i'm tim lang i'm the uh
three-year third term representative i'm
the currently the chairman of the house
fish and game committee and i'm here to
introduce house bill 1035 which is
relevant the exemptions of
school vaccine mandates
this bill on its faces is a fairly
straightforward bill you can tell it's
only one paragraph it didn't go into
multiple pages
and one of the things you have to so we
establish a common understanding is that
this is a lot of this is already allowed
by law we already have an exemption
statute in our in our immunization or
communicable diseases statute under 141c
that allow
children to be able to get
exemptions currently just under two
categories medical and religious
this bill adds a third category called
conscient called conscientious objector
conscientious objections
so
how i got there so i'm going to quickly
read
a little section from our state
constitution
so under a state constitution article 3
it talks about society it's or it's uh
organization and purposes and it says
when a man enters into a state of
society they surrender up some of their
natural rights to that society in order
to ensure the protection of others and
without such equivalent the surrender is
void
so had their founders stopped right
there i would say that maybe this is one
of these rights that we give up however
that's not they continued on with
article number four right after article
number three the right of conscious
unalienable i had to look up the word
unalienable it means that which is uh
cannot be given or taken away
so again they titled it specifically
uh rights of conscience unalienable that
did not be given or taken away
among the natural rights some are in
their very nature unalienable because no
equivalent can be given receipt or
received for them of this kind is the
right of conscience
again so i'd go further on you look in
the constitution i go well tim you know
so it doesn't say anything about
religion so maybe religion we should get
rid of that that exemption except that
we go on to article five and again it
specifically calls out religion and says
religious freedom is recognized
every individual has a natural and
unalienable right to worship god
according to their dictates of their own
conscience
and reason and no subject shall be hurt
molested or restrained in this person's
liberty or a state for worshiping god in
a manner that manner and season most
agreeable to their dictates of their own
conscience or in his religious
profession settlements persuasion
provided he does not disturb the public
peace or disturb others in their
religious worship
so again it's pretty clear in our in our
constitution we call out two specific
rights uh that being the right of
conscience and the right of religion
so it makes sense that those things are
in there
i find it kind of one the right of
conscious or conscious objector is the
is one of the discussion points that
i've had most why we're adding this and
i i find and usually i get it from
doctors like wow that shouldn't mean
anybody tim can do it i find it kind of
hypocritical is the word i'm going to
use
because under hhs.gov right from the
federal website
conscientious protections for healthcare
providers
and right within the hhs website this is
your right of your conscious rights
conscience protections apply to all
health care providers who refuse to
perform accommodate or assist with
certain health care services
on religious or moral grounds
where is this again police that's from
the from the
federalhhs.gov website it's hhs.gov
conscience conscious protections dot
html so when it goes on to say you may
file a complaint under the federal
health care provider conscious
protection statutes if you believe you
have experienced discrimination because
you and one of the items is were coerced
into performing procedures that are
against your religious or moral beliefs
so hear the same doctors saying no we
have to give vaccines and at the same
point they have protections like if i
don't believe it i don't have to do it
so it is a little little hypocritical to
me that we have this conscientious
objector component that they're
protected from and yet they don't want
to give that same protection to our
citizens
so the second thing this bill does after
adding the conscientious objector
is
i do away with the data point
so if you look at the bill the bill says
it actually defines the form
that a parent would use to have their
children exempt from
the law
and the reason that form is there is
because you're not declaring which of
the three exemptions you are just merely
that you fall within one of the three
why because we just passed article 2b
that says the government doesn't need to
collect your private information so why
should i have to release to my doctor
for my child that he has myocarditis or
has a potential myocarditis and
therefore he doesn't have to get the
vaccine why does the government need to
protect have that data i should be able
to just assert the privilege and that's
all that's needed same with the
religious perce uh provision why do i
have to prove that my child is religious
enough to be entitled to a medical uh a
religious exemption again these are data
points the government are going to
collect from our chu from us and for our
children that i think is inappropriate
especially in light of article 2b which
says that the government shall not
protect uh collect our private and
personal data
um the last thing i do in this bill is i
take away the notary requirement
um again this is an onerous provision
that that you can go and register your
child spend twenty thousand dollars of
tax money to have your child educated in
the public school system you never have
to have anything notarized
unless you want an exemption then you
gotta go find a notary and deal with all
that hassle to get a notary which just
seems like an onerous provision on our
citizens when i can spend 20 grand of
state money but i can't i can't have my
kid not vaccinated without getting some
notary to sign a piece of paper
um
so the last point i'm going to bring up
two points one more um one of the
reasons for taking away that data point
was i was really concerned when i heard
on september 12th of this last year the
u.s
surgeon general murthy dr murthy
says that he's going to start monitoring
religious exemptions to see if they're
going to be if they're abused
that was a statement made by our u.s
surgeon general so what that means is
government's going to start measuring
whether you're spiritual enough to be
entitled to a religious exemption that
should be chilling to everybody in this
room the idea that government's going to
start mandating and worrying about and
finding out if you're really religious
enough to get that exemption or not
so the last point i make is more of just
another data point and i i'd asked does
anybody have any idea what percentage of
cities of our children are uh
unvaccinated in our state that ask for
medical or religious
2.6
over 90 of our citizens our children are
vaccinated and and that's through the
voluntary vaccination requests even with
the exemptions we have
so when we think about herd immunity and
that's the other one tim if you put this
bill in we're going to lose hurt
immunity in our schools we won't be able
to do it herd immunity threshold is 70
percent
so
70 is the threshold the beginning part
of where herd immunity goes they say
anywhere from 70 to 90 but the threshold
is 70 for herd immunity we're well
beyond that
our children are not out doing this i
would also postulate that
anybody who has
conscientious objector exemptions are
already probably using medical exemption
anyway the medical or the religious
exemption anyway in filing this bill
will not drastically change
the number of people filing for
religious or medical or conscientious
objector exemptions i doubt it will go
much much beyond three percent and it
just allows our citizens to be honest
instead of instead of having a
conscientious objector i'll give you the
example i call it the organic lifestyle
there are people that choose to grow
their own chickens and and get their own
eggs and and grow their own crops and
step away from
you know modern life if you will
industrialize food and those kind of
things those people choose to live an
organic life my ex-wife is one of those
and i eat some really weird stuff
but given that um one of the things that
i we we do is we look for healthy
alternatives before medical alternatives
so in my case my family has a history of
heart disease so when i went to saw my
cardiologist when i turned 50 years old
they wanted to put me on a statin drugs
my mom and dad both died of heart
disease and two brothers that died of
heart disease i didn't have any
indication of heart disease but they
wanted to give me a preventative
medicine because that was the history i
had in my family and i was like is there
anything we can do before you put me on
a drug i gotta take for the rest of my
life
and the answer was yeah diet and
exercise i'm like great so i went on a
diet and exercise and as you can tell
i'm not in bad shape i wouldn't say i'm
in great shape but i'm not in bad shape
and when they put me on my treadmill for
my test i ran 21 minutes on the
treadmill no sign of coronary disease
they said thank you mr lang have a nice
day keep up what you're doing
but otherwise i've done modern medicine
i would've took a pill every day
and and we shouldn't make our people do
that there should be alternatives we
should allow people to live the
lifestyle that they want to live
that protects them that's morally right
for them
and for therefore that's why you have
this bill in front of you be happy to
take any questions
of the representative representative
nada upham
uh thank you chairman thanks for taking
my question representative um
i just wanted to clarify that you said
90 of the children in new hampshire are
vaccinated and that's the measles mumps
rebel those
based on last year's census numbers from
doe which i pulled right off their
website it was actually it was only 2.6
were unvaccinated but then they have
what they call preliminary which are
kids that have not turned into paperwork
yet so i said 90 be nice i think the
number's higher but i said 90 to play it
down as short as possible i think the
number's probably closer to 94 to 95
okay thank you very much let me clarify
i may have missed something but you said
vaccinated does that mean vaccinated
against the traditional things like
polio and so on but not covet this is
not a covert number that's correct my
bill is not covet specific and this is
relative to the standard
under
141 c
20 is that it 20 um has the
vaccines that are required to attend
school and it's the kids that meet that
requirement under the current law
thank you
any other questions representative
delemus
thank you mr chairman actually i wanted
to just direct it to you did we receive
written testimony from representative
lang
did not but i can submit it if you'd
like
representative leon thank you mr
chairman and thank you representative
lang for taking the question
when i look at this it seems that right
now we do just have to have the
notarized form for religious exemptions
do you think that this further would
protect um protect against any overreach
like we're seeing from the surgeon
general and some of these companies that
are compiling people's religious beliefs
and do you think that broad line's even
more important when you have students
who have a permanent record who's
assembled with all of these records yes
i do again i i think that anytime
government's starting to collect
personal data especially about what my
religious beliefs are that's something
that should cause everybody to go uh
wait a second
you know government doesn't have that
need or that requirement nor should they
do it
representative merchant
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
i think i'm following along with you
except
i'm not sure whether a parent has the
where for all or the knowledge to
declare something being medical
i think i can understand the religious
conscientious part of it but the medical
part i think should still reside with
medical people so if you go back and
look at the statute
and the first part it says if you want a
medical one you have to go to a position
somebody who has the medical knowledge
and training to give that exemption
however if you want a religious one a
conscientious one you could actually do
that yourself
so
so that
right now under current law you only do
medical and religious medical requires a
doctor's note religious requires a
notary um adding conscience subject to
your right
again one of the reasoning for doing
that is taking away a data point if i'm
not if a parent isn't asking for any
other accommodation other than the fact
that my child's not going to be exempted
then why do i need to give medical data
to the school well again myocarditis has
nothing to do with the kid in school
he's not asking for any other extra
accommodations other than an exempt
an exemption from the vaccine
representative
you wanted to follow up sure sorry
i think i'm tracking with you so
basically
um if we go back into the statute as
written now and at that point in time
strike notarized form
and then add conscientious to religious
with that satisfy we're trying to get to
because that still allows for the
medical to be done by the medical people
if you're telling me that's the only way
the bill will be passed yes i'll accept
that thank you representative folsom
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um
did you know that there are 25 federal
agencies that are collecting
this
religious information or for the
religious exemption
and they are collecting
date of birth
the name contact information
religious affiliation and the reason for
seeking the exemption
and one that i cannot figure out why
they need this is the
transportation secretary
well again you know i the point of that
one of the main points of this bill
isn't just to add to conscience
objectors to take away the data point
that the government can collect because
again under our our constitution uh
article 2b which was just passed in 1980
1918 and i mean like 2018 i think it was
when i my first term in the legislature
and it passed with an 85 percent
um vote our citizens don't want
government collecting our data so this
bill goes along the lines of that that
and allows you to ask for an exemption
without having to disclose personal data
to the government
representative shapiro thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking this
question
um
you made i would say you made some very
compelling um arguments based on
rights of conscience and um
also on the fact that the
amount of the number of unvaccinated
people the percentage of unvaccinated
children is very small and that you have
reason to believe that that would not
change very much
um and i'm not
disagreeing with you necessarily
but you also made comments started off
your comments
talking about the constitution and the
kind of balance between the common good
and personal freedom
so i'm wondering that if this bill was
to pass or if
you when you contemplate this bill
passing
and you were wrong and the number of
unvaccinated children increased
dramatically
um
at what point would you feel like
that was a problem
or would you not feel like that was a
problem because there have been
outbreaks of some of these illnesses in
areas where people have not been
vaccinated their children so my question
basically is at what point
could you conceive of this becoming a
problem if the number of unvaccinated
increased
so
looking at this bill it's you know i
talk about looking through a straw
sometimes so if you just look at this
bill and you look through a straw you
see just that one thing but you forget
there are a whole bunch of other
infectious disease statutes including
statutes that give the commissioner of
health and human services emergency
oversight privileges so if there was an
outbreak the the commissioner has
authority to act differently and change
rules right so we're talking about in
the regular course of life right and so
the commissioner which i think you heard
an oversight
bill today um so again the commissioner
has during outbreaks different authority
to do different things and so again i
i'd urge you not to look at this through
a straw
but to look it as a big painted picture
right this is just one piece of that
picture and that is that in under normal
circumstances our parents have the right
to choose to be exempt from this from
vaccines or have their children exempt
in the case of an outbreak there are a
whole new set of rules um and that's
outlined in the communicable disease
statutes
thank you
representative gay
thank you mr chairman are you concerned
if we struck that
option to be a
objector for medical reasons you know
parental
medic
i don't know how to say this
but right now it's medical religious or
conscientious
if we struck the medical
wouldn't that risk make us risk what
happened to the lady who testified in
blue that they couldn't find any doctor
who was willing to write a medical uh
exemption
well so the good thing under my bill is
that the medic you're not declaring
anything so you don't need a doctor's
note if you pass my bill as it's written
um if you go to um the suggestion of
leaving chapter one in which deals with
medical and just adjusting uh chapter
two and adding the conscientious
objector in there and taking away the
nota requirement you would still have
the medical you can't strike medical
because we also have the whole again you
can't look through a straw we have the
whole federal ada you know american
disabilities act which has which also
oversights the met the reason for
medical exemptions is because you have
certain medical conditions that require
unique
action by an employer in this case by a
school district so again you can't look
through a straw that if you struck
medical you would still be we'd still be
subject to ada and an american
disabilities act for a parent who chose
to disclose a medical condition and
request an accommodation
representative soloway mr truman this is
a point of personal preference i just
want to inform you and the committee
that the snow has begun to fall east of
here and is scheduled to begin here
momentarily
thank you sir i'm playing it by ear and
thank you for reminding me
um okay who anyone anybody else
thank you rip
you got it in under the wire
representative cushman thank you mr
chairman
um i momentarily forgot my question let
me try to appreciate it
um
we'll come back to you i try to
entertain you but i can't sing for snot
so
would you agree or disagree with what
she was thinking
[Laughter]
if it's leah i would have a
representative cushman i would probably
agree i think the correct answer is yes
i would anyone else and i'm buying a
little bit of time and i hope she's
using it to uh she is
no okay
thank you
thank you mr chairman i'll be in the
room if you have someone remember
something
representative jerry kanerk
has 25 copies
and this is on
it we'll say on the top it's on house
bill 53
oh no dyslexia was only once and by the
way
the forgetting stuff gets worse as you
get older so get ready
yes i did distribute testimony regarding
this just a little while ago um
so
i think i really thank representative
lang for not bringing a bill about
coveted vaccines
it is important to realize that it is
about a number of other well-established
long-standing long-standing accepted
vaccines
it expands the available exemptions for
required immunizations for admission to
a school or child care agency public and
private that is in the statute already
the reason
that these
immunizations are required to attend
schools and child care is that
schools and child care are incredibly
effective settings for the transmission
of communicable diseases especially
respiratory diseases and any parent in
this room can certainly vouch for that
now because hb1 1035 automatically
grants an exemption just with a request
including for conscientious rejection
which uh is also not actually defined
it essentially removes any requirement
for immunization
um
the
and i should also comment when vivek
murthy made that comment about
abusive religious exemptions i think he
was speaking explicitly about covet and
it had due to the fact that people would
ex requested a religious exemption for
one vaccine but not for others which
would indicate an inconsistency
with regard to conscientious objection
uh i applied as a co in the draft back
during the vietnam war and i had to
actually still have my six page essay
that i had to write
justifying why i felt that i was a
conscientious objector there's nothing
here other than just saying i object so
that kind of takes it away
also i want to comment just quickly
about that comment about a vaccine
that was stated earlier that these
things aren't really vaccines you got to
understand that the definition about a
vaccine that produces protection from an
infectious disease the current one has
to do with the fact that vaccines have
evolved let's think of the 1950s if we
defined what a telephone is
it's a thing that sits on your desk with
a wire going to a handset with a speaker
and a microphone and then it has a wire
that goes to the wall if you any of our
grandkids would only see that in a
museum so we do have to update
definitions it's important to realize
that for example not all uh vaccines are
giving you a
pathogen uh the tetanus vaccine is not
at all against the clostridium tetani
it's against the toxin that is
elaborated by clostridium tetani to
protect you from disease so we are
talking about
broadly diseases or in what's in the
chapter immunizations and the acquired
immunizations on 141 c 28 are diphtheria
mumps pertussis polio rubella rubiola
and tetanus
vaccination has been one of the most
effective public
uh health measures in the history of
mankind
if you've ever gone out and explored
some of our old cemeteries and we have a
lot of them
it's kind of interesting to notice in
the 18th and 19th century how many
children died young
often you notice notice that in one
little family plot there's going to be
two or three kids that all died the same
month
why is that
well it's frequently from infectious
disease
and diseases we now control either with
vaccination
or bacterial diseases we control with
antibiotics
i've cared for patients who contracted
polio before the vaccine was developed
my most memorable
being a patient who was my age who
contracted polio just before the vaccine
was available
leaving him with severe paralytic
scoliosis
and when i met him he had about seven
failed surgeries on his spine
leaving him bent forward to the side and
in constant pain and i completely took
apart his spine and refused him with
rods and screws which were not available
when he had all of his previous
operations in a 22-hour long operation
and i often thought about the fact that
that could have been me
that could have been my problem except
for the luck that i had
dodged the bullet before the vaccine was
available
we've seen scattered outbreaks of polio
secondary to lack of vaccination in the
occasional communities and we've also
seen as you've all known as i alluded to
earlier scattered outbreaks of measles
because of inadequate vaccination rates
and they don't have to get below 70
because measles is highly contagious and
if you just have a relatively low
vaccination rate you can have an
outbreak
so yes one could argue that a parent
should be able to make this decision for
their own child
but the difficulty is that their
decisions that decision does not just
affect
their child
it affects other children
they need to accept the responsibility
that their unvaccinated child may infect
another
vulnerable child
in the school because a high level of
vaccination is very important to protect
those vulnerable individuals who are
medically unable to be vaccinated
and those who are immunosuppressed
and may not be able to mount a good
response either to a vaccine or
ultimately to an infection
so the exempted child would place others
at risk
now there's an occasional rare exemption
because of
religion or because of medical that's
not a problem but if we open up the door
and allow lots of exemptions it could be
a problem
and that's what i'm concerned about
i should mention that dr lynn then
painter a retired physician in concord
wanted to be here to testify and gave me
permission to tell their story
he noted and i did provide this to you
on the testimony quote during my
training i spent time in bangladesh for
basic immune immunizations available to
every american were unavailable
i observed children literally dying of
preventable infectious diseases such as
tetanus it was a gruesome and
unforgettable experience this bill opens
the door for a return to earlier times
in the u.s when infectious diseases such
as diphtheria whooping cough scarlet
fever and polio were dreaded scourges
mandatory school vaccination
vaccinations have served us so well
that these diseases are now uncommon
and many of us have forgotten that
childhood deaths were commonplace in the
era before vaccines were widespread and
if you do want to remember go for a walk
in an old cemetery
so i am concerned
that the reason for our good rate is our
current law
and that weakening this with making
exemptions just
basically filling out a form and not
having to have any evaluation medically
or any attestation as to why you
conscientiously object
uh we'll potentially drop our
vaccination rate quite a bit and that
will take us potentially back to the
18th century
and move this to a third world status of
disease and suffering so i don't i do
not really favor this bill thank you
very much any questions for the
representative
thank you so much
representative acton
thank you mr chair and uh thank you uh
representative for taking my question
the
to
to get a to take a vaccine i i think
requires
education and informed consent it seems
as though we've moved away from
from
convincing people to compelling people
how do how do we get back to
convincing educating and making informed
decisions rather than just pure force
which isn't working out too well
well actually i come back to precisely
what representative ling pointed out in
our part one article three of the
constitution that when men had turned to
a state of society they just read up
some of their natural rights to that
society in order to
guarantee their to ensure the protection
of others
and that's the whole point it is really
to
to help protect others as well and
that's the only reason that's why we
don't mandated
vaccinations for example for
non-communicable diseases and that is in
statute that we do not mandate
vaccinations for non-communicable
diseases
that makes good sense but again if you
have a communicable disease you can
therefore transmit to another person
you are your decision not to
affects others and if we're going to
enter in society we may have to give up
some of those rights but i agree with
you about informed consent that is a
very important part and it is actually
i mean when i got the covet vaccine i
sort of had to go through
a informed consent now most the time
people don't spend much time on it i
agree
representative
cushman
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative kanark
uh
my question is you mentioned how
you keep saying how you know
if we don't require vaccines
you know we're putting up other people's
we're putting children of
families who do choose to vaccinate or
maybe they can't vaccinate because of
a medical reason
at risk
but
you could say the inverse of that where
mandating that kids get these vaccines
is still putting people's children at
risk so
wouldn't you think that the best
possible solution to that because
there's risks on both sides is to allow
the parents to choose
actually your point is exactly well
taken that is that you are by mandating
placing some other children at risk but
you have to look at then the overall
risk benefit analysis and we
those do still end up being in favor of
vaccination rather than in favor of not
vaccination for these kind of
well-established and again that's why
i'm glad koben's not in here because i'm
not so sure that it does meet that
criteria for that necessarily
follow-up
thank you
i understand you're you're alluding to
an aggregate greater benefit to
vaccination but
when we're talking about individuals
if if a person's child ends up vaccine
injured
you know that that's a severe impact to
their family you know that's
could potentially alter the course of
the rest of their lives
so
it seems like
it wouldn't be
justified to
coerce or force or you know make it
difficult for someone to make that
decision for their family do you follow
yes i mean i agree that it shouldn't be
overly difficult i think what we
currently have is perfectly satisfactory
because it has a bar but the bar is but
there are exemptions
that you have things you have to do but
it's not
it's not that high a bar i mean i think
i could agree with perhaps getting rid
of the notary that would not be such a
crazy idea that could that would be
pretty clean um but i think that if
you're going to claim a medical it's it
should have some kind of documentation
if you're going to claim religious it
should be a consistent uh belief and not
something that's capricious and again
conscience subjection just means i don't
want it so i think that's a little bit
different
but the other thing i do also come back
to what i said in the testimony of the
previous bill it is critical that we do
understand and remember that the
risks of vaccines are often
wildly inflated by spouting various
numbers that are just simply reports
they are not necessarily causal and
that's why any report needs to be looked
into carefully so we do have to balance
that and that's really why we're here to
make that decision about what is the
best thing because i can only kind of
address my worries about the science
what we do as a group is why we work as
a committee and as a legislature because
one person shouldn't make that decision
thank you representative
we've heard from the bill's proponents a
proponent and
a learned expert for the other side
and now we have two things in play a
myth full of pink cards and snow coming
down
so we're going to go to our two-minute
rule
and you can do it
people caught on very well in the last
hearing
and the chair recognizes dr william
palmer from the american college of
physicians dr palmer
thank you mr chairman um my name is bill
palmer i'm a practicing hospitalist and
intern is from cornish
and i'm also the
uh governor of the new hampshire chapter
of the american college of physicians
which is a group of internists there are
611 of us in new hampshire and a 160 000
or more nationwide
we're a
group of internists which is adult
medicine
and
one of the main tenets of organization
is
using the best evidence possible to
determine
our health care
we
support immunization of all children and
adult and adults according to the
recommendations and standards
of the advisory committee on
immunization practices the national
vaccine advisory committee and the cdc
our chapter as well as the national
organization
is opposed to hb 1035 as it's counter to
our goal
of eliminating non-medical exemptions
for vaccines which i know is maybe a
little controversial but we certainly
don't want to see it expanded for the
reasons that dr knurk
has already alluded to which is that
vaccines have saved millions of lives
and we we have seen
in areas where
there are
lower vaccine rates or where groups of
people have opted not to vaccine we've
seen outbreaks of measles
and uh
we really just don't want to see it go
back that way
while
right now the the level of
of exemptions is very low um
with the current anti-vaccination um
what's the word i want movement that's
going on
we would expect to see an increasing
number of unvaccinated people it's the
number has quadrupled since about 2000
and if it keeps going at that rate
in in not that long a time we might see
a very um high rate of
unvaccinated people and increases in
diseases
and i've got 15 seconds to conclude and
so i will just conclude by saying so we
are opposed to this bill
thank you very much
we welcome back uh trisha tilley and
anne marie mercury from the department
the relative height of the chair has
nothing to do with anything
thank you again my name is patricia
tilly i'm the director of the division
of public health services at the
department of health and human services
i am aware of this very small chair and
with me i have amir mccurry who is the
chief of immunization
good afternoon chairman pearson and
members of the committee for the record
on me and marie mccary i'm the
immunization section chief of the new
hampshire department of health and human
services public health
trying to talk fast to get my two
minutes in
um so thank you very much we have
submitted this testimony um we are in
opposition of hb 1035 as this bill
proposes to loosen the new hampshire
school and child care immunization
requirements which in turn will decrease
the vaccination rates among children and
put children unnecessarily at risk
of the vaccine-preventable diseases that
cause illness disability and death
as we mentioned earlier today new
hampshire has significantly fewer
vaccines which are required compared to
other states there are 16 diseases that
are recommended by the acip which is the
advisory committee on immunization
practices and new hampshire has
immunization requirements for 10 of
those diseases
we do allow for the medical and
religious exemptions
for these
school and child care immunization
requirements
but we do feel as though we're in line
with many of the leading medical
organizations such as the american
academy of pediatrics american college
of obstetricians and gynecologists and
the american medical association
in opposition to loosening the school
requirements
and
we are also feeling as though the
department has a goal of having that
balance of individual individual choice
and public health protection we feel as
though allowing the medical exemption
excuse me allowing the religious
exemption allows for that
historically new hampshire we have
experienced a less than five percent
exemption rate we are concerned about
the potential of the expansion of the
non-medical exemptions
as indicated by other states
new idaho for instance some counties
have had a 27 percent
height of
exemption rates so that would be very
concerning for new hampshire
we feel as though 10 35 would undermine
the protection from vaccine preventable
diseases that new hampshire currently
experiences and if i could just clarify
one point that was made earlier today
the state does not receive any personal
information about individuals who submit
religious or medical exemptions schools
do report aggregate numbers to the
department
hence the privacy issues that were
discussed earlier today
are not
considered to be an issue of concern
because we have no data point on this
thank you
well done
any questions representative shapiro
yes thank you mr chairman um i was just
wondering about when you cited
statistics in idaho
um
which was a
significantly larger number of
unvaccinated children did that
did that relate at all to an expansion
of exemptions
idaho is one of those states where they
do allow the conscientious objection
overall their state is a little bit over
7 percent
however their counties specific data
do have pockets where 27
are considered to be having exemptions
and that would be highly concerning for
new hampshire
and again this um this data was seen
when we they went to the expansion to a
conscientious objection and where they
really saw that increase was incoming
kindergartners so that that is something
that we're very concerned about thank
you which seemed to be that would be
covert driven i should assume this
happened before covet
then i assume wrong thank you
did you want to follow up sir
representative gay
thank you mr chairman um this increase
in
the exemptions
what was the resulting increase or was
there an increase in the actual illness
count
we do have studies that talk about
recent outbreaks of measles pertussis in
varicella
for example in 2019 a total of 1249
measle cases and 22 measle outbreaks
were reported in the united states this
represents
the most
u.s cases in a single year and the
second highest number reported outbreaks
annually since measles were declared
elimination in u.s in 2000. follow-up
how did that cool
how do you
what was the exact result from the
places that increased the exemptions
that's not national data that has to be
specific to where the exemptions
increased
that is correct
and those studies
talk more about the
vaccination status and numbers of
children that are vaccinated it doesn't
necessarily dictate exemption or
non-exemption for states
but where we see the pockets of
outbreaks occurring are the pockets
where
the exemptions are likely to occur
because of the relationship of decreased
vaccination rates
representative folsom
thank you chairman thank you for taking
my question um
uh i'm gonna give you a scenario i love
to give scenarios everyone in here knows
this so
it's my thing um
a
a per a family
atheist
no religious
feelings whatsoever about anything
they hear that
there is something in the vaccine in the
in the makeup of it
that's associated with aborted fetal
cells
and they don't believe in abortion
they have a moral
feeling but not based on any kind of
religion
where do they fit it's not a religious
exemption
it's not a medical exemption
and i think that's where i think
that's where the
the sponsor of the bill is trying to
allow those people
um to fit in
thank you very much for that question
so you're correct um we currently have a
religious exemption and we currently
have a medical exemption and under that
religious exemption there's very little
information that's provided it's the
child's name the parent's name date of
birth and a notary signature and that's
what's provided we understand that there
are folks who
take issue with the fact that it is
called a religious exemption for the
very reasons that you've described i
think what we are concerned about is the
overall opening and widening of the door
for conscientious objections or
otherwise reducing any sort of
requirements within our schools
so that we can better protect our
concern is that we want to better
protect the health of all the children
in the in the schools i think
representative kenner did a great job of
describing this very fine balance we all
enter into especially when we're in a
place like a school of protecting our
own individual rights and the rights of
others in the school as well
representative delemus
thank you mr chairman
thank you for taking my question
so
just so you know i i'm going to give a
definition that i'm going to ask a
question an unalienable right is that
which cannot be given away or taken away
governmentally at least
and it's not given by government so
government can't take it away
and then yes we have a balance we give
up some of our rights however
article 4 which is constitutional and
that's that's our new hampshire state
constitution but i know it also exists
in the uh federal constitution
the among the natural rights natural
rights
some are
in their very na uh nature unalienable
or inalienable because no equivalent can
be given or received for them of this
kind are the rights of conscience and
now wouldn't you agree that if someone
has a conscientious objection that they
have the constitutional right to
exercise that
thank you for that question i think
again that is a decision for all of you
in this committee and our legislature to
make the concern that we have within the
department of health and human services
is protecting the public's health and we
do that under the guidance of our state
legislature and the policies that we're
given thank you very much representative
leon thank you mr chairman and thank you
for the questions i appreciate that the
department of health and human services
only gets aggregated data but when
you're speaking to that you can't speak
to what's collected in the schools or in
the department of education correct
that is correct
any other questions for the department
thank you so much for coming staying
now we will also hand out a map that we
have of all the states that have
different exemptions
i love maps
they're almost as good as scenarios
but as good as
mr chairman
i i hear my yes
this year yeah uh
from the looks of the empty chairs i
don't think there'll be
any exact exacting of there will not be
any execs so the seed fillers are
dismissed may i be excused
absolutely
[Music]
mercy
for those of you in the gallery the
chair kept calling people with very
clearly franco-american or franco names
and they insisted
on
giving american renditions
and that's certainly their right but
that that's what this little runner is
we finally brought in someone who is
monsieur gonier
the chair calls um melissa economakis
from newton
hi it's me again
um from newton way down south with me
i i just wanted to share a personal um
experience my daughter she's not a child
anymore she's 27 but she works at
starbucks
and
they were mandating vaccines at a time
and she has a history of seizure
disorder
um she had grand mal seizures growing up
um she would have to take like 10 pills
a day um it was awful and she remembers
it she
thankfully
thankfully um she
outgrew them so she's no longer has any
criminal seizures however she was
petrified to take this vaccine
because there's been
many neurological disorders
that have become affiliated from the
adverse effects from the vaccine
so she was petrified she was crying she
was really really upset
i said well get a medical exemption i
mean you you have a history of seizures
so
she reached out to her doctor her doctor
um said oh i can't give you one
and then she reached out to and she's
like oh we'll call this person so my
daughter called that person oh i don't
know why she told me to call me i can't
give you one so she reached out to her
neurologist that she used to have a
while back
no answer
so this is a thing and then there's this
other woman i don't know this woman
personally thank god the starbucks said
no more maxine mandates they um
they don't require anymore she was so
happy she didn't have to lose her job
because she's going to college as well
through them
anyway so there's another another woman
just real quick there's another woman
her husband had
got myocarditis from the first shot
and
he went to the um his doctor and asked
for a medical exemption
and his doctor would not give him one
um so
they reached they
well actually it was denied that it was
from even the vaccine just real quick it
was denied from the vaccine
so um
he he ended up finally finding a doctor
that would you know that agreed that it
was from the vaccine that causes
myocarditis
however the doctor said
my hands are tied i will be investigated
these doctors are going to be
investigated if they give any medical
exemption
and this is really really sad and that's
exactly what hap what's happening right
now
if you vote on this that they you can't
get a medical exemption
we have no backbone
[Music]
so i just i just
implore you to please
vote support this bill thank you so much
dr debra scott if you would come forward
and please tell us it doesn't give any
other information where you're from what
group are you part of
yeah this is uh
this is my first time coming before this
august body
and um
and
yeah i'm from plainfield namesake new
hampshire
and i work as a hospitalist per diem at
uh so if they need me i'm at huggins in
wolfeboro
as a hospitalist and if they um the rest
of the time i'm at alice peck day
uh working in the outpatient clinic and
also respiratory um where i get to see a
lot of
coveted positive people that are uh not
sick enough to go thank you your two
minutes start now yes okay so that's um
that's who i am and um although i'm an
internist so i mostly see people older
than 18.
i'm also a parent so i've had the whole
school
vaccination you know concern myself
and people
are
in our country
wonderfully lucky that
we actually have vaccinations
and
i just i just wanted to say my gosh
in the states where they've had pockets
like
there's a particular
religious group that is very much
against vaccines in new york and um
and that unfortunately that group also
got
quite a lot of measles and so new york
as well as five other states actually
removed the religious exemption
it's just that it's a such a wonderfully
infectious disease and
with terrible outcomes
so
um i i would really um hope that
everybody would vote against this for
the vaccines that we've been doing right
along
we've just been so
[Music]
yeah so lucky to not have the polio not
have the measles not have you know
what we would otherwise if
a number of people start dropping off
the list of those vaccinated
so that's that's it maybe i finished
challenge thank you for coming
well thank you for listening i don't
know if there's any questions but anyway
chair recognizes kate fry
100 north main street concord which is
where new futures is located
thank you thank you for providing that
information
you filled it out perfectly um good
afternoon you've been here once or twice
before once or twice yes
good afternoon um i do have written
testimony that i will leave with you um
my name is kate fry i'm the vice
president of advocacy at new futures
i'll do my best not to repeat what was
said but also hit the highlights and i
will probably speak really fast too so
uh new features support public health
policy measures that decrease illness
including immunizations and programs
that ensure equitable and broad
distribution of vaccines especially to
kids
this program new hampshire's
immunization children's immune
program does just that in new hampshire
all children through the age of 18 can
receive vaccines at no cost through an
innovative program
that
combines general funds state funds and
contributions from insurance companies
this model allows
every child to receive a vaccine free of
charge in the child immunization
schedule that has been approved at the
national level
through the acip and the american
academy of pediatrics
i say this because it's again an
innovative program that many states have
replicated and it's a cost-saving
measure as well too
as you know this is not about cova this
is really about our childhood
vaccination program and weakening that
program by adding a vaccination adding a
philosophical vaccination um not only
would there be
cost there's a huge cost savings when we
talk about vaccinations um and i have
some information in my testimony about
how much money you save uh with every
round of childhood vaccines
again we have very high rates of
vaccination rates in the state um a very
low exemption rate at this point but the
fear is once you add an easy opt out
that we've talked about
it will impact
the greater number of folks who sent
their kids to school unvaccinated
public health achievements such as
vaccines are often a victim of their own
success because
vaccines many of us have never seen
polio tetanus all the diseases you've
heard
and it also protects a broader
population because they build a
protective firewall around us by
increasing immunity and protecting those
who can't get vaccinated including
infants and children and adults with
weakened immune system
um so i think i sped through it but i am
leaving you with my testimony um
information about um some outbreaks um
that happened after a result of um a
widening of the exemptions and since you
like maps i'm bringing you the same map
probably that trisha telly
thank you so much you're always welcome
here
while these are going around the chair
calls dr claire o'grady from barnstead
new hampshire and let us know what kind
of a doctor are you i asked my wife that
and she says i'm a good one thank you
i am a good one but i'm a family
medicine physician
excellent and master of public health
and i am from barnstead new hampshire
um and i'm testifying in opposition of
house bill 1035.
um
as many people have already pointed out
since the mid-1800s the u.s school
system has done quite a bit to improve
american children's health including
introducing physical education classes
reviewing fire safety but also being a
place
where vaccination mandates occurred
first with our neighbor in the south
massachusetts
um we've learned a lot from these school
vaccination mandates and the subsequent
supreme court cases revolving around
them including jacobson versus
massachusetts and zucked versus king
in both of these cases where individuals
challenge the vaccination mandates due
to perceived oppression
against their personal liberties it was
deemed that quote every well-ordered
society charged with the duty of
conserving the safety of its members
must understand that an individual's
liberty does not outweigh the protection
of public health and safety in the face
of great danger such as a pandemic or a
deadly illness
ultimately in both cases the court held
that mandatory vaccinations are neither
arbitrary nor oppressive so long as they
meet several conditions
there are three of them
one that there's a grave threat to the
public without vaccination two that
vaccines mandated are safe and effective
and three that mandatory vaccination has
superior cost-benefit profile
in the written testimony that i'll give
to you guys i'll outline on how our
current vaccines meet all three criteria
our school vaccine mandates do meet
these three conditions our current
school vaccinations are not oppressive
nor are they unconstitutional what would
be oppressive and unconstitutional is
allowing conscientious objection
exemptions or personal opinions
to trump the safety of our children
school of action and school vaccination
mandates are largely associated with
increased vaccine coverage by
introducing this alternative exemption
new hampshire is permitting a decrease
in the rate of vaccine coverage a
fracture in our herd community and an
increased risk for infections and death
i ask that you guys oppose house bill
1035 at least for now we are in the
middle of a pandemic health care workers
including myself are extremely exhausted
and subjecting us to the horrors of
influx of children sick with vaccine
preventable illnesses is more than any
of us can take right now thank you
doctor appreciate your coming
chair recognizes dr christine asnow from
the
new hampshire american academy of
pediatrics
where do you live i mean not your
strengths i live in new london new
london yes i work in concord though
um good afternoon where did you say you
worked concord conquered what kind of a
doctor i'm a pediatrician yeah okay
thank you of course that's why you're
part of the american academy of
pediatrics they don't let up they don't
let just anyone in thank you very much
go on hi
my name is dr christine arsnow
i am the vice president of the new
hampshire chapter of the american
academy of pediatrics i'm speaking today
on behalf of that society as well as the
new hampshire medical society which
represents physicians from across all
disciplines
i am also and perhaps most importantly a
mother
from all these perspectives i strongly
encourage you
to vote no on house bill 1035
this bill
passing this bill
would be reckless and really
shows disregard for history
and science as many of the previous
speakers have mentioned
this bill would bring our public schools
back to
the
state of decades even centuries ago when
these vaccine preventable illnesses ran
rampant
um
i will um
try to speed through and i'm echoing
some of the points that others have had
but part of the problem here is that
these vaccines are so effective that
many of us have never seen these
diseases you know i think polio is such
a good example i can't imagine being a
parent in the 1940s and worrying about
my child waking up
paralyzed
and and so when the polio vaccine was
introduced in the 1950s that was very
well accepted and adopted parents were
so grateful because they saw that threat
every day we don't you know i've never
seen a child with measles and i'm a
pediatrician um but
i think you know it's important to
believe the scientific and historical
accounts of these diseases just as i
have never been to mount everest than
believe scientific accounts of
the climate there
some of the
symptoms of these illnesses all gloss
over because i think they have been you
know it's been hammered home that these
illnesses are deadly and that the risks
of these illnesses are much greater than
the risks of the vaccines against them
it's been
so i will just end by saying
children
sending parents have the right to choose
not to vaccinate their children that is
their right if they choose to take those
risks absolutely they are welcome to do
that i will recommend that they
vaccinate their children but they have
that right they do not have the right to
then send their children to school with
other children who may have leukemia and
be unable to be vaccinated
putting all those children and teachers
at risk is
in my opinion more of a rights violation
i strongly urge you to
oppose house bill 1035 thank you thank
you doctor the chair calls gary
york from hopkinton new hampshire
is that dr gary york thank you yes i
thought so yes you didn't you left it
off i'm not a pediatrician well neither
am i no but i have a doctorate as well
i must admit i'm not a little confused
with all the legislation that's going
around
i looked at this bill and
if i'll it follow on the heels of the
bill that we heard presented recently
and it it left me uh at sea to be honest
because
the previous bill
was
put forth to require
a
copy 19 vaccine in the school system
so in the main i don't have any issues
with the currently required
vaccines for attendance
i have deep concerns about the schedule
of those vaccines but nonetheless
i looked at this bill and
i'm thinking if the previous bill is
passed
that we heard about copen 19
and i think you all know the passion i
have about testifying for
the
mandates and vaccines
how would that even uh
come into play here it would seem that
then um
suppose that the 19 vaccine is rushed
through like so much of
the cobin 19 stuff and it became
available fda approved
i don't feel there's been a lot of
safety data on that vaccine
so i guess um as i say i'm not against
the historic uh required vaccines but
i'm just trying to cover the bases
because as a citizen i'm confused by all
the overlap of some of these bills and i
uh i just i'm i like the part that says
let's just say that
a vaccine for covet is required say
within six months
uh i don't think any of my
children
if they were of school age would have
the religious exemption or the medic
medical exemption
but
having a conscientious objection
allows for someone to
declare a long-held
personal belief that is sincere
and i think you have to honor that
so um
i'm up here kind of befuddled and
i'm just showing you
my crazy mind spinning around
i'm sorry
that's quite all right the only
difference is we have the same but we
hide it
chair recognizes paula mckinnon comes
back to us new hampshire school nurse
association
from the great town of salem
thank you chairman
uh i am paula mckinnon i have been a
school nurse for 27 years and a nurse
for 30 years
and school nurses are the
entity that actually
implements the law when it comes to
vaccine mandates the legislature has
already said that the schools have the
power to exclude children from school
if they don't have the required vaccines
and that is the way if you choose to use
the word coerce that is the way we get
people to comply with the law
now i do have written testimony i'm
going to skip over most of it and get to
some points that i'd like to make
there has been
testimony or comments made
that the information that's given to the
school as to your
reason for a medical
exemption then gets passed on to
government agencies and i can say with
100 percent certainty that that is not
the case
uh the school law ferpa which is the
release of information from schools
would
strictly prohibit that
and while the school nurse has knowledge
of these
people and their
medical exemptions it stops there it's
not reported to teachers it's not
reported to the state it is recorded
nowhere except in the child's own health
record as i'm sure it also is at the
doctor's office
if i could speak for a moment
about you've got about half a minute to
go oh great okay
i'm going to give you in my testimony uh
there are ten different medical
organizations that in 2019
did studies on the
elimination of non-medical exemptions
i'll give you that for your reading
pleasure later on today
i would also like to state that
sometimes there's unintended
consequences from from laws that are
passed and
if
we want our children to be back full
time and in person
for all of the vaccine-mandated diseases
if they currently are not
vaccinated and let's just throw it out
there what if measles came into new
hampshire and in my school i've got 10
children that are not vaccinated against
measles wrap it up 15 seconds one of
them brought measles into the school
community unintended consequences of
those 10 that are unvaccinated are
required by law to stay home so that we
can
not proliferate the
the
disease being spread further thank you
so much for your testimony we appreciate
it we wish we had a lot longer but we
don't
the chair next recognizes dr jennifer
jones who's going to tell us
where she's from
uh
what her specialty is
in medicine thank you mr chairman my
name is dr jennifer jones i'm a
pediatrician i work for core pediatric
and adolescent medicine where i serve as
the medical director it's the large
pediatric group that is associated with
exeter hospital
i had some prepared testimony but given
that there's two minutes and we've had a
lot of good testimony already um i think
instead what i'd like to do is respond
to some um concepts that have been
brought forward
specifically i'd like to talk about a
medical exemption
i grant medical exemptions for vaccines
not only do i grant them i suggest them
because medically it is the right thing
to do
some children meet medical criteria that
they should not be vaccinated for
certain vaccines
and it is not controversial it is not
based on my personal feelings it's based
on scientific uh guidelines for which
types of children should avoid
vaccination
uh i don't worry about being
investigated or
getting in trouble for giving vaccine
mandates because medically i'm providing
appropriate evidence-based care
the time i might be worried about being
investigated is if i provided a false
medical exemption which i would not do
i also would like to comment on the idea
of people who choose alternative healthy
lifestyles i think that's wonderful
and
certainly promotes general health
does not however provide antibodies in
your body against infectious diseases
there really are no alternatives to
vaccinations to protect you against
particular diseases
in terms of the idea of inalienable
rights i've been thinking about that
while sitting in this room and um
it's it's very clear that all parents
have the right as dr arsenal mentioned
to decline vaccines
parents decline vaccines in my office
all the time
and we talk about it we talk about the
risks and benefits we talk about their
concerns their fears their worries
and um of course they have that
inalienable right i cannot hold their
child down and give them a vaccine
against their consent
i think that is separate from the idea
of whether they can participate in
school as part of society and so those
are just some of my thoughts on the idea
of inalienable rights
in terms of
the covid vaccine that's not what this
bill is about this bill has nothing to
do with the coveted vaccine
this bill is about
established science on vaccines that
have been part of routine pediatric care
for decades
and i think some of the discussion about
kovid is a distraction from this bill i
urge this committee to vote against this
bill thank you i want to question if um
i'll try to word it more graciously
i think i have a different understanding
of the bill
then it's not about cobit if it is about
vaccinations doesn't it include covid
with the others it's not solely about
covert but it includes it does it not mr
chairman i don't believe that it
pertains to covet as coveted vaccine is
not currently mandated in the state of
new hampshire and this bill my
understanding is refers to the current
law
and the nine vaccinations that are
required for children plus one
additional for preschool children covet
is not included on that list i thank you
for your clarification i think you're
correct thank you
and thank you for your testimony
chair recognizes laura condon from
bedford
good afternoon my name is laura condon
i'm from bedford i'm the new hampshire
director of advocacy with the national
vaccine information center
would you believe
that
that i served for five years as public
member on the new hampshire vaccine
association board um so i know it pretty
well would you believe that the
department spends about 30 million
dollars every year on child vaccines
would you believe that 40 74
of those 30 million vaccine purchases
are received by parents on a voluntary
basis
74 percent of vaccines in new hampshire
received in a voluntary basis no
mandates no exemptions required parents
are willingly getting 47 percent of the
vaccines that the state purchases
and um although the the state did
report that during the pandemic vaccine
use is down about 60 percent based on
vaccine ordering and we've seen
absolutely zero outbreaks of any
childhood diseases
parents know their children's best um
they love their children more than
anyone else it really should be a
parent's right to to decide there's been
talk here about nine or ten vaccines for
children let's be clear there are 35
doses of vaccines required for children
in daycare and schools in new hampshire
many of these vaccines for illnesses
that are non-communicable in a classroom
setting such as hepatitis b many of
these vaccines do not prevent illness or
spread pertussis vaccine is one example
only reducing symptoms to that of a cold
resulting in greater spread other
vaccines fail to provide immunity mumps
for example as thousands of cases of
mump occur every year and fully
vaccinated college students
children do not have a vaccine
deficiency that needs to be addressed
they have
immune systems that work just fine and
on our advanced living conditions
including indoor plumbing child labor
laws have been instituted um we don't
spray ddt the paralyzing agent on
children anymore good thing um
that um there's been much that have been
changed when you look at the history
there there's a lot to be changed
parents are increasingly bullied at
doctor's office to submit a vaccination
those parents come to me 15 seconds i
had one such parent that we actually had
to file a police report she was so
bullied by her national pediatrician
i i urge you to
no joke um i urge you that here we are
in a free state and a free nation we
respect the rights and responsibility of
parents to make medical decisions in the
best interest of their own children i
urge you to vote this bill is ought to
pass thank you and the chair now calls
on um
russon chester
i almost had the town wrong
right
last name kind of messes everyone up
thank you committee chair thank you
committee members i'm going to be brief
um yay
the bottom line is is that i listened to
a lot of folks today
and they talked about the importance of
school systems done a lot of good first
with neighbor
in the south massachusetts what makes uh
what makes the it good is if
if a vaccine if a vaccine can help
prevent great threat
safe if it's safe and effective
and it's cost benefit profile
so
when a parent's child
is damaged
from a vaccine injury
can we use that
is that okay is it okay to say yes but
cost benefit says it was worth it to
have your child hurt
that's not okay one child we see it on
our highways one death is too many
why isn't one vaccine injury too many
our children have been dying for years
from vaccine injuries or have been
deliberately
injured well not deliberately less
necessarily but they've been but i was
talking to laura condon and
she shocked me with some of the
statistics that's been going on with our
children the only reason why it's a big
deal now which i'm ashamed of is because
it's affected the adults and that's
that's terrible
the other reason why it's become
[Music]
common knowledge is because this whole
coven 19 pandemic has opened a lot of
eyes
it's opened a lot of eyes and a lot of
hearts and i thank the lord for that but
at the same time
with
because it we're responsible
bottom line is we are responsible for
the wealth health and well-being of our
children did you know that the amish
population has the lowest coven 19
um
any kind of cova they must all be
well they're not vaccinated so they must
all be non whatever um
with regards to mean second okay
with regards to polio would you believe
that i was approached by a
representative in this room that says i
have polio careful no no no that i i was
i was inflicted with polio however i
truly believe that the problem was is
that i we used to go through the most
mosquito
um smoke
and i'm convinced that my polio was
caused because i already had natural
immunity thank you so much for your
testimony
thank you
um just one final thing the uh prime
sponsor
has indicated he's willing to be
flexible some of that could go back to
when he had to exercise
but he is flexible on the bill and you
know we like to get this as many bills
as we can on to consent out of this
committee it's not always possible to
square the circle but we like to try
and i am wondering we don't have to do
it but i'd like to give the opportunity
as i always do that if there's one or
two people who would like to work with
the representative the prime sponsor on
maybe making the bill
acceptable to them without it becoming
unacceptable to you
the chair would be very happy to do that
so or do we have a few people on this
side of the playground okay
representative nada upham
and i think i saw representative cushman
one or two more from
doctors row okay
and representative canarik
and if the three of you would work
with
the honorable gentleman from fish and
game um this is not an early bill
uh it has to be out the door the middle
of march so if you would do that
it sounds good to me
what's that
you would like to be on that too okay
fine thank you so with that this closes
the hearing on house bill 1035 a couple
of business items i am learning not to
say housekeeping matters um
a couple of business items here for the
committee we will exec tomorrow all the
bills that are in the calendar because
they have to be
and if you have an amendment that's
coming in tomorrow
it has to be coming in tomorrow
if they're
bogged down downstairs we can push the
bill to the early afternoon but we got
to get it done tomorrow
asked for your attention please
um also just for the republicans in the
room we have a caucus at 8 45 tomorrow
we're going to be looking over uh the
bills for tomorrow that we hadn't
already
with that drive safely stay well
don't let the bedbugs bite we're done
i agree
let me speak to the representative
briefly
like i said i now stay with a friend
when i'm overnight
you